this is jocko podcast number 318 with
echo charles and me jocko willink good
evening echo good evening
the
native americans believed
that if you gave someone a diagnosis
it was a curse
it was a curse that can become an
identity
if you accept it
but a rewiring can happen
when you realize that you are the one
creating your own experience
this is a
long and truthful conversation with
yourself
how can we learn and evolve
from our successes
and our failures
where do we need to change
how can a person
find
solace and sovereignty
in the face of experience that has been
shaped by such pressure
immense hardship bad choices chemical
manipulation digital stimulation and
sophisticated programming that teaches
you to kill
when the
antiquated ways fail
and repeat the same answers and produce
the same results
it's time to take charge of change
you are not the victim of this life but
rather the victim of your own choices
truth is found within oneself but to get
to that truth you have to peel back the
layers to who you are
it's self work and self knowing that
creates
profound change
today we have an addiction problem we
are addicted to other people's ideas
we become
the victim of our experience
we take magic pills or become convinced
by false prophets as to what will fix us
or make us happy
we just want to
relieve hurt
and make it go away
but running from pain only magnifies the
pain
we are born to honor what is good while
striving for our highest self
you have to be open to everything
enclosed to nothing the heat the cold
your weaknesses failures and successes
your loss
and your regrets face them
face yourself
this is the most important and difficult
battle you have ever been in
alexander the great once said
bury me with my hands out of the ground
so the world can see that i left it with
nothing
that is the plan
you change your own life
from within
always from within never outside
it's one hundred percent in you
life is not here to punish us
but is here to help us grow in wisdom
and knowledge and to ensure we never
again
are a victim of life
the time is
now
and that is a
compilation of words
that i put together that were
written by or spoken by or implied by
a man by the name of micah
fink
and i think you're going to see that
through
his path in life
in boyhood and business and war and
combat and service and sacrifice
it's allowed him to learn some valuable
lessons
and his goal is to teach those lessons
or if not the lessons themselves then at
least teach other people how to learn
those lessons how to rewire themselves
to be
who you want to be
to be who you can be
and we are
lucky enough to have micah with us here
tonight
to share some of those lessons
so micah
thanks for coming by man
thanks buddy
man that was intense
yeah that was awesome yeah
you've got a bunch of clips out and and
stuff that you've written on your
website and i just pulled
from some of it and watched some of your
videos and pulled from some of that
to try and give people a feel for sort
of where you're at
but in order to get to where you're at i
guess we
we start at the beginning yeah where
have you been yeah
where have you been
so
where'd it all start man
you know uh
i uh i kind of always started like yeah
i was just a small town kid from upstate
new york and
i laughed because if you would have told
me when i was a kid that i would be
doing the things that i'm doing today i
would have
i probably would have hit you over the
head with a frying pan
i just uh i feel really fortunate to uh
you know to now be in a place where i
can i can take the experiences in my
life that
at a point did break me down um and and
and now kind of uh show people that
those experiences are the greatest ally
that they have and this journey of
self-discovery uh that we're all on
and uh you know i grew up my dad you
know i grew up
tough family you know uh
my dad was uh
you know seven brothers and sisters and
uh grandfather was a mob mob guy and uh
so he was in federal prison you know for
10 years and
uh were you alive then no
no i was so this is before you were born
yes before i was born and but and
he had a tough life and so he grew up as
an orphan on the streets and this is
your dad my dad my grandfather who i was
super close to he died when i was 16.
and uh
i was i was really close to him he was a
he was a hard man and uh he grew up as
an orphan and
um and ended up turning his life around
i guess you could say much later in his
life became the head of the railroad
union and
you know
my dad always tells the story when when
their life kind of started straightening
out and
fast forward a little bit my my dad said
they used to go back he was a
engineer in the railroad
and uh he said he used to go back in the
caboose my grandfather be running all
these card games you know
hustling and doing this and that and
my dad would come back and say bye
what are you doing back here i thought
you were a christian and he's like you
can't gamble and he's like well with me
it's a sure thing so it's not gambling
because he was a card counter he could
count cards but uh you know so it's like
real blue collar family railroad family
and uh
you know my dad my dad grew up in that
kind of life so my grandfather's pretty
severe guy so did your dad grow did your
grandfather live in
also an upstate or was he down in the
city so he was upstate he was in the
city and then and then family moved
upstate new york and then uh
mother and father died alcoholism and
then i think nine nine of the brothers
and sisters were street kids basically
they were orphans and then my
grandfather kept escaping and
um
matter of fact he broke his leg as an
orphan was taken back to the home had to
get surgery and
you want to talk about having a rough
they circumcised them he was 10. the doc
yeah there's an orphan kid so they
brought him in there they're just like
yeah i'll give a little snip but uh yeah
so it was a it was a interesting kind of
upbringing because my dad grew up and he
he went to the 82nd airborne i always
either go to go to prison or go to
vietnam type deal
and um
my dad was a really really rough guy
like
he's the epitome of a tough guy
like a real tough like a violent tough
guy
and uh he wound up in prison and he ran
up in lemonworth and uh
and what what was this before you were
born was this yeah this is so this was
before i was born so my mom and dad have
been together since 15 or 16. my dad had
to join the military
um did he go to vietnam well he was
supposed to go to vietnam but then he
wound up going to prison
um which vietnam might have been better
but uh
yeah he uh he never had that balance in
his life you know and
um you know it's interesting my mom and
dad i think 56 years or something
they've been together um
but yeah my dad went to leavenworth and
uh he got in some trouble in the
military of course and he was riding
with all the biker gangs stuff like that
and i mean he doesn't
every tooth in my dad's head's been
punched out he's got 100 something
stitches across his head and
you know he kind of just
he had a rough and he hit rock bottom
and he got out he ended up uh becoming a
christian and then i was so he so his
prison time was in the military yeah he
went to leavenworth yep yeah
yeah so he went to leavenworth and uh
how long was he in leavenworth for a
couple years
and then after that it was whatever
dishonorable discharge most likely yeah
and then
and then he got out and he just uh
like took a bus back basically so he
owed he owed a bunch of money to uh
like the hell's angels and those kind of
guys so they like took everything when
he went to prison robbed him blind
basically and uh so we got out with
nothing and you know when i was a kid
like my christmases were spent like in
the city missions you know every single
christmas we were in the slums and the
hoods we had people at my house like
straight out of prison and like
my daddy's always telling me i was a kid
he's like you know why i come here he
said i come here because i never want to
forget where i came from
and my mom said that when my dad when
she met him he had a van 56 panel van
that said no hope without dope you can
never figure why i figure figure out why
i'm getting pulled over all the time but
like so he was you know he was a he was
a rough guy and a matter of fact
i know because as a kid people would
come up to my dad they wouldn't believe
that you know it was him
and he was he was he was a violent human
being
and the kind of person has nothing to
lose and he was tough and he was a boxer
and he was a street fighter and
um
so yeah so my dad gets out and he ends
up becoming walking down the street like
lowest point of his life and he sees
like the windows open in a church and
lights on and he decides he's gonna walk
in there and he sits in the back zz top
looking guy if you look at the pictures
he's got the huge beard with the you
know the jacket with 87 patches on it
you know rats and stuff
and uh tattoos he had like jesus smoking
pot in his arm
and he had all kinds of crazy stuff and
uh
he uh
he has an experience like in that church
and nobody talked to him like nobody
would even come up to him they just
looked at him like whoa this is a scary
guy and
he turned his life around right there in
that moment
and uh so i was born in 79 my sister was
born to 77
and my dad
had to figure out how to put his life
together so my grandfather got him
hooked up on the railroad and i ended up
becoming an engineer
and uh working on the railroad through
until i was in second grade and then he
started a church in a really rural town
of 600 people
so we were we were real poor when i grew
up uh we all lived in the same bedroom
so how many brothers and sisters were
one sister just just the one sister just
the one sister yeah and this is still in
upstate new york yeah and then they
started doing the tent revivals so when
i was a kid i always tell people i'm
like listen i at the time i had become
uh and i'm not a religious guy like but
i had become i would get saved like
pretty much three to four times a week
i've been i've been saved more than any
human being in north america because you
would hear these guys and they would
start preaching you know the crescendo
would build and the worms and the hell
and then i'm like god i'm like you know
i've been kind of i'm touching my penis
or something i'm like i should i'm gonna
that would just be my hand up and then
i was like i moved my way up to the
blanket guy where i when the people
would fall down i would rush in with a
little blanket and laid over them
which a lot of them are faking because
i was like man these people kind of just
fall down like before they even get up
there sometimes they would just they
would get over the tower or whatever so
i'd have these little blankets you know
i'm like seven or eight years old i'd
run up the blanket and i'd always like
step on their finger
and they'd be like hey
so then i was like i started questioning
things
i really i really did start questioning
things or sometimes they'd push you down
on the ground but that was a crazy
experience you know we traveled all
around was that all around the country
you travel or just upstate new york okay
upstate new york you know so it was a i
remember the 80s it was kind of a wild
time for that kind of stuff that people
get the
laughing spells and like you know there
was all these kind of things going on
and
so i ended up uh
i ended up leaving home at 16 so
and i lived on my own from then on and
where did you move to
i kind of moved around the country uh
and uh
yeah so i ended up uh
moving uh down to south florida and uh
getting a job down there and working and
what were you doing in south florida uh
my grandmother lived down there
and i lived uh
i was homeless for a little while i was
almost for some months down there and uh
i'd gotten you know i'd gotten in some
trouble i was also a very rough
kid as you could imagine i
the thing about that whole movement
looking back now retrospectively is
is the guilt and the fear and all the
things that are associated with that
world movement the movement you had a
revival movement and all that kind of
stuff and it was never about love you
know and i mean to me like
that loving yourself and not judging
yourself and all those kind of things it
wasn't associated with that at the time
and so as soon as i got old enough you
know around 15 i uh well i started
working at 10
and
yeah i had my first job on a dairy farm
and then
by time i was 14 years old i was working
35 40 hours a week sometimes
and
that was kind of my life were you going
to school yeah i was going to school so
i get off school sometimes i worked at
10 o'clock at night i'd work all the
weekends work sunday afternoons
um and then i started working for a
family as a lineman first i was like
pick up the sticks guy you know i'd run
around and move the trucks and do all
these things and then um slowly anything
you get off the dairy i don't really
drink milk because of that
[Music]
milk is a disturbing product
like
it is
just sorry like new horizon organics or
whatever but
it's nasty like it's a nasty thing you
know like and my job was to clean the
udders and stick these little suckers
onto there and you know like these old
bags kicking you in and
on you and it's the worst thing
and then the milk goes in there and
there's the flies and the cat's licking
it up everywhere
and then these things got to be like
constantly you know kept pregnant you
know so they're like in this perpetual
state of pregnancy to get him to keep
lactating you know
and the only thing i wanted to do is
just get the hell away from it so
yeah i ended up uh ended up becoming
alignment so i learned how to do line
work be started climbing telephone poles
when i was 13
and uh i started making like good money
doing that so
um i didn't do that down in florida i
did a bunch of other things and then uh
i sounded like fun
oh yeah yeah that was a really really
rough time in my life uh matter of fact
we were just down in florida and i was
driving through some of the areas i used
to live in
i could remember being so hungry like
going in the grocery store and just
living like
just like grabbing like food and just
like seeing like the big fat security
guy like just looking at me like
and i would do the whole kind of like
julio jones like you know and
usually i'd make it out with like
one-tenth of what i had
like and i remember this particular
package of sausage that i had
um
who are you hanging around with what was
that was going on
uh i ended up uh i had met some guys
when i was younger and uh that were kind
of passing through they were like street
guys
and passing through upstate new york
yeah
they were like selling and you know
kind of rough crew and so i actually
showed up at their house
in florida yeah and i was you know i was
in some
i was in some pretty big trouble at the
time and um
i uh
i was on my i wasn't living at home at
all anyway and so i moved down there and
i stayed down there until i was
and and then i moved back home i had
like 30 grand on me and a car and all
kinds of stuff and i moved back home
with a
with a stripper girlfriend i got that
out of my system so when i got the
stripper in the teams i was like boys
i was there when i was 17. don't do it
and
yeah so i you know i moved back home my
life was kind of like in a tailspin
honestly i you know i had money at
things and
i had a real hard chip on my shoulder
and
i just uh
you know i had kind of become like my
father i guess in a sense where i was i
could be violent i was pissed off i was
just angry
once your dad found like god was he
still pissed off and angry
no but inversely he was really hard
he was a hard man
like hard you know
i didn't i never looked at god as like
god is love and he wants to like care
for us and jesus with the lamb and stuff
you're like old testament god old
testament god like like i'm gonna take
the stab those are the stories i heard
you know like the ones you never hear
you only hear like jesus just loves
everybody like and then if you don't
listen to him like worms are going to
come suck your brains out you're going
to burn it now and by the way like i
mean i mean it was like that that was
the was the revival days it was the fire
and brimstone and so
um
i was afraid of it to be honest and i um
i didn't i didn't like the whole thing i
didn't like the hypocrisy and that whole
movement and stuff and so as soon as i
got old enough you know i had a bunch of
money i had worked my whole life that's
what i did i put my head down and i
worked i worked really hard and
that's kind of all i knew i was
excessive compulsive worker and
you know when i left i was on my own i
had like i had no like balance in my
life
so
yeah
i moved back home i started doing line
work again and actually a big turning
point for me was that i uh
um i went on a backpacking trip by
myself and i ended up kind of having
this experience out there with a bear it
was like a little black bear or whatever
and i kind of just started like thinking
about my whole life and and
how i just wasn't ready to die i wasn't
ready to
that there was something else missing
and i walked out of there and i
literally after that moment i kind of
changed my whole life it was nothing
religious
where was where were you out in the
adirondacks
yeah kind of where i grew up going to
all the time
and so uh
yeah so i ended up getting back on the
line crew climbing telephone poles again
and i look back like when i was a
teenager working on these line crews i
would spend the summers living in new
york city and i was living with grown
men that were shooting heroin and you
know living in these they would put me
up in these hotels and
i would live in these with these guys
that were like
vagrants you know they were they were
like they would travel from city to city
on these huge contracts and i would be
down there for the week and
um
yeah that was a that was tough you know
because i was a kid matter of fact
i remember there was a guy i'll never
forget him i won't say his name he's
probably dead now but he was like six
foot eight he was the scariest guy who's
from long island okay his brother was
another gigantic dude and they were the
hairiest people like i've ever seen in
my life okay i've never seen men that
hairy in my life until i met you and
then um these guys were like these guys
are like lebanese butchers like
and they had the deepest voices and
i get put on a splicing crew with this
guy and i remember i'm you know
i'm 16. it's right before i left i'm
living in the city i'm living with all
these guys and of course they would
never give me a bed i'd be in the corner
my little like sleeping bag you know and
they'd be doing their things
and uh
i remember this guy would never talk to
me and he would always flick his
cigarettes at me
and he was just constantly smoking pot
all right and you're 16 at this point
yeah yeah
and uh so
i'm down there with this guy and i'm
like he has a van like a white like
murderer van filled with all his cable
stuff and his head like touches the
ceilings in it and you'd always be like
he always called me loser or fake
or whatever like any name except for my
name he would call me he had the deepest
voice he's covered in hair
and i remember we're in long island and
i mean most kids are like playing like
basketball and they're out there like
trying to like you know make out with
their girlfriend like high school prom
like
i'm there with this dude jim and
i remember we're in long island i'm like
setting the cones up or whatever and and
i'm not doing it fast enough or good
enough everything's getting paid by the
units
and
i remember he like he's in the bucket
above and he just looks at me and he
starts swearing at me and he takes like
a bolt and he throws it down he hits me
in the side of the head within my heart
had it like i mean it rang my belt
freaking dude had a wing on him too
so he just like whips it down it's like
boom like and i like remember i like
rocked back and i like i went around the
side of the truck and i started like
kind of crying i was
like so then i like i just snapped and
so i started like taking all the cones i
started screaming and throwing them into
the road and cars like laying on their
horns this is in new york and i'm like
and then i run over and grab the
emergency controls in the bucket
and i'm like
and he's like flopping and shit's coming
everywhere and he's screaming i'm going
over you
and i'm like crying i'm like
like i'm pushing all the tools under the
ground i'm throwing everything
everywhere i'm kicking the truck i'm
going crazy so finally after like 30
seconds of going crazy on the controls i
can see is like this dude's gonna murder
me
so he just like stands up when i stop
and he's like you're dead
you're dead he says to me
and i'm like so i just grab a huge pipe
off the thing and i'm like and i'm out
in the road and i'm just bawling my eyes
out like come on jack i'm on like
screaming and he's like
he's like coming down his little bucket
out i'm the tears and people are laying
on their horns and shit's everywhere
and he looked at me and he's like
he gets down like just like out of reach
from me and i'm hitting the truck on my
yard dad like and he probably would have
killed me
and then he just like looked at me
he's like
and he went back up he made a good
decision and i was like
so then he's like pick up everything you
piece of he says to me like and so
i'm out there picking everything up and
sure enough like i got to live in the
house with the guy so i like you know i
go back the week's over and of course we
go back up you know
it was like nothing happened you know
and i would ride back up there and he
would just be like smoking like joint
after joint listening to the led
zeppelin he would like look at me and
get done you go
and he like flicking at me and like hit
my pants and i'd brush it off and he'd
be like
and he'd like he's like keep driving so
i mean that was kind of like
you know i always like joke about like
when i got in the military like
i was already kind of like a
i wasn't afraid of much at that point
like in the sense of like
i just had i had had a lot of
experiences you know i'd grown up on my
own and grown up you know pretty rough
and so
um i end up starting my own line crew
and hiring some of my
delinquent friends that i grew up with
you know and
and i happened to be uh in queens new
york and at this point i really did turn
my life around
and i'm in queens new york uh when the
first plane hit the world trade center
so
september 11th i go to the yards in long
island pick up all my equipment we used
to store everything in these huge
yards just outside the city
and um i'm gonna get some of this here i
got
i need some like juice
and uh i could uh get all the stuff
loaded up and i got we used to just go
down there and be dudes standing on the
street and i always give them cash
so i'd be like who needs to who needs a
job you know like who's got a driver's
license i'm like all right 100 bucks get
in and we'd hire like a ground guy
and um
i was making big money at the time and i
bought myself like an audi which i did
not advise uh wait what was there
something wrong with the audience well i
mean i didn't realize that when it broke
i could afford to fix it like that that
was like and they do break who are your
friends that you were hanging out with
who are these dudes
so like i only really kind of ever had
like the same friends kind of growing up
so the same crew from catskill yeah move
down with you
uh the guy yeah so they would work with
me during the week we'd live down there
and on the weekends they'd go home so
we'd leave sunday night at like three
o'clock in the morning or whatever and
then we'd be there to work monday and
then we had a place that we'd rent and
we'd live down there work all week and
then come back up weren't you in a band
or something too yeah yeah i played it
in a funk skyband shout out to funkshop
loomis i think everyone's probably dead
in that band
but uh and were you guys playing gigs
back then yeah so we were playing gigs
back then so i ended up uh man i wish i
had a
my wife has a great picture
of me at the house with my band i had
platinum blonde hair and like my ears
pierced and they're like stretched out
and i got the
whole thing huh oh yeah so this is like
nice so this is
i started playing drums as a kid in
church as a you know and playing that
gospel music you know so when you
weren't covering you got all the like
blankets
so it's all those kind of like old
gospel chops and uh and so i started
playing drums when i was eight and um
you know i wasn't like that we ended up
kind of moving out of being you know
really poor and
and um
you know kind of got to like i guess you
could say like i guess what would be
considered middle class or whatever you
know yeah because your dad had a legit
job but then the railroad yeah but he
left the railroad and that's when we
kind of went down because god was gonna
pay us
jack
yeah and so you guys were gigging you
were in a gigging band gigging band yeah
we actually uh the band funk shot bloom
is opened up for long beach double
all-stars um
bro yeah i actually have a dem we
actually have a demo cd we had a song um
called single man
and uh
tv dinner's always the same cause i'm a
single man
one night stands are calling my name
because i'm a single man so it was uh
yeah we were kind of a jam band and funk
ska band and i like that kind of chops i
like gospel music like you know that's
kind of what i grew up with and um guys
like dave weckel and ginger birch and
uh you know so i was really actually
thought i was gonna become a
professional drummer that was like what
i was really aspiring at the time to be
um
and
i probably would have been had i stayed
on the trajectory had 9 11 not happen um
i mean i was uh getting i just gotten
sponsored by evan's drum heads jd adario
um
so i was i was getting pretty like
serious and i probably wouldn't have
stayed with that band forever would have
moved up you know you know to various
bands and
you know selling out your band before
you even made it bro
look at you yeah
yeah i would have moved up from loomis
funk
[Music]
yeah music guy it definitely gets people
well scott is like the fact that you
were playing ska music is
is it's a well it's a particular style
of playing too it's a lot of like odd
time signatures you know like
um and so it's it's and funk and gospel
and all that kind of stuff has a similar
foundations you know it's all based off
of kind of like jazz you know
so that's what i did you know and i
played a lot of like christian music and
i was like jesus rock um and let me tell
you something you get the youth group
girls when you're like jesus rockstar
you totally do
you're playing like at the huge youth
camps and stuff you know you're like
you're the guy you're driving the beats
you know
we love the lord but you know what's
your name christian youth camp
attendance just went down by 80 for
young girls by the way don't go there
i'll never send my kids there it's the
worst you know
back of the van
so
so all that's kind of where you're at
you're busting your ass working you're
playing music
and
making money enough money to buy an audi
that you really can't afford to fix but
still you got the audi yeah and then
september 11th comes yeah september 11
came and i had never like you know
thought about joining the military
anything like that where were you on
september 11 because you're in the city
so i was in queens new york yeah i was
on a telephone bowl when it happened uh
so i was on a railroad pole at the time
my job was to send a so time warner was
being stood up high-speed internet road
runner
and
we had to isolate those systems with
what they call power supplies and so
power supplies had to be isolated so if
there's a lightning strike it would only
go like 300 feet before the next pole
and not below the whole system
so i had a job putting in these power
supplies and then grounding everything
to power bell
cable and all the way down into the
ground and then i install these big
supplies and then wire everything up and
i got paid for everything i mean if i
put like a screw on i could bill for it
whatever it was
so it was it was a good gig i mean
making 7 800 bucks a day after i paid my
guys and all my expenses so it was like
it was good money and i was a hustler
and so i mean i could just i would work
when the sun was up like you know
i was on my second cup of coffee and
making money
so
um
yeah the the first plane hits the world
trade center i'm on a telephone pole i
have no idea what's going on
um and then i get a call in the next
hell from a friend of mine that tells me
that uh a plane just hit the world trade
center
and at first i really
didn't believe him and um
i come down off the pole and end up like
meeting a lady who's had her door open
like right next to where the pole was
basically she lived right by the
railroad tracks
and what a terrible place to live oh my
god when people live by the railroad
tracks it's just like especially on the
east coast like when you drop when you
take the train they'll the railroad
tracks yeah if you live by the railroad
tracks it's a bummer that's that's
let's face it out here in california you
can live by the railroad tracks in
encinitas and have an ocean view that in
a house that you paid 4.8 million
dollars for it's not that way on the
east coast no your house is made of
shingles yeah cause they're like the how
you know how those houses are shingled
it's like yeah these are working on the
roof let's just keep going and uh
yeah so i was like so i come down i see
this lady she's in there she's watching
the news husband was a port authority
police officer and she was kind of
crying and emotional you know then
obviously the other plane hits and
like at the time i thought like
america was like under attack or were
being invaded i i don't know i had all
these like weird thoughts probably from
watching like movies and
red dots
happening now yeah jed
um
so yeah so i uh i go back to the yards
and i got my buddy with me we got rid of
the other dude we gave him his hundred
bucks
and
and i was like i'm going into the city
and my buddy's like to do what and i'm
like i don't know to like help out
and he's like you don't know anything i
remember this conversation we were at
because i did i don't know what i was
going to do i would be a victim or
something but how old are you
i was 21. okay yeah so i'm 42 now and
so i was like so i go in there drop
everything off take the audi get on the
lie 495 and i'm like hauling ass down
there there was no traffic
it was crazy and i'm like maxing this
car out it's probably why i broke down
and
i get to the i think it's the lincoln
tunnel
and there's like already tactical teams
and guys all standing there and
tell you how tight security was like i
had like a bunch of like cable tv and
electrical ids and like just you know
i look like a state department guy in
iraq you know i have like a million
badges or whatever
and
i tell them i'm like a demolition crew
and can you can you let me through and
they're like yep bring it in and so i
just drove right on through and we went
down there and parked and
that's when i you know towers that fall
listen to the radio and that's when uh
i realized like the severity of
everything that was happening like i
could see the smoke and people were
screaming and running everywhere
and i'd never seen anything like that in
my life and
so
i ripped the sleeve off my shirt put it
on my face and my buddy and just walked
into the smoke
basically at this point no idea where i
was going
so i would stay there for
24 hours until september 12 and
um that was uh what were you doing
at first like nothing i was just like
trying to like see if anybody needed
help but like i needed help myself
because i was covered in the smoke and
everybody was running the opposite way
so i ended up getting in there and then
they were putting together these like
makeshift shirt it was total chaos like
i don't think that people unless you
were there like realized like there was
really no organization it wasn't like
there was half you know the fire
department was dead there's smash
vehicles cop cars everywhere so we kind
of started like getting together with
groups to like look for people
late in the afternoon i ended up seeing
like a guy's leg sticking out from
underneath the police car
and a bunch of us got over there and
lifted it up and he was dead
and i remember like all the gravel and
everything was like shoved into his face
he must have hid underneath the car
i don't know to speculate but
whatever happened the car lifted up and
smushed them and
so people like pulled them out and they
pulled like some blankets over them and
fire department came in
citibank tower fell that tower you know
mystical tower 7 i was like right there
and uh you know for a couple hours i
couldn't see my hand in front of my face
it was one of the most terrifying
experiences of my life until i became an
sdv guy did you stay put did you just
stay there i just stayed there with my
shirt over my head but i couldn't
breathe and then you know i go to the
fire department they watched my eyes out
and i stayed there all night i found
like an arm and like intestines like and
i crawled inside the world trade center
like i was sliding down the metal beams
into the belly of the world trade center
and it was like
the most insane noises i ever heard in
my life like creaking and
you know just
like smoke and steam and it was just it
was so chaotic i had no idea what i was
doing but i wanted to help i had
i have this memory of like
i had a bicycle tube tire
on my hard hat with those little like
disposable ever ready like red and green
like with the white switch lights that
was my headlamp i had them like tied on
there
to the rescue and even if i found
somebody i don't really know what i
would have done because i had zero
skills really and
so
i you know i'm right by that iconic
picture of where the exoskeleton of the
world trade center is where the guys are
raising the flag and it's all over the
posters and stuff i'm like sitting off
to the right
and uh so the next morning i was there
got some food out of like a smashed up
like little bagel cart that was there
with my buddy and
i remember for the first time since like
that dude hit me in the head with that
bug nut i uh
i was like crying really hard
like i ne i could feel the death i could
feel the departure of life
in that area like you could feel the
immense loss
and um
i was sitting there with my buddy i'm
like we're just crying and he just looks
at me he's like man like what are we
gonna do the sun's coming up it's the
next morning
and i just looked at him i was like
i'm gonna kill whoever did this
and he was like okay like
you know
you kind of patted me on the back like
yeah okay and so
um
i ended up um
deciding 2003 that i joined the military
because what happened was i lost my
contract like six
maybe it wasn't six months maybe three
months later
i lost my contract so so through the end
of
2001 you're you go back to work go back
to work but then they're like you know
all this economic ambiguity all the new
build all the stuff they start cutting
them like low guy in the totem pole you
know subcontractor
so i own like all these like um
uh
like
all this line equipment that i bought
and you know i had a truck that was i
bought that payments on i had my audi
like
like i had all this now i'm like
you know basically i'm just trying to
keep everything flow i couldn't find any
work everyone's freaking out i'm
watching it i'm glued to the tv you know
24-hour news cycle
and so i ended up selling everything off
picked up some like side work and uh and
then moved out to
big sky montana
and i got a job as a ski tech out there
because i was just like i was watching
this warren miller movie and he said if
you don't pack up everything that you
have and move the big sky montana you
only be one year older when you do
and i was like so i got a job out there
in a ski shop
uh fixing skis and
so i worked out there came back did you
know anything about skiing
yeah i had i mean my idea of skiing like
i hate them like i basically just like
stole the skis like and i would i had a
pair of wire sniffers and that's how i
learned how to ski
um my parents did take me on like a
youth group thing one but i spent most
of the time trying to like make out with
a girl and uh
and then get saved on the next sunday
get forgiveness but i uh no i would um
i would go up with a pair of like wire
snippers and you know used to have the
old things and i would like snip them
off and put them on my jacket and that's
how i would ski and i'd ski all the time
like that
um i know it sounds terrible and i'm
sorry if you're listening and i did that
to you
it's for your forgiveness but
but i mean that's that's how i was you
know i mean i didn't really i didn't i
didn't have
you know a lot of things and so
um so anyway i went out there and i
worked in the ski shop and i just
basically was a ski bomb and it was
awesome and i met my uh i met my first
and only ex-wife so uh
she was like a work exchange program
from brazil a little spotty on the
english so it worked well
and um
yeah so so i ended up you know working
out there for basically about a year
coming back and then getting on a line
crew and that's when i decided i was
going to join the military
and then how did you figure out the navy
well
um i
tried to join the army because i had
seen like everything roberts ridge and
all that kind of stuff and uh i didn't
know like a ton about the military and i
they you know of course the army is
trying to get me to go in the infantry
and you work your way up and this is
where it starts and i'm like
i didn't so a navy guy actually came out
and like saw me and i kept going to the
mall because the recruiting station was
in the mall
um which meant you know go try to get in
the military if it didn't work out get
orange julius need a pretzel
so
that's
kind of is orange julia still around
does that still look big i think all
their customers died
one leg at a time
yeah
yeah exactly so eventually a navy
recruiter sees you he sees well he's
like he starts chatting it up with me
he's like coming back for lunch in one
day and he's like oh hey i've like seen
you coming here a bunch like what are
you doing you're always like here i'm
like well they're like i'm trying to get
a rain go in the rangers
and uh he's like well why you want to do
that and i was like oh because you know
they're the best in the world he goes no
they're not
and he's like
you got a minute let me show you a video
and he brings me in there and shows me
like the cj croc is kind of video like
it's it's like the dudes doing flutter
kicks in the shorts and they're like in
the desert like i mean it was
at the time the coolest thing i'd ever
seen in my entire life
and i was just like enthralled and these
dudes are like doing the triangle
defense and like they're
so i was like man he's like yeah the
navy seals like they're the best and i
was like whoa man what do i got to do
he's like you got to just sign up take a
little pt test like i was like great
like so i go through all this stuff
and it took me a little while to get
longer to get in than i had wanted
because i had a couple like little
altercations in my life i had to get
cleared up
and uh
yeah so i ended up starting doing like a
bunch of research and i was like i could
barely swim i could swim but i wasn't
like
that kind of swimmer so i started uh
i started training uh i bought the uh
like a
navy seal workout book
and
uh i started boxing again
because you grew up boxing i grew up
boxing yeah how much did you box when
you were a kid uh on and off pretty much
since i was like about 10. yeah i
started in catskill new york same place
mike tyson learned catskill village
boxing there you go yeah
and uh
i actually
understood working out because if you
never did that
but working out back in the day was kind
of like the toe touchers you know you're
doing the side it was not as like you
know scientific as it is today no i
remember getting ready to come in the
navy and thinking like dude you know i
did
whatever five sets of eight pull-ups
like what a good workout because you
just had no idea i mean this is like 89.
so there's no well at least there was no
information available that i had i mean
i wasn't going to go to the library
library we couldn't just google and
figure it out
so and
at least if you box like you knew
even if you just knew like you got to
push yourself like you obviously did you
compete in boxing yeah then you then you
knew like you you knew how to push
yourself hard in a workout absolutely
but that was like a different kind of
like
in the sense basically the workouts i
was doing was was running push-ups
pulsar like i was i would get up in the
morning i would get up before work so i
had a job i started working for a
roofing contractor once i was working
for a line guy that job kind of foiled
out
and thank god these guys were crazy i
was working on glenn's falls
anyway lion crew's got some crazy people
in it you know they got a lot of
problems like i find myself living in a
trailer in glens falls with this dude
johnny cause you want to pay my hotel or
whatever but anyway so i'm like doing
that end up getting a job for this
roofing company so i'm roofing all day
i'm working at a pizzeria at night and
on the weekends i worked for this guy
sanja this ugandan guy
who had a bunch of slums and i would go
in there and basically patch everything
up temporarily you know i wish flex tape
was around because i
was basically you know
flex taping everything just to make it
like you know pass the sniff test for
the renters and uh so i was working
three jobs and you know busting my ass
making pizzas
and matter of fact this is so when i
went to buds
i had a bicycle that i bought
uh from a guy that came in the pizzeria
uh it was a really cool
um specialized stump jumper
like for the day it was like she had
like the shocks i mean it was like it
was sick
and i took that the buds with me i
bought it for 60 bucks and at the
pizzeria and i sold that bike to mike
everett
who was my neighbor
yeah
anyway just a little factoid but um
so if he still has that you know i don't
know oh you mean mikey everett mikey
ever the team guy yeah oh wait he was
your neighbor yeah he was my neighbor
when i lived in buzz i lived in imperial
beach okay and i lived like two blocks
over him and how i met him was i was
going through buzz of course i showed up
with you know i got the tow head and
he was selling a jeep
and i had seen the movie i wanted a jeep
because navy seals and i did end up
getting one uh
i mean i had once i went and i like
bought into it like big time became like
a navy seal his story and i bought every
single i've read everything you know
from hunters and shooters you know men
of devils agree i read everything the
stories that i mean i was like obsessed
and uh that's how i am i'm like a total
immersion guy
but mikey was i l when i lived in
coronado when i was at team one yeah
mikey was a team one mike was in my
opportunity team one we lived in the
upstairs apartment and he lived in the
downstairs apartment so i have
many many many many mikeys yeah
[Music]
yeah that's freaking awesome i would go
over it like so i met him and he's like
i went over there and i was like oh how
like how much for your jeep he's like
are you in buds and i was like yeah
he's like
the out of here he said something
like that to me or something i was like
if you come back when you'd get a brown
t-shirt or something he said to me i
ended up like getting him known
through buzz he's like the nicest guy
ever he's the nicest nicest guy and his
wife you know that little gal
um just great people for sure his dad
was like a hell's angel and he was like
on easy riders and stuff like i mean
um
super cool people the best the best
you know i used to get crazy with stuff
oh yeah yeah so i was like so i went
over i remember i sold my bike to him uh
i needed like the money i forgot i
figured it was why i was selling i wish
i never sold it
um
but i sold that bike that i bought the
pizzeria and uh for 60 bucks i think i
sold him for 150 so damn ripping off
shout out to the business mind
gotcha mike so
so uh so i'm like so i'm training for
buzz i'm like basically order the baits
like six two sixes or whatever they were
and the pants and
and i just start working out and
and training my ass off and end up
meeting a guy named
through my recruiter a guy named drew
bisset you know he is
an old team guy he was a he was a
commander i don't think i know yeah and
he started off in udts and went on and
they ran this like seal
um
training course in greenwich connecticut
so you would go down there and you're
supposed to get this like letter of
approval or like recommendation i never
got from it but it was a great
experience because
i met a bunch of guys that later on i
would go on and serve with um and
we would train like on the once a month
together for like a whole weekend and
i'd never done anything like that and so
it was a really good experience i you
know worked out tons and
you know i'd work out in the morning
right on the evening i show up to buds
uh you know go through uh
boot camp which was like i'll never
forget it because i remember the boot
camp guy was like i
i got busted taking the
lunches for the sick people and eating
them at night
and i was so hungry because i would like
go work out in the bathroom i was so
nervous about failing
and i got busted
and so they you know they had all these
restrictions going on then they had that
dive motivator program going on run by
uh jody mcintyre was running at the time
and
so i would like go over there and i'd
get these little passes and then i
started knowing all the scruffs waiting
to go to buds and so they would give me
these passes and then eventually i was
just kind of filling them out and
leaving like and wandering around boot
camp right
so
i started calling my
my my now ex-wife
um and i'd go in the phone booth and i
got busted by the chief like right
before graduation so i never really got
to see my family they restricted me
before i left to go to buds or whatever
i was eating m ms and i was like in the
booth and i was like i saw my chief and
i was like i just timed it wrong like
literally as i was walking around with
like chips on my chin i like walked out
he's like looks at me and i was like i
have a pass and and he's and he's give
me your pass
who signed this i was like
uh petty officer johnson like oh
like
i got that was my first taste of like
the military has you by the balls
and um
yeah so i show up
class up with class two five four
matter of fact bro i graduated brian
bourgeois oh really yeah brian was it
was a buddy of mine
and uh
yeah so i classed up with them and
yeah cruise through
i think we graduated 13 original guys
that class graduates like guys like ryan
bates and
uh
yeah i remember i didn't shout out to
ryan bates for sure i didn't like him at
first because everyone's like hey ryan's
like he does like wrestles at the lions
then i'm like what the is the lions
then
you know everyone's like he's like in
the best shape ever like everyone's
there i was like
freaking beat his ass like i i just was
like not having it you know we ended up
becoming super good buds you know but
he's awesome yeah
i tell a story a lot but i don't say his
name brian but uh
it's like one of those moments where i
was they were going through training and
through
work up training and i was running the
training
and there's like total chaos going on in
the mount town and there's just like
everyone's getting shot up with
paintball or whatever and no one's
making any decisions
and i could already i
a guy like him he stood out because he's
just like
freaking stud and was squared away
and i don't think i had trained because
eventually we trained together in jiu
jitsu and whatnot so i think i kind of
knew that or whatever but that wasn't he
was good as an operator you know beyond
jiu jitsu he was good as an operator and
i knew it and you could all you could
tell like in a platoon there'd be like
two guys that were good or three guys
that were good or whatever and it might
be the oic it might be the platoon chief
it might be the lpo or it might be some
freaking random e5 so i've been watching
him and there's total mayhem and chaos
going on and he's like crouched down
behind a wall and i walk over to him
like hey bro what's going on he said
just just get crazy and i said what do
you think you should do right now and
he's like we should we should freaking
strong point that building and i go why
don't you make it happen he and he
it was beautiful the look on his face
was like
oh i can do that
and he just was like hey
we're strong point in that building over
there here's like you know i don't even
know he's a new guy or maybe he's a one
cruise wonder whatever he started making
calls and people just listened and they
did what they're supposed to do
and uh yeah i love that guy
yeah i know i you know i have so uh van
wilson he was a team guy that uh
uh got killed in a car crash day after
we graduated buds
academy grad officer
who's ncaa wrestling champ
monster i know we're all heartbroken we
all got like tattoos the night before or
whatever together and we're all
all super tight and
yeah that was uh
that that you know being in buds and
that like that changed my life you know
that whole that whole experience you
know i was like finally like a part of
something you know did you have trouble
with anything you said you weren't that
great of a swimmer did you figure it out
no i aced everything except for the last
one but
uh as a matter of fact it would have
been the first time every time had i not
dragged another friend of mine who's
getting ready to get out uh
because he was he was done after that if
he didn't pass that it was over for him
and he was like sandbagging like crazy
but yeah that's pretty good that you
were able to not really be like a water
guy and pass everything yeah i mean
later on i would become you know i
started competing you know you know a
free dive spear fishing you know around
the world um so i mean i that water
experience and then being an sdv guy
um
which was like if they they should just
have the sdv at buds like day one
everyone get into this we're gonna sink
it under the water in the dark you would
you would it would you would weed out
like 75 percent of the people a lot of
people it's terrifying and um
so i got out went you know went to 18
delta i went to the sacramento course
and then uh
um got sent to stv team one how tall are
you six four do they even think about
that at all i mean that doesn't make
sense bro no ah
so if you don't know sdv is like a mini
sub and it's it's a it's what's called a
wet submersible which means when you're
in it it's filled with water so it's not
like you're in a little submarine like
james bond all listening to itunes with
with the freaking heater on it's
it's like this time they're not big
they're small and they fill up with
water
ocean water
not like warm water ocean water is
around you you can't move in it there's
a guy in front of you and so like the
dive profiles get so
um you know i went to sdv school i
crashed the sdv like before i graduated
which was great because i ended up
becoming a backseat guy and i got to do
the real world mish um
but i was like i'll never forget i had
an officer next to me i can't remember
his name he was a total dick and and he
was like so bossy he's a new officer he
knows he wants to he wants to lead me
and yeah and i'm but we drive
they nav so i got the stick i'm like you
know controlling the ballast i'm like
you know and i was like hey uh sir i
think there's like there's something in
front of us i think he's like just stay
on this course and i'm like i don't know
he's like it's just artifact i'm like i
think that's a thing like and i was like
so i was i was like okay fine so like
crank it up accelerate and i'm like
accelerate and i hit it and it was like
out in the middle of osha was like one
of those like
rock little jetties with the with a
little lighthouse on it
and all of a sudden it was like you know
we come rocketing out all sudden it's
like all the water trades out it's like
[Music]
i'm like
so i like open up the door and i like
look down and there's like land and i
look at him he's like oh like we're
there and so that was the end of my
driving career
um and he was he was pissed because i
did i said okay fine and i just
accelerated right into it so um
graduated stb school
go out to the team and uh you know
that's when i started learning like
how sophisticated that really is and how
you know it's super complicated you're
diving mixed gas
free breathers and open circuit all in
these various profiles throughout very
long dives under under pressure and like
12 hours
eight hours like yeah and you you'll
switch on and off so you'll be like you
know you can't be on a rebreather you
know because you got oxygen
toxicity area you can't be on all heliox
or nitrox or you can't be on all open
circuit because of nitrogen narcosis so
you're like and then you have these like
computers with all these like lights
that blink and like these huge like
screens and i could never remember like
i knew that double red was not good even
i know that
it was like double red and i'd be like
uh manually enter the air like and i'm
like oh
double green
i think it's okay solid i'm good and so
there's a guy right in front of you
and you can't move
so he sits in between your legs all your
gear and all your equipment gets shoved
in the back and then everything's pitch
black so when we're training for the
national tasking like
everything's by memory
every single thing has a not every
single light has a signal you know
because you're not using the under the
ots system you know because it can be
heard so everything is by feel so
everything begins like you know first
you're in these huge tanks and then
you're graduating up until you're in the
ocean so everything is in the pitch
black
so like when things get out of sync it
gets very confusing and then
you have to fsa at the end you have to
take your rigs click it to the outside
and then the sub will surface
and then you like blow out close your
rebreather and kick away and then the
sub leaves and then you're on the
surface
and then you swim ashore you know and
then you have underwater pingers that
find you like all that kind of stuff so
it was like at first like not what i had
like signed up to do
like meanwhile i'm like watching the
news you know it's like
glasgow
and i'm like underwater like
like hand signals so
um
i wouldn't change it for anything in the
world because of the team i got to be a
part of what we got to do
um and
the knowledge that i gained of that
mobility platform uh
it was something that
i think like within the teams is so like
niche
and most people think you know because
the stv guys always get like bad rap you
know like all freaking like sdv guys
like
um but i got out of that and then i got
to augment damn neck so
uh seven days later after that
deployment so
yeah the it's i
thought the attitude of like oh sdv guys
like i
i don't know at some point and i was
pretty young when i was like yeah you
know what that those guys freaking get
my respect
and because it's a
i don't know i i talked to some of my
friends one of my friends in particular
was like
who came from sdv and was that
whatever team we were at
and i remember he's a good dude a solid
dude and a like team a reliable team guy
that you would want to go with you on
and off
and one time we were talking he was like
hey man we were doing like
some exercise off of korea
and you know it's winter time and he was
like
he's telling me the story and he's all
like he's all like in the like he starts
filling up with water and he's like i
don't want to do this anymore yeah
but he's like i don't want to do this i
don't want this is not what i this is
not what i want to do i don't do this
anymore like literally having dor
thoughts like he wants to quit after
he's been in teams for 10 years people
both we've had team guys i won't call
them out but like there was team guys
that would freak panic i mean
you can get we had a we had a chief uh
in my second platoon who drowned and
died
um i mean got tangled up in the lines on
a bottom up you know because they would
bottom up underneath stuff and it was uh
it's sketchy there's lines everywhere
there's stuff going everything's by me
you have all this gear all this
equipment all this stuff like it is you
have to maintain like a totally cool
mind
um and then when you get into like dry
dock sheltering and
in the real world and all those kind of
things like things can go sideways
quick
there's no there's no mistakes matter of
fact i remember we were training for
that for that mission how was that 80
feet on a rebreath of my buddy
um
my best friend actually like we're down
to the bottom i remember like i had like
a leak in my mask and i was like looking
i was like pointing you know doing the
signal like there's a problem he's like
typical he's like
you're good and i remember i was like
and the whole piece goes
and i was like
like and i was like
and he looked at me he's like there is
no buddy breathing you're in like a full
face mask he's like
you know just remember him like i watch
you die he's just he just looks at me
like you're dead like and i remember i
just was like
sorry you just blow and go hey blow and
go from 80 feet
yeah i was watching
he's like i'll never forget your face it
was hilarious i was like it was
hilarious because i could never make
that piece again unless i'm about to die
we did we used to do more sub-ops in the
regular teams yeah and so
you know like i did a few trips of doing
lockouts and stuff and even that you
know you're in this little freaking
chamber and it's filling up with water
and it's freezing cold and you got it
what do we have we'd have like weapons
bags and engine bags and all this stuff
in there
and it's all claustrophobic and i'm i'm
very comfortable in the water yeah but
like guys did not like even that and
that's one you know 100th of what it's
actually like because when we do that
we'd be like cool hey we're going to do
we're going to do sub-ops
for a week or whatever two weeks you
guys just like oh what are we doing for
the rest of our lives sub-ops just
it's like god like you could kind of gut
through something right you know you're
learning and just got through something
if that's just your life and you know
what yo we just did a 12-hour dive today
cool what are we doing tomorrow a while
while we're dive oh man it never it's
like
you you had to uh
i mean you you got to learn to relax
like you can't freak out in those
situations at all no no like
you know we used to always say like
those who panic first die
if you panic you'll die
i mean the
what happened to
you know that chief that died was
he got tangled up in some lines and you
know then his mask got pulled off and
there was no getting it there's no
getting out like there's no you're it's
pitch black you know and the worst is
you know the bioluminescence like all
that kind of you're like completely
blinded
um you know and then working all the way
up to a national tasking with those guys
and doing all that stuff um
matter of fact uh
we had to we were like getting to the
point we didn't know where we're going
we didn't know any of the information
uh still you know still classified to
this day probably always will be
and you're just getting sick of the same
people you know the same problem same
personalities the same dirty coffee cup
the same dude the same you know it's the
same and we were traveling all around
the country in different environments
like
you know preparing for
anything and i remember finally our
chief at the time was like
he called a smoker's
and he got in big trouble because he's
like okay this is it we got to settle
all these beefs before we leave and
deploy
you like oh
well at first i didn't really have
problems with anybody i was kind of just
like whatever and
um
so you were a new guy when this was
going down this is your first first
first that's freaking savage new guy and
so um
i was like you know i'm super moto guy
like i was just like so you know fired
up and did you know what you were
getting into
into when you got assigned sdvs
well i had read the old books about the
dudes like in the tortilla like getting
covered in grease and like squirting out
of like a sewage pipe or whatever old
school you know but that's that's really
all i knew about i had no idea
um
and uh
yeah so like he had calls the smokers
and we're getting ready to leave and
he's like hey we're gonna put the board
up here officers unless it doesn't
matter everybody write name on the board
one five minute round
so by the way yeah that's just right if
you don't know echo you know what
smokers is yes sir okay smokers is hey
we're gonna it's usually boxing it's
like we're just gonna
boxing yeah and they do it on ships too
they do well at least they used to used
to have smokers on ships and smokers on
navy bases we're just going to go and
box other people
so that's what like the military was
like tough back in the day but it was a
great let me tell you something it
leveled the scores between a lot of
people and i didn't so everybody like
got up and you had to write your name on
the board with the guy that you wanted
to
fight and of course like some guys
jumped up right away and like wrote the
guy's name down
and i just kind of sat back i'm like
and then this dude gets up and he's one
of the divers and he writes my name on
the board and i was like
i didn't know he had like a problem
so i was like
so we go oh he didn't know you freaking
box since you were 10 years old well i
wore all my so we like so everybody
starts coming to me and they're like hey
like help me out they're all nervous now
and so i'm working with some guys a week
goes by it's like a friday night or
something we show up there and
and i wore like my old boxing trunks i
got like you know custom gloves i got
all my stuff no head gear i didn't want
anything i did my gold teeth like
mouthpiece and i put it in i'm like
and so when i was in the meta course i
actually um was sparring partner for ray
mercer
yeah that kind of ended in my hopes of
like thinking that i was going to be
like great someday i don't you know how
we you know men are like we just kind of
think like
but i ended up so like to backtrack a
little bit i started boxing again while
i was going through the medic course in
fort bragg for a year and
i end up fighting in the north carolina
state prison so boxing guys like bernard
hopkins and then they come up out of the
prison programs
and so i went in there went through all
the security stuff whatever and i fight
like you know various rounds kind of
like a
tournament style and i ended up winning
to like the top guy well we was a draw
the top guy and he was like the scariest
dude i'm telling you he was like the
biggest
scariest dude he was doing like 17 the
life and ray mercer was there and so
his coach saw me boxing or whatever and
was like hey ray's like getting back in
the game which he did and he ended up
fighting like tim sylvia oh that's right
he
crushed his face in okay ray mercer
people don't remember like that guy was
an animal
he also unfortunately lost a kimbo slice
mercer did yep in mma yep got but the
funny thing is they didn't box
like somehow i think if i remember right
kimbo slice got him in a guillotine
and ra and ray was like i don't know
what this is but
i thought we were going to
know what i mean it's like i thought we
were going to fight so yeah so like i
started i was so did you do like a camp
with him
yeah so i started boxing with him on the
weekends like sparring partner getting
them in shape and so uh you know i grew
up watching ray mercer you know he
devastated tommy morrison he lost the
linux louis he was a brutal dude he'd
never been knocked down he had a head
like a you know like a giant block of
cheese and
and
he was merciless i mean if you watch
that knockout against tom morrison who
was like my hero at the time before he
got aids and
uh but like i mean when he beat him down
i remember what he said he's like you
know you can kill somebody in boxing
that's like all he said it was like very
like not like is he okay or anything
and when he lost to lennox lewis which
was controversial actually um
i kind of ended his career he had some
more fights like along the way but um
when he hit tim sylvia he caved his
whole head in i mean if you watch that
clip on youtube i mean it's brutal so
i'm in there boxing with him i have a
couple great shots of me and him boxing
together and he hit me so hard one time
that for the first time like i like
kneeled down the ground i wasn't really
sure like i'm on like roller skates like
i and i i remember i was like hurt for
like a week
and i started thinking in my head like
man if this is how like people are
hitting like this level
i don't
i think i'll die
because i don't have a huge neck
i don't know i just got like more of
like a noodle neck like uh no matter how
hard i work i need the iron neck or
whatever but um
yeah so i so i i boxed with him and then
i just i just stayed in shape you know
or whatever once i left there i had
three amateur fights and then box would
fray then whatever went in the teams and
so we show up at the smokers and so i
got all my trunks i got all my stuff i
got my shoes on my little tassels and
everything and i got the whole thing in
there
and
he's looking at me over there with his
like you know i don't know off brand
boxing gloves or whatever and he just
comes over he's like hey man i just
i don't
i don't know why i signed up for that i
don't really have a problem with you or
anything like that it's just are we good
i'm like
you're
dead and we got in there and i let him
like punch me around for like 30 seconds
i hit him one time knocked him out
cold
and so shout out to my chief because
like he got in big trouble because some
guys got hurt and they couldn't die
because they're because you know their
noses and it was like dudes
dudes got beat up um so yeah so it was
it was a good experience you know i uh
really uh really fortunate that i went
there you know it was a unique
experience and then i and then seven
days later well while underway i got
told i was getting augmented
to tf373 so and where did you go for
that
uh well i went damn neck
did like a train up with them and then
went to afghanistan
to an out station
and how was that deployment
that one was rough that one we lost uh
josh harris so i was with him when he
died um that's right next to him and
then
jason freewald and john markham
so
that was a that was a tough one
and so uh you know that was my first
experience in real war you know i mean
what i had just come off though like the
implications were so high like the
intensity that if anything went wrong
like
literally no one's coming to get you
you know
it's uh
not gonna be good so but it was
completely different you know than being
shot at in the desert so
um yeah it was uh
that was a really good experience and
then it kind of just like you know up to
my aspirations i got to work with some
incredible people
and uh do a lot of really cool missions
and kind of do the stuff that i had been
hoping to do from when i was sitting
there at 9 11 and i had a you know a
vision of what i was going to do you
know what were you guys doing like
pretty much just da's yeah was that what
you were doing do a da's
a lot of like srs and stuff like that a
lot of overwatch's for the army you know
in various areas we had a lot of remote
outstations and then we were with the uh
um the people that i later went on to
work for uh we were kind of the military
component for them so and so the op
temple was high tempo was high it was
2008 so and you're just living the dream
living the dream like i mean riding dirt
bikes like i'm just like living the
dream uh
and then uh when josh died
you know that was my first experience
with losing somebody
and then it just was like really real to
me
how you know it just everything changed
after that for me
um
and that that mission was
you know he drowned
uh so that was uh the way that whole
thing went down that that was tough that
was that was a tough one and then the
guys that were with us you know
uh jason got killed on entry
uh he got shot in the stomach and then
john markham got shot in the neck
on that so that was a huge loss in 2008
you know for the teams
so
so when you when you say
when you say like things changed or you
changed or it changed what was what was
like the change was it hey all of a
sudden oh
we're not immortal or what was the
change that you were yeah i think that
was it
like i think i had this like i had this
like immortality idea in my head
where i could
outsmart out run out shoot out do
anything
and then uh
the realism when someone's wrapped in a
flag on a helicopter you know
as a young guy i was just like the
implications were so high i have a great
picture
at my house
i don't have a lot of military stuff at
my house i have some stuff in my office
but
because i don't want to influence my son
you know i try to
you know i don't want him to feel that
you know and uh
um it's a picture that was taken by an
oga guy of me that he sent to me later
on and i was standing out looking over
the corn gall
and uh
i couldn't believe like where i'd come
from
and that i'm like standing here with
these people like these men you know
like who
are were giants to me you know because
like i said i became like a historian i
read every book everything every there's
probably not a book on the teams that i
didn't read and this was before like a
lot of books were coming out they're
like old school books
and i really believe like in the
brotherhood like in the old school like
do everything together kind of mentality
uh matter of fact kirby harel he's like
an old school team guy
and he was like
i never forget we were like sitting
drinking a beer one day when i was a new
guy and he's like
he's like you and you know this other
guy's like you guys are like the spirit
of like the old teams like the old teams
like just
and i mean i was i like lived it i loved
it and uh um
so you know going to actual war though
is very humbling you know
and it kind of puts you like in a place
where you realize like
this is like super dangerous because to
be honest with you i didn't really think
that way at the time
you know
real quick kirby harel story because
it's just awesome
he was on the podcast and he's talking
oh he's talking about the phoenix
program and he's like yeah
he goes so
he
we'd we'd go up and i was talking to him
because
you know i have a little bit of
perspective of like what doing missions
are like so i was like so
so how would you know what
what like hut you're going into in a
village and he's like oh well i would a
source tell you like hey it's three huts
down on the right and he's like yup
that's what happened i go that's cool
and so there's one op
they're in a in a little sampan him and
one other guy
and they go into this village
and he and so he's telling the story and
he goes yeah you know so i went in there
and i went into the third hut on the
right or whatever it was knocked the guy
out i come out throw him in the boat and
so i'm thinking i'm like that's cool and
i go i go uh
how did you knock him out he goes and he
go without missing a beat i go i go
how'd you knock him out he goes ball
peen hammer
so like you see him on his web gear he's
got a ball-peen hammer and his freaking
web gear just whack it dude at the head
and that's that
that's so bad that's so badass
back when the men were iron and the
ships were wood
yeah
how long was that deployment to
afghanistan that uh i think we were so
four months yeah month like working up
getting ready and then were you still
actually technically attached to sdv and
yeah they're tad yeah yep that was their
tid so so when you got done with that
deployment
what happened i went into uh well i went
into another platoon like basically
uh i got home
my girlfriend now wife we've been
together for 15 years now um married for
10. and she
picked me up at the airport and i showed
up to drop all my gear off i got my car
this is coming home from deployment
coming home from deployment i get picked
up uh no fanfare obviously at the
command line again just get all your
stuff and um hung out with some of the
guys for a couple days and then headed
out and
uh i get back to the command and so i
was with slab uh so after josh died i
got went to another base got to kind of
know him and um which obviously is like
was an icon you know looking up to him
or whatever just like a really great
leader like real real quiet real steady
likes you know um
got to meet him and i was like i want to
go screen and go to the command or
whatever and so
some guys like reached out about me you
know putting my package in and all that
kind of stuff and so it's like a
saturday or something i get to come i
get my car get all my stuff tell my
girlfriend that i'm going to meet her
and drop everything off and the master
chiefs there
and so he sees me in the locker room
he's like come on this is the sdv master
chief truck yeah
who
i didn't like and so
i uh
i
i'm down there like getting all my stuff
just home from deployment like and to be
honest with you like
looking back like
that
whole like there was a lot that happened
like that was like a lot because i just
did back to back so i mean i was like
hadn't been there in like a long time
and all this stuff had gone down and
here i am like checking in thinking i'm
gonna like get some time off or whatever
and he goes up in the office and he's
like hey i want to talk to you come on
upstairs
and you go so uh
you know you just got back i'm like yeah
i just got back like right now you know
and he's like
so you think you're gonna like go over
there and like screen is that what you
think i was like
i'm like what like apparently some
people had sent some emails and said hey
we want him to come over blah blah
whatever
and
and i was like yeah he's like whoa
you know they're not in charge of
manning i am he says to me
and i was like
i thinking about my headspace at the
time you know i was like not in a good
head space
and i was like
i i said something inflammatory i think
and he went like crazy and started like
screaming at me came over the desk like
on my face you know and he's like
you'll go where i tell you to go and da
da da and i was like then i'll
get out you know like i i mean i've had
that kind of attitude and so we're
getting this huge thing
i get a text message from the chief he
tells me hey um gear ready on sunday 96
hour
sr i'm like
okay so i like unpack my gear call my
girlfriend i'm like packing out so i
roll right into another platoon
two days later
and i was pretty bitter
about that
uh nobody like asked me how i was doing
nobody was like hey like what's going on
like or you know how was your trip like
next thing i know i'm like literally
like dudes with orange vests walking
around looking for me with like rubber
shape
like laying in the bushes like
like i was so mad i can't describe how
mad i was
uh the only thing i could do was think
about how mad i was and that was
impossible for me getting madder like
like i would explode so um
i go through you know i go through that
and i hurt my hand uh and end up rolling
out of that platoon right before the
tasking i got a pretty severe arterial
injury in my hand
and uh
so then i go to
like you said go to trade at made e6 and
go to trade at this like sdv trade at or
did you go to oh it was like standoff
weapons that we had it was like no it
was like sdv
i forget what's called something so
you're still at sdv yeah but you're in
the training i'm in the training
department so i'm like going to seattle
a lot and you know working over in those
regions or whatever
and then uh and then i got out uh
because and then i tried to screen for
well i went into the reserves
immediately and then tried to screen for
kag uh
and the reserve unit wouldn't let me go
so then i tried to go from the reserve
unit i remember the mass chief at the
time and he wanted me to go sell res
for two years and serve my time at the
reserves before i can go there because
this isn't going to be a stepping stone
everything i was trying to do was try to
get the opportunity to go over there
so then i ended up uh
i won't say his name because he ended up
getting a lot of trouble but i ended up
meeting getting picked up and doing a
job in iraq for uh during the
i think it was a status of forces
agreement that was going on at the time
doing like psd stuff so now you're a
contractor so now i'm a contractor
and i was like picking up schools and
stuff and going to schools or whatever
and trying to like figure out how i
could like weasel my way like back into
active duty that's all i wanted to do
and i was just really got out of pure
spite i was just so angry like and i
looked back at like my state and i was
like man like luckily i'm like a fairly
i may not sound like it but i'm like a
steady-headed person
because i was like really like
a roller coaster of emotions like i had
just experienced all this stuff in a
nutshell and next thing you know i'm
like felt like i was being on
you know
so
i um
i'm in iraq and i'm like standing at the
green bean and i see a guy who knows me
and he starts talking he's like oh hey
what are you doing i was like i told him
what i was doing he's like
give me your email i got another job for
you and so
i ended up going over to uh
you know contracting for the cia
yeah and i did like almost four years
over there
and
did you go what what did that you know
from what you can say that's cool to say
was that
did you get some immediate training were
they like hey you're good on your
training what would you have to do i was
the only team guy that made it out of
the training me and three other guys uh
first of all i didn't really like i had
an idea but he wouldn't tell me anything
and i got how it went down was like i
got a random email being like you know
you've been like recommended for
training can you be here on uh you know
whatever the date was and i was in iraq
so i remember i went to this guy was
like a total tool bag he was like some
like army guy or something and i was
like oh hey i gotta like get out of here
i got like a family health problem
and he's like you can't leave here i was
like i'll walk right out of this gate
and i'll get on the airplane i'm like
you don't own me i'll do whatever i want
you know so finally like
they like they made me fly calm air so
i'm like
i do whatever i want thank you
yeah because i was like i'm taking this
job like i want this job and so i
couldn't have gotten out of there and
made it training so i end up flying calm
air out
and i'm like
rethinking everything i was about to
like baghdad airport like
there's no orange julius's there
and
and i'm like one of these guys is not
like the others so i fly back and two
days later i'm in training and uh at an
undisclosed facility
and it's like
go time like
can you perform like show up here on the
line nobody talk nobody's saying
anything like nobody's like i'm in this
like vetting and it's like i know it's
like four or five weeks
all over in various locations and uh i
show up it was really funny because i'm
checking into the hotel in
one of the states and
of course i'm in the lobby and i look
around it's like typical contractors
like you know huge like american flag
had some beards like everyone's like low
problems
clearly like
clearly we're all here together you know
everyone's calling everyone brother like
and
like even the even the guy at the front
desk is a brother
and and so we check into the uh we check
we check in and my roommate is a team
guy bunny of mine and so uh as we're
like in
like he's like a good buddy of mine
and i didn't even know he was there so
we're there and
um he didn't make it
but
theo so i get a text
message from overseas like watch the
news tonight
okay bin laden goes down and i'm in the
hotel like
no way you know and of course you know
and then you've got all you got all the
seal experts on there describing it
exactly how they did it like right it
was like it was like the uh it was like
the captain phillips thing you know hey
i had that dude with like i forget who
it was like brandon webb or something it
was like a watermelon like swinging
slowly and he's like shooting it with a
50 cal like showing how like difficult
it would have been to hit the watermelon
but so i'm like glued to the news show
up the next morning we got like
selection starts and um
you know pt tests all those kind of
things and the quals were super hard
shooting calls yeah they were very
difficult like
that's what got most people was the
qualls and then the cqb
um i mean it's and then
they never like there's no coaching
there's no like if you don't make past
these tests at this time you're just you
just go away like a van just pulls up
and you just leave there's no like hey
bro you think he can do better next time
like
i mean i've walked i mean we're i was
there with cat guys team guys like
everybody and so i get to the end
there's only
four of us left and
now i'm kind of figuring i'm in a total
state of paranoia too because every
movie i've ever watched about the cia is
like playing in my head you know i like
turn the sync on i'm waiting for like a
cable to come out and look at me or
whatever you know like everything
everybody is like everybody's on it
which is kind of funny because when i
went through the surveillance course and
uh i actually got busted by like a big
fat lady in a kfc
she like busted me
so i was like
you know there is those kind of people
so they don't discriminate i i was doing
like some countering surveillance thing
and i was i was in san diego
and i was all dressed up like a bum
and uh
and i'm like sitting there and i'm all
freaking dirty and shitty and
and i got busted and i got busted
because i had my watch on and like this
you know so just like whoever we were
surveilling
whatever it was surveilling the
surveillers or whatever yeah and like we
got back to the debriefing they're like
hey you know
jocko freaking nice watch they're like
you got rolled up because of that you
know everyone everyone's like look you
look like a bum with this freaking uh
iron man watch
this is the healthiest bum ever yeah
this was before everyone had like the
big tactical watches that everybody has
now yeah you know but back in the day i
guess this was sort of like a big
tactical watch bear can you do it
so yeah the old school
that's funny so not so only a few you
get a few of us make it through yeah and
so some of the guys got the opportunity
to try you know they were good dudes and
they had to try again but the quals were
like i mean were you always a good
shooter
yeah i was always a good shooter i don't
not that i grew up i grew up like you
know deer hunting like but like i always
laugh because now i'm like big archery
hunter and stuff and
and and actually a hunter but when i
grew up like hunting was like you know
shooting out of the back of the truck
and like a deer like in a corn field and
like you know like that that was hunting
like you know like our hunting gear was
like you know like this onesie snow suit
was like yeah you bought a wall crack
yeah exactly and a six-pack it was like
bubba
you must have good hand-eye coordination
from maybe from boxing and everything to
just go in there and knock the out
of a course like that that's legit yeah
and the pistol i mean the pistol
shooting was like they had this one
called the rundown uh so it was you
lined up on the 100 all right and then
you would sprint to the 200
drop down two shots prone
and then you'd sprint
no no no this is rifle oh i thought you
were talking pistol i was like damn no
this is no joke
so
um no but this was a tough one so it's
full kit on and then you would start you
had to have six mags and with two rounds
in each mac you'd start at the 100
sprint to the 200 drop down two shots
prone then sprint to the 100 two shots
kneeling and then sprint to the 50 two
shot standing then to the 25 two head
shots then to the seven two head shots
mag change in between every one you had
two minutes and minimum score 24 on a
ipsec
um
that got a lot of guys and then six
seconds four shots from the concealed 25
yards um on the pistol so that was and
you can't miss yeah that's gonna
by time you get through all that then
you got like cqb so i'm like and this is
the interesting thing about this is no
workup it's not like you went through no
you came off some shooting school or you
like okay hey let's get you guys all
dialed in here's your test i was just
like hey welcome here's your test yes
and you're you're basically testing the
whole time because it's like a vetting
and uh it was really funny because we
show up and we're at like the uh
the dwayne deter thing
so i thought i was done with that
because i went through that in skt you
know okay you hit me ahead of the thing
it hurts and i i know this is deadly
like but you know how they got to do the
level one everyone's a level three yeah
it depends who you know if you got
somebody
a meathead they're gonna hit you with it
so i'm thinking i'm done with that i
show up there and i'm like oh no like
karate chops to the head like
so
we go through all that stuff we get done
there's another series of calls at the
end
you finish that off and then you get
offered a job and get ready to start
deploying
and then every two years you have to
redo it
and if you fail you're done
so there's like this looming pressure of
like
i have to redo all these things and then
it gets more like i went through that
and then it gets more like uh training
there's like you still have to crawl but
there's more training involved
but that the initial one was just the
vetting out and that was tough that was
some of the toughest training i ever
went through
so now you get to that job
and you're starting to conduct
operations obviously there's only so
much we can say about the operations
yeah you know where you're conducting
them and kind of what you're doing but
broadly speaking what was your what was
your task yeah so um tasking was to
you know protect uh you know cia
personnel like you know around the world
you know they conduct their missions uh
so it's uh it's intense and you work all
the time there is no moratorium there is
no standing down there is no you know
you're you're employed and it's onesies
and twozies
um and
then there's also like the high vis
military side where you're doing the
paramilitary stuff depending on what
bases you're at so
i was a team leader at a couple bases
where it's like full-on i mean it's
full-on military like you're you know
you got a whole you got a whole team of
guys underneath you
and uh
yeah it's uh
looking at it from that side and looking
at it from the military side is just so
different like it's unbelievable um
and so yeah it was uh for a team of guys
that you're talking about are not
americans yeah not americans yeah and uh
and you know people can say what they
want about those guys and i wouldn't say
i trusted all of them but you really
develop a relationship you know you you
rely on these guys and you know watching
afghanistan fall and
it was hard you know it was hard matter
of fact i met some of the guys
recently that got out of the country uh
last month uh they reached out to me and
they're they're here somewhere living in
the refugee camp basically
and uh they were telling me about what
happened to a bunch of our guys i mean
held against the walls shish kebab
spears stuff through their hearts you
know i mean like brutally killed um
so it was uh it was tough i had a good
relationship with those guys so
some of them are here in the states
actually uh funny enough like one of
them like i don't know they don't we
don't use our names
but one of the guys somehow like found
me and like reached out to like my
secretary
like i was like my name is like
so-and-so muhammad like you know i'm
looking for mike and they said it to me
i'm like
take everything off the internet like
[Music]
yeah that's bizarre it is bizarre and he
you know it was uh
i sat down for a matter of fact
what happened was i was
i won't say where i was but i was in a
state for work a month ago
my plane gets cancelled
um
so i'm like kind of wandering around
like oh my god i gotta like get another
hotel and do all this stuff i walk into
the parking garage and i hear somebody
calling me by my call sign
of course like my spidey senses like
just perk up and there's not a lot of
people that know that and i like turn
and look and
it's two of my guys like where i was the
team leader of that place for three
deployments
and uh
and he's like you know i'm like
like what's happening right now so i
ended up like
going back to their house with them
and having dinner at this which is like
it's a wicked refugee camp i just ran
into him at the airport all right so i
sit down and when we go off i'll show
you some pictures of me with them but uh
yeah they started telling me like what
happened to all these guys i mean dude
it's like
man that guy is all he's ever done since
he was 20 years old was worked for the
americans i mean his family's been
killed her house has burned down people
have been beheaded
um i mean they've been tortured i mean
it's it's
it's rough
yeah
this the amount of people that worked
with america in afghanistan
is like a massive number it's a massive
number to think like oh well there's
only a small amount of people that are
going to bear the burden it's like
there's a massive number of people that
work with americans
well if you look at uh you know kind of
in my work with my foundation
um if you look at the number of of
people that have served in the war
americans right 2.7
million americans served in the global
war and terrorism 20 years right so 7
died in the war over 20 years 1500 are
amputated so that's point zero zero zero
two six percent
um point zero zero five six percent are
those who have died right and then you
look at the fallout though from the war
so we just we look at those hard numbers
right but we don't look at the cost of
it
and you look at uh
only 4.5 percent of them are 10 you know
american veterans attempting to start
businesses or be entrepreneurs you know
there's 50 000 non-profits in north
america two and six veteran on you know
psychiatric medications
um and
between 2005 and the end of 2020 155 000
guys have killed themselves
so people say well you know some of
those guys were other vets or whatever
you know they didn't serve in there
there were vietnam vets or
it doesn't matter like
that's a huge number that's every 64
minutes
and
so we look at those numbers and the
fallout on american culture
and then you gotta look at the fallout
on the on the host nation
culture
and that that will be felt for
generations
like and then what we did like
i don't mean we but like what our nation
did like
we're no longer like a force of
righteousness and of good
like we are
we are colonialists that have destroyed
the foundation and fabric matter of fact
i was talking andy said like
what is it 98 of all people in
afghanistan didn't know who osama bin
laden was and didn't know 9 11 had
happened right so
so we just think about our cost of war
but then you've got to look at the
long-term cost of of what's the
displacement within societies
and
it's going to come home to roost i mean
i was listening to there was a general
who supported us when i worked on the
other side of the house
he was a badass matter of fact i have a
t-shirt with his face on it i work out
with it all the time he was he was a
real
he was committed to the cause and he was
he wasn't we just
just abandoned them and they uh
they tore these guys told me they just
tortured them viciously
and this is a guy that for for 15 years
15 years dedicated his whole life to our
nation
and they you know they told me what they
did what they did to them and i was just
like
man
it's not like
there's a cost there's a huge cost you
know and i think the cost is felt on our
uh
on our soldiers here
you know i think that the
enemy that we were fighting is not
it's not like the it's not like
you know they're not like chinese or
like russians you know these guys didn't
have drones they didn't have
bombers they don't have any of that kind
of stuff you know they they had
you know weapons that were uh
you know that they took from the
russians the 70s and running around in
flip-flops in like pajamas and uh and
the ones that fought alongside of us
believed in us that we they took us at
our word
that we would
you know
that we would honor our commitment to
them as a people and as a nation and
think about the girls and going to
school and the children and
um
my heart breaks for it
there's nothing i can do i'm a pawn i'm
a minion like in the scope of things but
uh
but i
you know i think that uh
the karma is gonna come home and it's
gonna haunt this nation you know i think
you look i look at my little children i
got
you know my fifth kid about to be born
and and i think about what does 50 years
look like
right
50 years
um
it's gonna come home
it's gonna come home to us and you could
see the hurt and you know what these
guys i'm sitting there eating dinner
with them i'm eating the foot brad i'm
sitting in there of course i'm waiting
for somebody to come out and stab like a
tenon inside of my head i'm like i
cannot believe i'm in this situation but
i show these pictures i'm like
i'm like i can't first of all they're in
like abject poverty all right they're
like in these refugee camps where it's
like no wheels on the vehicles
everywhere
and like here here you go thanks for
helping us out
and um
you know i just uh
you know i have a heart i have a heart
for people that's my life my life is
people and i see that hurt whether
they're
you know afghani or american or whatever
i see the hurt because it adds to the
global collective you know and you can
everybody can feel it they can feel the
whole world changing right now
and you know i think that hammer is
going to come home i think it's going to
hit us right in the face
you know
so
how long did you continue to work
um doing that job
with oga
yeah so i uh
i did it for almost four years um and
uh
and what was the op tempo how often were
you going on deployment how often were
you home it was i was
every
60 days to 90 days depending on where i
was and what i was doing sometimes i get
extended or whatever
um
and that's about all you could take
of that job
before he just got completely burned out
so it's a 60 to 90 day deployment 30
days home and then 30 days home
is it
yeah like when you come home how long
does it take you to reset and freaking
enjoy your life before you're like well
i gotta go back again in four days or
whatever you don't
you don't i never get out of that zone i
would come home uh
and be
i was so intense you know i was i wasn't
an intense person and i didn't have i
wasn't on facebook i didn't i'm not
i didn't live that my whole life was
isolated i have like the same friends
like the same
people you know the same job i i i
didn't like
i wasn't out there my i would come home
and i would be very distracted like i
because i always knew that i had to like
leave again and then in um
in 2014 i was in a
really significant ordeal um i i would
say it was like up there in my top
two or three events i had in my you know
military paramilitary career was uh
actually i would say it's probably the
top like it was the most
insane
gunfire and combat and carnage that i've
ever been involved in and
um
you know that's when i kind of was like
enough was enough for me i'd had enough
at that point
you know so um
and that's kind of when
my whole world fell apart really because
i didn't have that anchor anymore and
that that that had become my identity
like when that identity went away you
know i was kind of left spiraled with
all these experiences and skills and
things and now i had
no mission no purpose like uh what what
was different about that event
that
i mean you had your buddies been killed
before you'd done missions where there's
a ton of pressure you've been in gun
fights
like what was why was that particular
event the straw that broke the camel's
back
because there's no
community uh
you know you're a gun for hire
and there's no community it's not like i
come home and i'm like with the team i'm
with all my buddies i'm in my platoon i
got the people i got the things i got
this culture
i show up and i'm with different people
from different units i got two cat guys
here and a green beret here and a you
know a cct guy here i don't you know and
you become friends and you yeah there's
a brotherhood
but then i may never see those i'm gonna
even work with them again i may be over
here you know so that so when you go
home it's kind of just like oh you're
just like
you just get on the airplane i mean
when i came home
i flew through dc i still had like you
know pieces of concrete like you know i
was still banged up like and i just like
arrive home at the airport like and then
that's just it
there's no nobody calls and says are you
okay like what's going on like how's the
family
like nothing you're just
i'm living in a rural area by myself
with my wife and kids and i'm you know
there's
you feel like you have nobody does your
wife have any idea what's going on
not real i mean yeah i mean
i didn't like tell her stuff but she
could just tell um
a matter of fact when i left and i and i
resigned
i um
there and there was a lot of reasons for
that but
um
i remember my my daughter my middle
daughter said to me mom always sits in
the car and cries every day and by
herself
and i was like
about what you know like so like i went
over there and i was like why are you
crying in the car like what's going on
and she's like you're just
you're so intense
like i didn't say anything
i mean i wasn't like chatting it up but
i just radiated a form of intensity like
at any minute i'm ready to go
and
yeah i mean if it wasn't for horses and
what i'm doing right now i'm probably
i don't know i look at the state of
veterans today
and i don't think that people understand
the severity of what's happening to our
culture especially like kind of where we
come from you know and my my career is a
just a fraction of of you of you living
a lifetime in that you know
and
uh
but it has a huge impact on you long
term and we forget about those people
and like i was kind of rattling off some
of the statistics like
i mean
if you look at
having fifty thousand nonprofits in
north america for vets
fifty 000. between 2012 and the end of
2020 we spent 92 billion dollars
all right the top five nonprofits for
veterans have
billions of dollars all right there's
organizations in those top five that you
know spend 29 28 million dollars last
year on postage stamps all right 18
million dollars on tv ads all right
the the addiction rate of what i see of
guys coming and applying to my program a
couple hundred a year i can only look at
those hard numbers right but 75 of those
guys are on at least two
my maximum guy had come to heroes and
horses had was on 13 medications
last year we had a guy come
on 11 medications come off all and lose
37 pounds in 41 days in the program
right nobody cares about nobody looks at
any of those kind of things the
joblessness the suicide and then there's
a conversation about
living and being alive
we say oh this is a success story
because he didn't kill himself and i and
i've looked at guys and i told him
you're you're you're dead you're already
dead
you haven't pulled the trigger but
you're dead you're not living any form
of life
and
you know
if it wasn't if i didn't happen to
fall into i guess you could say or
or be directed i guess serendipitously
or you know
um
i don't i don't know i don't know
because i was uh
i was just i was so wrapped up in anger
you know and i felt alone in the world
because it's not like
you don't have anybody around you
you're just you're just done
you know and you realize like
you're just uh you're just a number
you are literally if the tool breaks
they throw the tool away you never hear
these stories i could tell you stories
about guys that have been shot and
busted they're you know crippled and
they're they can't even pay their bills
they're living in a one-room shack and
you know trying to get medical payments
like
contractors like it's um and then tie
that into their military career and it
just becomes this caustic cocktail
and that's why i've dedicated my life to
this because i think that there's
something special whether no matter what
you did in the military that
that you went signed up knowing that you
could die in a time of war
because you believed in something i
think people think that means fighting
for the government but i think it means
fighting for your country and fighting
for what is good
and
somewhere when that gets lost and gets
twisted i think a whole person loses
their anchor point
and they spiral out of control and
yeah i mean i
yeah so that's why today the program
that i run is it's so intensive and
when so when you got out when you when
you left that contracting job did you
have a plan
no well yeah kind of i guess i i left
because i remember i was i got home on
christmas eve and i was like putting
together all this like
my wife picks me up from the airport and
i remember i'm driving she's driving are
you living on the east coast at this
point no i'm in montana okay and uh it's
snowing out and she's driving and she
just starts like hysterically crying and
i'm like
you know what's your problem
and she's like
are you okay and i'm like yeah i'm fine
i just like i can feel your energy
coming off you you're like a furnace
right now
i was like
fun like and she's like okay like well
we gotta like you know put the christmas
stuff together and i got extended so
i've been on like a long trip
so christmas eve i go back and i
remember i'm like
it was the uh frozen
the frozen thing that's enough to drive
anyone freaking over you want to talk
about freaking snapping like i had the
frozen car like i'm trying to put the
wheels on like and i remember i was
shaking so bad and i was like i was just
so in my head
because you know after that we you know
some things happen we got to the suicide
bomb went off we had all these like
things that happened and i remember like
i just could i would i couldn't down
regulate i i mean i just couldn't down
regulate even just driving in the car i
felt like i was
there like everything was happening
around me
yeah when you said that 30 days coming
home for 30 days i can remember coming
home off of deployments and
it takes like a 30 day period to where
you're like okay
like my first deployment to iraq
we there was this big paranoia about
getting you know ied'd when you went
under bridges or were ambushed when you
went under bridges and so you know you'd
always kind of like take a little breath
before you'd go under a bridge in a in a
in a convoy
and and i remember when i came home you
know i'm like i'm like i'm not trying to
say i was freaking out or anything but
when you when when i would be driving my
car from work back home and go under a
bridge it'd be like
you'd have that just like oh yeah i
remember that just this little something
in your mind right and it would take
like a month for me to go away so i'm
thinking you're coming home for 30 days
that's not enough time to get any sort
of like
to to to to
would you say downgrade or whatever down
regularly
there's no time 30 days is not enough to
down regulate
period and when you're all you're doing
is coming home and you know you're going
on another deployment in that 30 days
you might as well i kind of feel like
you might as well not even come home
because it's just what is what good is
it going to do that's freaking crazy
it is and uh it's it's it's crazy that
the amount of work that's carried out by
contractors around the world i don't
think people understand the scope of it
especially when it pertains to like you
know the dia the nsa the cia like you
know these institutions that use
contractors um
yeah it's it's a it's a tough transition
for sure and uh i happened to uh you
know for me like going back to work you
know i started you know working on a
ranch i met some guys and so i would
kind of like immerse myself in that and
so christmas eve yeah so i kind of cut
off your story because so this is this
is you just had this sort of what you
called the biggest incident in your
career yeah i would say one of the top
three for sure like and now you get into
the freaking aluminum tube and you
wake up and you're in freaking montana
again i'm in montana and i'm like and i
remember i was trying to put
i couldn't
focus to like even put the wheels on the
thing i was just so
and i remember like i
i stayed up all night you know i got on
late i got in basically christmas
morning and like the kids got out but of
course you know they're like you know
american consumerism like ah am i tired
they're not even looking at the thing
and ripping stuff stuff like everywhere
and i'm like you know the waste like
the dolphin's gonna eat that so we're
like uh
you know and i remember like trying to
cook breakfast that morning i've been up
now for i don't know probably 48 hours
or something and
and i remember cooking breakfast and
looking out the window and i was like my
wife came over and kind of put her arm
on me you know i'm trying to like be
happy and everything
but i just looked and i was like i'm
just like
i need some more time home
you know so i email and say hey like i
need some time home and obviously like
this huge thing happened and it was huge
and like you know
the highest levels
were involved and it came overseas like
uh so like it's not like you know they
didn't know or anything and uh and
they're like well we like need you to go
back like you know take this team blah
blah and if you don't come back we're
going to dock your pet
and that's when i was like
[Music]
back to like my master chief story you
know i was like
like and i was just i was just done i
really wasn't
sure i had i had started um
you know i started my foundation uh and
and so then i did a film called 180 you
had already started your foundation i
had filed the paperwork and done i
hadn't run anything or done anything yet
but did you have a vision for what the
foundation actually was yeah and that's
evolved
significantly to what it is today
um
but yeah so and then
i ended up in
2015 running my first season which was
like come out for two weeks go home come
out for two weeks go home and so i did a
film with yeti called 180 out
um and i had met a guy
strangely enough my wife had this like
mommy's workout thing i watched a video
he's a big hunter uh mark c capp and uh
he was like sitka's main guy yeti's main
guy big archery wrote he made a video
called searching for west
and it's about him being this prolific
archer and
how his son's born and he's kind of like
thinking about why he he should be there
with him and you know so i watched this
video overseas with a bunch of guys and
he's they're like oh this guy lives in
bozeman so i send the video to my wife
she launches this like mommy's workout
thing and his wife comes
and strangely enough like so i was like
this is the guy from the video like that
this is the hunting guy and so we ended
up like meeting and he goes hey i want
to do a video on you uh yeti video and
he was making all the yeti videos at the
time like
a bunch of them and so
initially it was about me like being an
archery elk hunter or whatever
and uh and then he got to know me and
he's like hey i want to like do it on
your standing up this foundation on your
first season and that first season was
i don't know how that year didn't kill
me honestly uh
i mean it was one of the it was probably
the hardest year i've had in my entire
life uh
i got to you know i bought my house
basically broke no paycheck i started
trimming trees for a guy i'm like
working on the side like you know my
relationship was like touch and go i was
you know i started chewing horses i'm
trying to bring these vets out i'm
self-funding everything
um i am basically down to you know a few
thousand dollars in the bank account
um
and uh end up meeting a gentleman that
over over a beer totally randomly for a
friend of mine that gave me a twenty
five thousand dollar check
and before he gives me the check and i
was twenty four thousand five hundred in
debt with the non-profit and i never met
this guy before i'm on my way to wyoming
to shoot for national geographic
and i got a huge fight i'm charging up
my credit cards non-profit you're
supposed to raise money the people
donate then you use that money to do
good
i didn't really know anything about that
so i started a nonprofit and started
putting my own money into the nonprofit
and going broke
i miss that page uh
so
i'll never forget it this guy comes i
got horses on the trailer i'm heading
into wyoming to shoot for national
geographic packing some guys
but he calls me oh stop and get a beer
with this guy i'm like i can't i'm just
i'm like getting a lot of problems right
now and i couldn't pay for the vets to
come back so i had all these vets
supposed to come back and the last words
i have my wife was like i'm doing this
and i'm charging up the cards and i'm
going to finish when i start i don't
care what it costs i don't care if we
sink the whole family i'm doing this i'm
finishing this so on my way to wyoming
everybody's like hey dude it's maureen
he's like let's get a beer with this guy
and i and i refuse to refuse he keeps
persistently calling me so finally i
stop i grab one beer with the guy i sit
there i kind of talk for like i don't
know 45 minutes i was like i gotta get
going he's like can i talk to you
outside so
i go outside he looks at me he goes
he wanted to pet the one of the horses
and he's allergic so he puts a glove on
he's out there petting it both a guy
he looks and he goes you're the worst
non-profit guy i've ever met in my life
and i've been working with charities for
40 years
and i was like of course my ego is like
you know out like how dare you but
he was right i was i didn't know what i
didn't know anything and he
hands me a check
and he goes i want you to call me i
i like what you're trying to do so it
gives me it gives me a check i drive
down the road i look at it for 25 grand
and that's when i knew i was doing the
right thing
and so um
you know i think like initially looking
back i think really i was like trying to
find a way to help myself you know
and um
because i i felt so lost you know i just
i felt lost i had no purpose i had no
mission
um you know and working with horses and
shoeing horses and just that world just
took me
out of
where the focus was all on myself
and my focus became on managing these
animals and learning about them and
learning and learning about myself
through the animal
um i didn't really know that then
because my my the guys that i was with
were force fear and repetition you know
they were old school cowboys putting me
in a horse house getting bucked off and
kicked and all those things and whiskey
drinking and that was perfect for me at
the time
um
but you know through that relationship
over the years
horses became a mere reflection to who i
was you know because they're a they're a
prey animal um
and they're designed to stay away from
things with eyes in front of their head
you know they're instinctually
um
highly intelligent cerebrally very
stupid of course it's a dumb animal and
um but instinctually they're highly
evolved and so
um you know i brought these guys out i
finish out the season with them i start
the next season i start getting some
fundraising behind me i have the first
class a guy leaves the two weeks goes
home at ods and dies
army officer
and dies in his house ods
he was a lieutenant
and
so then i extended the program to
realize i still have this letter i wrote
the class and so
i extend it and today the program is now
41 days long i'll kind of skip ahead to
that but
what i realized is that
it's actually struggle that gives
everything in life value
and so everything designed for veterans
is designed to take the struggle away
like people that wanted to help me
wanted to take the struggle away when it
was the re-engaging in the struggle that
helped me re-establish a foundation and
who i
am as a person or who i was and i really
just became an identity
i lost a baseline to that connection
with myself
and you know
so many times a job is what you do but a
purpose is how you live your life and so
when that job went away i didn't have
that purpose because i never really
learned that you know
that deeper connection uh to
um something that is uh
you know i think that that that's what
makes us human i think that uh we live
inside of our minds and we live a series
of ideas and we we level up through all
these things we get some stuff and we
get some things and we get to some
places we achieve some heights
but at the end of the day when it's all
said and done
the real question is like
what is it all for
what is meaning in life and i think when
those identities fade and people stop
waving the flag and nobody really cares
that you're in the air force for 20
years and it's you know
nobody cares that you were overseas like
your kind of life kind of goes on
everything spirals out of control and
your the problem is always you
and i think that um
you know now today looking at what
happens over 41 days it's really one
long continual conversation here with
yourself
who am i as a person because
you know the average person i was
reading yesterday spends between 15 and
23 years in front of the tv okay
all right
like i started
like i started i was i was verifying it
this morning because i was like
that is the craziest thing ever because
the average person lives well let's say
80 years that's 30 000 days right so if
you spend between 15 on the low end or
23 years watching television right then
you're not working for 24 hours right
you have eight hours of sleep every day
and then you know ages one to five what
are you doing you're eating off the
floor you're pooping your pants you
don't know anything you can't even talk
right you're just like wandering around
people are stuffing you in seats and
putting weird clothes on you
right and then they do the same thing to
you when you're old right so you've got
to knock off a few years at the end
where they're putting weird things in
you and putting diapers on you and you
kind of revert back right so how much
time do you really have
well
i was just crunching some rough math so
between 37 and 38 years roughly because
you spend you know
uh
what is it 419
hours on the toilet you know you spend
you know a year and a half showering
you know there's all these other things
that you look at
i mean
the question is like
what is this all about you know and and
what i realized is that success and
failures are one and the same
you can have a success and that success
can be the worst thing that ever
happened to you and you can have a
failure that could be the worst thing
that ever happened to you because the
byproducts are the same they inhibit
growth
and they they stop evolution because you
have an experience then you perpetuate
that identity associated with that
experience and then you live and create
your future so
human beings are constantly the victim
of their own choices and everything in
society is saying no it's not your
choices it's everything else around you
and so you know over 41 days
i i always say like i don't have any
ideas for you i'm not advertising come
to me and i'm going to tell you what to
do
i said come here and i'll put you in a
place where you're going to learn what
that is and i'm not going to judge you
for whatever the outcome is because
that's your life to live that's your 37
years that you have
get off the tv but um i the state of the
american veteran is absolutely in dismal
condition
um
i didn't know a lot about nonprofits
when i started matter of fact i didn't
know anything
and along the way i've met every crook
liar in charlatan from here to the rio
grande
um because it's a it's a people make
billions off the backs of other people's
pain
i'm sorry if you serve 10 years in the
military the answer for you is not to
float in a tube and eat donuts like or
you know to go to texas and you know
shoot a deer that's tied to a tree in
front of a corn feeder like nothing's
more healing than that right like um you
know i'm sorry like and people hate me
for saying that my thing is like
you're you're
you like i don't care like because
i see it i see the state of these guys
that show up and they are completely
fractured and they've been to 15 16
institutions they're on this they've
been injected with that they're on these
pills they're on these psych meds or on
this medicaid they're on this and i look
and i'm like
the pandemic
of suicide in the veterans community
can't be understated and the numbers
like i don't even know if you would ever
even be able to find the real numbers
um really
uh but it's substantial you know and and
this whole catch thing you know 22 a day
like like if you're doing 22 push-ups a
day for veteran suicide you're an
like 22 push my kid can do a
hundred he's eight
okay like at least have some dignity and
then it's like you know you're on there
filming like hey guys vets are killing
themselves
um shout out to my sponsor for my new
t-shirt i'm gonna be doing 22 push-ups
today um new lycra by the way go online
10 use my code bob
and i mean this is the world that we're
living in and i'm like
we have to get back into the business of
developing human beings
you know we have a uh
um
we have a desire you know human beings
are now
in such a state of like hyper complexity
where everything is integrated
everything is connected that there is no
individuality there is no original
thought you become an amalgamation of
everything that you've heard and been
exposed to but you really do nothing
right
like the jury's out like wake up do hard
work learn about yourself turn the
off like meditate like you know eat a
carrot every now and then like
and and life is gonna be pretty good for
you doesn't mean it's going to be easy
but you'll have the built-in tools
and you'll begin to learn about your
higher self
and you know people can say like you
know this is like magic or whatever but
like there is like i don't care you're
in worry like you got the spidey senses
what is that what is that
what is that thing what is meaning right
what is this what is this thing meaning
that we all have we're all gonna answer
that question at some point in our life
whether you get hit by a you know
skateboarder like and whack your head in
the curb or you die in combat or you
you know eat yourself to death like
you're all going to face those those
things and to me the hero's journey is
the journey of learning about yourself
and using those tools to overcome the
external circumstances that you face
and so
like over the 41 days like we have you
know that
every guy walks at least 80 miles in the
program just to meals they'll spend 22
days in the wilderness they won't eat a
piece of sugar they won't eat dairy they
won't eat they won't have juice
they will only eat meat vegetables salt
water and black coffee
and
they will learn to meditate they'll get
into an ice tank every single day they
will start their day with mindfulness
they'll read books they'll go through
leadership courses they'll learn to shoe
horses ride horses they'll learn to see
themselves you know working with wild
mustangs they'll be put in very
dangerous situations all these are just
tools to shift focus from a person that
is always looking out for answers
to a person that is looking in for
answers
and then using those answers to then
change the material world around them
with their choices that are
authentically theirs and that's called
purpose and when you
start to do that
there's always a dragon that steps out
right in front of you right the dragon
steps out in front of you and and then
you find out how much you really want it
because everything is designed today to
keep you from knowing what you are like
social media doesn't exist if you're not
there
the internet doesn't exist if you're not
there you are the energy source that
feeds your own demise
so so you give
your energy to feed your own destruction
and then you complain about the very
thing that you're feeding
when it's always you
you're the one i always tell people like
oh god like the guys like the twitter is
the this and then you know whatever it's
like
it's like oh god he did that but it's
not there if you're not there
you feed it you are feeding and you are
clothing and you are arming your own
captors
you are and everything is designed to
keep you
sound asleep consume consume consumes
know of they know i need you to feed
what i'm building
you will serve serve serve as the cog
in a gigantic organism and you will give
your energy
40 50 years of it you get your little
plaque thanks for bob employee of the
month and and
and then what you go down to south
florida and you sit there
and you just wait
your car you're sitting in the same
traffic yeah maybe it's a ferrari so
what you're in the same traffic
yeah maybe you get a little bit of
better beef
you know maybe this one was massaged by
50 japanese ladies or whatever right it
doesn't matter
it doesn't matter because then the fear
starts to build
and then the clock just starts going the
next thing you know what are they doing
they're like
ah it's too late
it's too late
you've missed the meaning of life you've
missed it and veterans are out there
like perpetuating these identities
that's why i don't do like
you know these guys they show up and
it's just like
dude you got out in 2005.
it's
2022.
okay they're putting chips in people's
brains man
no one cares about the logistics
department
and bagram and o5
that you know may or may not have been
mortared right like
like think about the numbers you would
think that every veteran is burned and
every veteran has been amputated
fifteen hundred amputees point zero zero
zero two six percent of veterans have
been amputated there's billions of
dollars of organizations to help the
amputated billions
we got this guy a wheelchair ramp
a ramp
how about like a ramp
made of like wood
like that's like 800 bucks
right but but but this is what's
happening we have to get back to where
we start developing ourselves push
ourselves away
reunite as a community and start getting
serious about human development and
begin giving our energy to things that
matter like our food our water our
shelter
like the community around us doing
things that are good turning off that
stuff don't spend 23 years of your life
in front of the tv
like
we have to change we have to change our
minds we have to change our bodies we
have to we have to become the governors
of our own perceptions we're no longer
the governors our own perceptions
perceptions they create actions and
behaviors
and they're being governed by something
else
and
you know my message is that i don't have
the answers
but you do
and the jury's out on greatness
it's it's it's spattered on walls and
caves and books and tablets throughout
all of mankind the jury is out
know thyself
there's a reason why everybody wants
your energy because you're building an
empire and that empire just turns out
that
you're its unwinning prisoner
and you can walk away and you can let
yourself out and you can change
you can do it we can do it and i'm not
gonna sit back and be a participant and
watch generation like i'm nobody special
i'm nobody of notoriety i'm not like
all i do is i believe in the dignity of
the human experience
and there's people that have done some
really great things throughout all of
the history of mankind and they did it
by knowing themselves and then whatever
you know we love to watch the brave
hearts and we love to watch the patriots
and we love it be that person be that
person it's not about dying when being
being burned at the stake when you're
23. well do you spend 23 of your life
watching tv that's a great 23 years that
a guy like william wallace had he was
able to do that because he understood
something
giordano van bruno who was burned at the
stake by the catholic church in the
1500s for writing the pope of
he uh
he looked at them when they were going
to burn him at the stake and they cut
his tongue out and they nailed it to him
over his head they were getting ready to
burn him and try to get him to recount
you know that the you know earth
revolves around the sun and all these
things you know that was heresy
and he looked at him and he understood
the deeper meaning of life and he said
it's not his last words were it's not
eyes who is afraid it's you
and then they lit the fire
what a badass way to go you know
um
so
i've just dedicated my life to you know
right now the program is a 41 day long
program you know at the end of it we
have a lakota sweat lodge i've had the
opportunity to uh
get to know
some of those medicine men and uh you
know that's an ancient tradition that is
uh 16 000 years old that dates back
and uh and you know they say you go into
the womb of the earth and when you come
out you know
you're reborn and it's it's really like
uh
it's like an insane sauna
that has
chanting and all those other kinds of
things and you you're in there in the
heat and you kind of go the heat brings
you from the kind of physical into the
spiritual and so every guy will pass
through those windows
and they'll do a four window ceremony
upon graduation and then and then people
are like and then what
and i'm like and then go and live your
life because now you know and if you
want to go participate in those same
things
you can do it
but not ignorantly
because you know you know that wow i'm
creating my own experience like
the
the whole idea of free will i believe
is
what project earth is all about it's
about free will
well
the experiment in free will is coming to
an end
because everybody's been programmed
everyone's it's coming to an end
and
um i'm not going to let it come to an
end in my life i'm going to take power
of that because free will is powerful i
can get up from this table right now
sell my rental car illegally to a chop
shop and go climb mount everest i could
do anything anything
but people do nothing
they do nothing they don't understand
the power that they have instead they
give that unknown power away
and then they blame life and they become
the victims of this experience we can
change
we can change right now
people can change and in turn the
goodness can be restored the goodness of
this nation you know the goodness that
made you sign up and say you know what i
want to fight against evil
i want to stand again if i lose my limb
if i get burned if i give i don't care i
want to do it and and return to those
values that represent not only us as
americans but
us as human beings
and
you know that's that's that's my message
you know to the world is like that book
right there about face
wake up
and turn around and do 180 degrees from
what you're doing and your life will
change
you will change it will change and it
will change for the better take that
journey reject the easiness of life that
is being sold because it is a poison and
it is a cancer
and uh
and you will maybe you'll be rich maybe
you won't be it does it won't matter
because you will be wealthy in heart and
wealthy in mind and wealthy in spirit
you know and that's uh
you know that's kind of what i want to
share with the world
so what's this look like first question
do
horse do you need to know how to ride a
horse to show up no
no matter of fact like the majority of
guys that come have never even seen them
you know never even ridden a horse
before in their life had you ridden
horses before um when did you start
riding horses i had one horse growing up
i never i wrote it like a couple of
times and that was about my experience
that was it and then you're i'm going
for this uh yeah so it was the
introduction of horses so i ended up
meeting some uh i was uh right before i
got out so this is like 2013 i ended up
meeting some cowboys uh with horses in
the backcountry
and i got to know him and they invited
me to the right i met him out of hiking
i was just hiking with my daughter and i
met him and that's how i started
shooting horses so i first started
shooting horses with a guy
on a tip and table so they put them into
a huge machine tip them on their sides
and then i just my job was to run like
the wheel grinder and i was just like
helping out and eventually i started
learning how to shoot horses and start
colts and
these guys like i kind of thought
initially they were all about like
helping vets and all this kind of stuff
they were like the most like crooked
human beings that i've ever met in my
life like real legit crooks uh
you know because the equine business is
tough like in the cowboy world and all
that kind of stuff so
um but i did learn a tremendous amount
those guys were mentors to me you know
all that aside and then um
and then i just so then you start riding
horses all the time
every single day day in and day out yeah
i mean i uh like i said i just crossed
my 18th wilderness on a horse you know
so uh
i we have 70 horses today um and i've
been breaking and training wild mustangs
for five years now like straight from
the wild and i always tell people i'm
like if you like think you're like a
legit tough guy like you like
i will put you in there with a
completely wild horse and you're gonna
find out real quick how tough you are
because the horse is immediately gonna
sense if you're afraid
and like i had this i had this horse two
years ago
i never did quite get him i'll show you
a cool picture of him going straight up
in the air and i'm on the end of this
rope
um he's the only horse i ever had
actually like just straight up attack me
um and uh
like attack me and
what would happen was is that he would
like you know you get in there and he'd
start moving around and if you even take
one step back
they're one step forward okay because in
the horse world you know
there is uh there is a hierarchy you
know so there's the alpha male and the
alpha female and they lead the herd and
then everybody else falls subsequently
underneath so the alpha male runs roams
around looks for predators you know
keeps everybody at bay and the mayor is
leading them into food and water in the
wild they eat first they do everything
first and then it slowly goes down so
you're falling somewhere in that horse
hierarchy
and you know to think about horses a
horse is the highest vo2 max out of any
land animal on earth all right they have
binocular and minocular vision they can
see out of both eyes completely
independently the right brain and left
brain doesn't know so they're looking at
something on the left the right brain
has no idea just like my ex-girlfriend
and
so
but uh you know they uh you know when
they put their heads down they can see
almost 360 degrees while they're eating
and but they can't see four feet in
front of their nose and they can't see
four feet behind them um and a horse is
designed really to do one thing run so
they have you know 50 liters of fluid in
their stomach at any given time which
sloshes around this free-floating
intestinal system so as the horse moves
that fluid sloshes and slaps in the
diaphragm which causes them to go
to breathe in so it's boom boom so
they're they're breathing in super hard
and uh they can't breathe through their
mouth so they breathe through their nose
and their noses are flared so it's like
an air ram system
and so a horse's design like you know i
i i can be a mile away i was out in
wyoming there's wild horses on the
horseback and they can feel the
vibrations in the ground and you just
can see them on your binos they just
they sense you right so they're highly
evolved at getting away from predators
so now here comes human beings like
hello i want to ride you
and
and so you have to one become their
leader
first so you have to have an ability of
self leadership right because they can
sense that
and then
and then you know two you have to gain
their trust and you gain that trust uh
with that animal um by you know pressure
and release so applying pressure that
animal releasing that pressure and
essentially talking to them you know so
if you watch me working wild horses i
can doesn't really look like i'm doing
much but i'm controlling the direction
of that animal because in horse language
whoever moves their feet first loses
so what happens is especially with the
students when they're first working with
wild horses as the program progresses
it's a couple days they get with wild
animals
you'll see the guy
i don't know 20 year green beret or
whatever horse takes a step towards him
you'll see him take a step back well
that horse is like okay now you're my
and in the next time around he's
on you right um and you know horses are
are like people some are you know docile
some are nice some are psychotic
whatever in terms of the wild ones
and um
so yeah i had this horse and he's
uh you know i get him like finally where
i can get him saddled and everything
like that it takes me like three or four
days and i can get hands on him starting
like pick his feet up and
one day just came in and he just never
was a trusting horse and i kind of
pushed him more than i think he was
capable of at the time
and
i just kind of like he was just there so
i'm gonna let him like sulk or just let
him stand there and rest and it was a
pretty rough morning and
and i turn around and he just like rears
back and tries to strike me in the back
of my head you know i kind of like fall
for it and then he bites me on my back
you know and kind of throws me to the
side or whatever you know of course i'm
like can't crawl up the round pen fast
enough you know like i mean
that's a large beast and you know so
this was three or four days into you
working with him yeah and he so we we
adopt him completely wild uh i think 28
of our 70 horses are wild horses um i've
been been
five years ago i did a film called the
500 mile project where i rode 16 wild
mustangs um from new mexico to arizona
760 miles
um after trading them for three months
with a couple guys and it was the story
of the unpurposed horse and the
unpurposed human being and so here you
have the wild horse which is facing the
same thing as the american veteran which
is
huge government monies right so there's
there's you know 50 100 000 whatever it
is today i haven't looked uh wild
mustangs in captivity so in 1979 they
had the wild horse and burro act so they
started rounding them up off the ranch
lands
and putting them into long-term holding
facilities and today it's a 60 or 70
million dollar program
and the problem's only worsening they've
tried shooting them out of helicopters
with birth control and all these kind of
things and
and so the whole thing is a disaster and
adoption doesn't really work either it
works on a small scale but there's too
many being produced to adopt them out
so we we go there we adopt them
we sort them out we figure them out and
if you watch the film and the opening
scenes of the films is very intense i
mean these horses have never been around
people so they're terrified because
they're designed to run away from us and
so you know through a series of shoots
and sorting things
you know we pick out what we want out of
hundreds of them and then we load them
into trailers and bring them back and
then we start training them and those
are the horses that then go into the
program
so you know horse is uh is a mirror
reflection to who you are because a
horse has designed it sensing your
predatorial instincts
so you may say i'm not scared and i or
or maybe i am going to hurt you because
i'm going to be very aggressive with you
and then the animal becomes very afraid
of you now you may not be per you know
portraying that on the outside but on
the inside that's what the horse is
looking at you could look like you're
totally calm but your heart's going 140
beats a minute and the horse feels that
so then he starts thinking
what are you going to do to me and then
they'll test you because where are you
going to be on the hierarchy
and if you watch them in the pens
you know there will be this one horse
that will come along everybody's eating
as soon as he starts walking over
everybody goes away and there'll be one
horse that's like maybe i'm not going to
go and then this horse like double
barrel kicks the music yeah i'm going to
go
so you're they don't you're somewhere on
that scale
and so horses a lot of the program
happens in the 41 days with these horses
without talking
because what happens is the horse
reflects back what you really are and so
people blame the animal this horse is an
idiot
well
you're an idiot no we don't say that
sometimes i do um but
but these guys begin to realize and when
they change their internal compass
their relationship with their horse
instantaneously change it is the most
beautiful thing you see this union where
all sudden okay you're my leader you're
the alpha male or alpha mayor
and i'll kill myself for you and when a
horse believes in you that might like
some of my like rope horses and my
really good horses like the one you have
like that video i sent you or whatever
you know they'll kill themselves they
will run for you until they die they
will run through a fence they will they
will do anything for you because they
trust their leader
but a lot of guys initially are just
passengers on an animal that hates them
because they hate themselves
and they're not able to have that
internal compass
be calibrated so throughout that
relationship and throughout them
learning about horses they're really
learning about themselves through the
medium of the horse and so from day one
you know guys apply to the program it's
a really comprehensive uh application
process and it's it's 100 veterans all
veterans all veterans yep and uh it's a
it's a it's a tricky application you
know most non-profits you kind of like
fill out the thing and it's like you
know you like pretzels or peanuts like
you're welcome like thanks for like this
is like gets in your head and then you
know through that process you get
selected you know kind of rate guys one
to five you know we can only take so
many guys you know we get a couple
hundred applications a year and then and
then we send them two books communicate
with them every week help them lose
weight change their diet we send them
articles on testosterone suppression
through ssris and medications and all
these kind of unhealthy lifestyle we
help them kind of level up as they're
preparing and then when they arrive
it's uh you know kind of indoctrination
getting in the ice tanks this is how
this works this is our morning routine
so you wake up it's a mile walk in the
dark off the ranch
they walk down to the main area um
they'll you know mobility work with jim
jones so they designed their workout
program all based you know these guys
are not trying to get jacked or anything
but they some of them are like straight
off the mission of the kitchen so
you know they they like i mean we have
guys that like haven't i had a guy last
year that said he hadn't walked up a
flight of stairs in seven years all
right so now like you're entering into
like
you want i mean
pain when you're scoping out applicants
are you trying to create uh what do you
call it a class yeah so i create a class
but are you trying to create a class of
like
do you look at the people and go look
this guy's probably he's going to need
some help but he's probably going to do
well this other person's like this is a
train wreck over here or are you just
looking for train wrecks i just take the
worst of the worst okay so you're
looking for and i put them all together
and there's no science to that because
to me it's like you to get through this
you have to work as a team but it's
about the individual you're on your own
journey and you're gonna need other
people to help you along the way but i
don't care if they ever talk to those
guys again
a lot of them maintained some of the
closest friendships ever
matter of fact on the way here some guys
uh
canadian special operations sent me a
guy and uh last year and he
changed his life and this guy was in a
real bad way and
they've maintained relationships with
each other but ultimately it's about the
individual because they're on the hero's
journey and the hero's journey is that
you have to walk through those flames
you have to go through those fires you
have to feel it and so you know 4 30 in
the morning they wake up they walk a
mile down to the main camp then they
intentionally move their bodies they get
done with that
we do a meditation um and then they do
breath work the wim hof breath holding
and then they get into an ice tank and
then that scales up till you know the
end they're sitting there for like 10
minutes
and
that's pretty rough on guys that are
like straight off like and then and then
it's all about horses and so then in the
evening we have what we call the uh
um the maxim lab which is a leadership
course based on stoiism so i don't tell
them any ideas i'll present a question
what does it mean you know choose to be
harmed in your harm choose not to be
harmed and you haven't been what does
that mean and guys will go around and
let them talk things out and so
throughout the program they'll do that
for 40 days and then after uh after six
days they'll head into the backcountry
for eight days they are given a horse
and a mule so wait six days they've been
there yep they've been doing this
routine they've been learning about
horses well at this point everybody can
lope a horse and get a dead run
everybody can you know rain control
their horse and pack a mule
and understand equine medicine trucks
trailers all that kind of stuff uh they
get all that in six days so it's very
intensive those are some long days
extremely long days um matter of fact
like
there was like a guy the vet came out
and he's like
um like there's like guys sleeping like
right next to the horse i'm like i know
guys come on we're not in the military
now we have to stand up
and like
but but so six days of so the beginning
of the program they're there they're
getting all this good stuff that you're
giving them and they're only eating like
meat
vegetables what do you say salt water
and coffee that's it okay there's no
juice there's no dairy there's no honey
nothing no and and then after six days
of that then it's we're going in the
wilderness yep on horseback with the hor
you on your horse and your mule correct
as a team as a teacher and then those
guys they're paired together eight guys
in the class they're paired together and
they've got to pack their own stuff and
then of course there's camp gear and all
that stuff we have duties all lined up
for everybody and that's a progressive
trip so there is no main camp so every
day they pack up and move okay so um you
know all ultralight stuff you know most
of the time i never use a 10 i'm just i
just sleep out unless it rains
um and they'll spend eight days we'll do
like around 80 or 90 miles on that trip
then they'll come back and they'll start
the next morning what's called ranch
week so now they're going to learn how
to rope they're going to we have you
know cows they're going to learn how to
rope cows how to do stock management
they're going to learn more advanced
riding they're going to learn
how to work on a range how to be in a
working ranch and so that's called ranch
week it's all about ranch stuff
they'll drive tractors and they'll learn
all these things in different groups
throughout you know the whole facility
then a lot of times we'll move we'll go
to another ranch we'll help them gather
and sort and ship cows and do stuff
depending on what's going on so that's
ranch week and then they start you know
i guess you could say like phase two or
something where there are another six
days of training so that training is
blacksmithing so they'll learn how to
shoot a horse they'll learn how to trim
learn how to pair they'll learn equine
medicine they'll work with wild mustangs
they'll do a cold starting they'll do
raining they'll do more advanced riding
they'll do roping well they'll actually
rope live cows and they'll learn how to
you know how to manage them how to
operate on a working ranch in terms of
all the agricultural components and
they'll learn more packing and learn how
to probably know seven eight ten animals
at a time pull them together how to
drive trucks how to drive trailers how
to do chains how to run chainsaws how to
run accidents all those kind of things
and then and then they'll head into the
backcountry for 11 days
um and then that's how many days deep
are we into this program right now uh
like is the 11 days 30 days or something
so is the 11 days sort of like the final
days in the field yeah and that's a
tough trip like it's tough on me
it's tough like you know 11 or 12 days
in the wilderness like that
progressively moving wears on you
plus the animals have their own
personalities and there's you know we
run our stock
loose so we tie you know we hobble them
and we turn them loose in the mountains
and so you know you got to get up and
you got to gather in the morning it's
cold it's snowing in august you know all
those kind of challenges last year we
rode across the wind rivers we did 120
miles across one river range
and that was a brutal trip it was
incredible but it's just tough and then
you know you're shooing horses you're
constantly where you're building camp
you're cooking everything
and it's all this you know like whole
food stuff so guys are
it's a tough trip and then they lead
every day so every day a different guy
leads he has the map he has the routes
he makes all the decisions i let him
fail i let him fall flat on their face i
let him make mistakes as long as
nobody's going to get hurt and let them
feel that
take you know ownership of all those
kind of you know that leadership
component and confidence and stuff and
so um
and then they get back and then when
they get back from that trip obviously
everyone's decimated so the average guy
last year lost 20 pounds in the program
um our record that last year was um 37
pounds in 41 days
and uh yeah and then and then the med
countless 11 psych meds guy a guy walked
away from so um and then of course you
have the guys on the onesies and the
twosies and stuff like that
so they get back then we wake them up at
one o'clock in the morning they usually
get to bed around 10 that night after we
because you know horses come first so
you got to doctor horses clean horses
you got to do shoes you got to do all
those things and then we'll wake them up
drive them to a mountain make them climb
sacagawea peak so 10 000 foot peak in
the dark
because the metaphor is that nobody
really cares what you just accomplished
because behind every mountain is another
mountain and so we want them to feel
that and in that video you can see the
guy standing on that peak and then one
guy's kind of rubbing the other guy in
the back you know none of that's
acting or anything you know that was a
real emotional moment because
they have lived a lifetime
and it is real life it's not like you're
coming here and this is fake life and
now you're gonna leave and go back to
real life it's all real life there is no
fake life right it's all real right you
put the virtual reality goggles on for
nine hours that's real life right right
it's not time doesn't stop and so um
they climb that mountain they come down
pack up all their gear and then the next
day is graduation day so then they get
into the sweat lodge so they graduate
get into the sweat lodge uh they go
through that we do some sound stuff with
them
and then we have a year-long take-home
course called stay the course where the
guys have diet reading you know
suggested reading you know fitness stuff
access to an app
and kind of like you know whole food
eating and stuff like that
and uh and then the guys that want to we
plug them into an internship and then
they go for four to six weeks to alaska
wyoming montana utah they go to work in
ranches they go to cowboy outfits they
go to outfitters and you know in the
yukon
um and at this point in their life
when they're done
they've moved on and i had an
interesting guy this year who came
straight out of the marine corps
basically like weeks
and came here
and
he showed up and he was like straight up
like ranger rick you know yeah they're
like the oakley's on you know you had
the
just like you were like he's straight
everything was the military everything
was the military
when he left
he
[Music]
had left all his military clothes in a
garbage bag had you know cowboy hats
like the whole thing and had
essentially he's been worked under he's
mexican i got him i happen to know a
team guy buddy of mine
awesome guy
and
who works for a guy that has a ranch in
mexico so he's been ranching in mexico
like his whole life is like completely
different i think what would happen if
more people got out and immediately took
on the next challenge
in their life in the face of everything
and where would they be today
and you know that's my overarching goal
is that like
you know the sweat lodge is a super
powerful thing and it can be terrifying
how hot does the sweat launch
really hot
like
like like really hotter than normal
sauna hot oh yeah yeah so so so the
rocks that they use they go out and
gather the rocks they're lava rocks they
haven't been heated up since the last
you know younger driest impact
their last major volcanic
eruptions and you know they put them in
there and there's a lot of drumming and
songs um they honor everything the water
and the earth and all those things um
and it's called the anipi wakan which is
one of like seven sacred ceremonies so
like the sun dance which is hanging by
your
flesh uh from a pole uh for three days
with no food or water and then um to
come off that they hook buffalo skulls
to you
and you have to run into the desert
until they rip out of your back
um these guys have all done this
numerous times um and then there's the
you say these guys you're talking about
the
guys that you work with yeah and uh they
um
they're some of the they're some of the
deepest most special people that i've
ever met they are people that when you
meet them you're like these people are
good they're like good peo like there's
a wholeness to them
that is um attractive like there is a
balance to them and uh so these guys of
course are terrified you know
everybody's like you go into this little
tiny lodge and you're in there you can't
see your hand in front of your face and
it the heat begins to increase in the
songs and they um you know they welcome
in you know all kinds of different
things and animal spirits all that kind
of stuff and when you come out how long
are you in there for um well the door
open closes four times but the whole
thing's like a couple hours
and uh so then there's the then there's
the vision quest where you go in there
for 24 hours with no food or water alone
that's uh and then there's the four days
we've had people on our ranch that grown
up there for four days with no food or
water by themselves in the mountain and
they sit up there
um in the sweat lodge no
so that's one of the other rights
so the sweat lodge was banned in north
america until 1976.
it was illegal
uh matter of fact dancing was illegal
native american dancing was illegal so
when columbus arrived in a north
american continent there were 60 million
natives here at the start of world war
one there was 800 000 left
in buffalo
almost 60 million had been killed to
almost to extinction
so those rights were banned and it was
illegal a matter of fact it was illegal
to carry those names unless you were
like on a reservation
so there's a real uh tradition in
history you know you're not taking
psychedelics or anything like that it's
the heat
and uh and it's the prayers and it does
change you and it leaves an impact and
the first time i ever did it i'll tell
you right now like i was ready to like
dig my way out of there like i did not
like it because your mind's like
of course i start watching youtube
videos you know i'm like oh no like i
get it i was like huh i'm gonna die i
can't get out sdv like no
and
like i'm back in the black tube of death
and and i uh
it's had such an impact on me i've done
eight of them now
and uh
you know i've really like uh learned i
guess like
in a way to honor myself like in a way
that is uh you know my mind my body my
spirit by like what i eat
and how who i am in relationship with
who i expose my my life to my energy to
like what i put my intentions towards
like
all these things begin to kind of open
up to you as the weeks in of your life
go on and uh so it's something that
we've integrated into the program that's
been really effective and
do you hallucinate
is that what you're talking about so
like i had uh interesting i i guess you
could say not every time every time it's
been different not one has been the same
uh some have been like incredible other
ones i feel like i just suffered like um
they're all different um but i actually
had a really interesting thing is that
like i
was in there and
i saw a baby in the womb appear over the
fire
and but there's no fire that's a
hallucination i think
well um i think i'm not sure though
uh
it there's no fire the rocks are just
red but you can't really see them then
they're in this hole
so there's no fire it's hot rocks and
they keep and then people open the door
and bring them in and put them in there
and then they have buffalo horns and
they add the water
they keep dumping water on it with
buffalo horns and they're singing drums
and chanting and stuff
and i saw like a baby
in the womb like in a fetus and it
appeared like over the fire and i
thought like oh man like
i'm
like
the children like are dying or something
i don't know i had this like thing and
then like a week later my wife found out
she was pregnant um
and
then i instantaneously knew like that's
what i saw i knew that i would have
another child
and i don't believe that children come
from you i think they pass through you
and you know i think they're here for
particular times i think we can become
derailed as human beings um because we
you know we get enticed you know by
gross materialism and all these things
that detract us from ourselves and then
somebody else has got to come along um
but yeah so so that experience has been
powerful so i added it to the program
and people are always like so what book
did you read who did you do like what
did you i'm like nothing zero it's just
my own journey it's the all the things
that i've done in my life that have
helped me
um really become
united with myself i had become homesick
from who i was as a person whether it
was the wild and crazy religious stuff
of the day or you know cast in the
demons or whatever or it was the
military or was the agency or it was all
these other experiences um you know i
had lost a footing
and a connection to myself and now that
that connection and that link has been
restored
um you know
i
feel a balance that i've never felt
before in my life i
you know i always tell people i'm like i
don't have a retirement i i don't have
any
um 401k i told my kids i'm not paying
for your college and i'm not buying you
a car like i'm not doing any of those
things
but i will build an ecosystem here and
teach you how to hunt and how to work
the land and how to honor the animals
and do all those things and i will
support you but you're gonna have to do
it yourself
and
you know i'm not gonna if i go tomorrow
and they're like you got cancer i'm like
okay
i'm going out like bob marley like i'm
just gonna be like all right cool you're
not poking me and sticking me or doing
anything i'll just like
i'm not you know so
these experiences have
given me a connection
to a place where you find true peace it
doesn't mean the world around you is
peaceful
but and it doesn't mean you're weak and
you're some kind of like you know
snowflake or whatever
it's a it's a balance that you when you
read about the great warriors the the
the sun zoos and you read the tao jings
and you read about the alexander the
greats and you read about the peoples
that ulysses and all these great people
there was a balance they had they were
artists they were calligraphers they
would also kill you in 57 different ways
but not out of anger
not out of hate
and they were such a place of balance
and so you know my life now is about
restoring that balance and then bringing
that balance to other people but i can't
do it for you and over the course of 41
days
you know it is a is is a conversation
how much
do you do really want it more often than
not we fall in love with getting in
shape you know
we fall in love with being healthy or we
fall in love with you know having things
or whatever
but we don't like the idea of what it
takes to get there
you know we don't like that we don't
like to feel uncomfortable and and we
have to become comfortable in the
uncomfortable and in turn the things
that are holding you back
they dissipate and go away you know so
that's what the 41 days is about
yeah you know what you and i didn't talk
before you showed up here today and and
so when like i was putting together
your words and i'm glad you've hit this
a couple times today and i'm
i i wasn't 100 sure but certainly
i was pretty confident that idea that
you
are
introducing situations to people that
then they figure out like what the
answers are to their questions and then
you said it multiple times today like
hey i don't have the answer for you and
i can't tell you what to do here what to
do there
but i can take you to a place where
you're going to start looking and you're
going to start looking inside and you're
going to start asking some questions and
finding the answers
yeah it's exactly and that that's
everybody is trying to tell you how to
be you know like you go to tony rob you
know i don't want to dis tony robbins or
anything because he's like probably able
to send assassins after me
but like
good luck to those assassins
yeah bring it i dare you um but yeah
like they're gonna track you up in the
mountains on force back themselves are
you kidding me tony ain't coming there
dude i dare you to challenge you tony
um but
you know
like people get so fired up and they get
so amped up and they spend their life
watching all this stuff and all these
things and going to these things but
they don't actually do anything
if you did one tenth of the information
that's contained in your brain you
wouldn't be in the situation you were in
we just become addicted to getting more
information you know it's like you know
12 steps to purpose like oh man like
you're going to get to the end and it's
12 it's like whoo but then what's the
guy come out with nine steps you're like
oh i gotta get the other book
there's only nine like you know like now
he's got he's got he's got nine more
books to write uh
to me the jury is out on what it means
to really be a human but we've lost that
we've lost that knowledge
um
in pursuit of a construct that if i if i
get to the end of an idea that never was
mine in the first place i'll achieve
some end state right i'll retire or um
i'll achieve happiness you know maybe
it's a it used to be in the 80s you know
become a millionaire now if you're a
millionaire who gives a a million
bucks like i mean it's like a million
bucks is like nothing nowadays right you
know
it's what was it like they had that
spending bill or whatever it's like if
you took one trillion dollars and you
stacked it on end to end go a third of
the way to the moon okay so 3.5 trillion
goes to the moon and part of the way
back
right like
so but there those things like
that really matter in life are
are your food your water your shelter
and your relationships in your life
and
um if you're not in balance with those
things there's not there's no things in
life that are going to help you find a
place of completion because eventually
you will face the man in the mirror
you will eventually
no matter what no matter how many cards
no matter what it is like i was using
the example of like warren buffett was
like laying in the desert and dying like
about to die and i came like walking by
with some water
and i was like hey warren
give me all the money that you have
and i'll give you this water he would
take it he would 100 take it he wouldn't
be like
no he'd be like
like he'd want it right so it puts
everything in relative perspective and
the most exciting adventure you can go
on is the adventure with yourself
that is the most exciting adventure and
then your whole life opens up we spend
our time like
in shitty relationships with shitty
people afraid to change and jobs that we
hate doing things that we don't want to
do to get to places that we never wanted
to go in the first place and then we
play and then when
i was using the exam i'm like okay
if you're depressed
okay and everyone's like you know this
for a while was like the mental health
month and the men all this mental health
stuff was going on like crazy
like you know everyone's like hey guys
mental health month i'm you know
skydiving for mental health like i'm i'm
um i'm conducting a uh boxing clinic for
mental health and bringing awareness to
it and and mental health so then you're
like i'm depressed it's like okay i'm
depressed so then you go to the person
that's in charge of the construct
and they say what's the matter you don't
like your life
well i don't know something's wrong
they're like hmm
well we're going to give you some things
to get you back to work okay we're going
to get you back in love with the very
thing that you hate it's never something
is wrong with the thing the construct
itself it's always something wrong with
you
so then you're like okay so you take the
stuff and you feel good for a while and
you're like butterflies and everything's
going around but then it wears off in
six months and you go back
and then the people tell you okay we
gotta get you back in love we gotta get
you back to work we gotta get you back
undepressed it's never about making
massive lifestyle changes like
it's never about throwing the keys away
getting radically committed to yourself
it's always about changing you to get
you back in love with the very thing
that's causing the depression
right it's never about like radical
change it's always like
you have a chemical imbalance so i'll
give you some chemicals to get you back
in balance
that'll work
by the way 79 bucks a month
and and so i think that like we have to
stop
like we have to pump the brakes like you
know
we have to return back to the basics of
what it means to be a human and and you
know my work with veterans is like
they're basically involved in a
socialist system right they show up to
an institution it's a one-size-fits-all
right my greater goal is to create a
board of the smart innovators people
that that maybe there's a wellness arm
like a fedex for veterans right and the
post office doesn't work where guys can
say you know what red pill blue pill
six weeks in therapy meds this that
counseling for ten years all these other
things institutions meetings or whatever
or or maybe there's an eight-week
program i'm going to go to that will be
the suckiest thing i've ever done in my
life
it'll be the true hero's journey but
when i come out the other side
i will have learned what i am and i will
take that knowledge and i will begin to
change the world around me with my own
energy my own impetus and my own
identity from the inside out
we should give people that opportunity
but instead you know you show up to
these like you said these false prophets
that what are they there really really
to do
yeah what's scary about this is
so much of the stuff that that people
get like prescribed or advised
it actually you know in in some of the
talks that you you talk about like
peeling away layers to get to you
all those other things are actually
added layers they're adding layers on
top of layers on top of layers
that seem to smooth things over for a
month or you know three months or
whatever and then all of a sudden that
whatever's in there is starting to burn
through and
caused you know caustic material to rise
the surface and so you're like wait a
second i don't know if this is it so you
go back and they say cool oh oh you got
a little uh friction coming out little
caustic materials coming up cool let's
put another layer on that and put
another layer on that and then we you
know what are you going to put over
yourself you're going to put you know a
car or a watch or whatever
expensive item that is another layer on
top of this
it's not a solution
no it's not it's not us
it's like this is i so i just went
through yesterday with my wife we like
threw out like
a ton of stuff right because the
average american household has over 300
thousand items in it okay
and i walked in there you have a weird
like a nerdy freaking uh uh what is it
statistical analytical mind well listen
i actually just watched like a thing
when i was traveling back from florida
about these like minimalist people or
whatever and they you know of course
went in there and it's like and i told
my wife so we're down in florida and
what does she want to do she's like
obsessed with the goodwill we don't buy
anything new nothing and the kids
nothing new zero everything we buy use
or you know will or whatever
but that in and of itself is an
addiction right because i'm like she's
like oh my gosh i got this flannel i'm
like you have like 90 flannels
she's like i know but this one was like
three bucks and i'm like
that's the problem right like you don't
need that right so so we went we were
like okay
once a week we're going to target one
portion of the house and get rid of
stuff so yesterday
we threw a we were taking to the
goodwill we i mean i don't we took out
an entire like ford expedition full of
things okay
and then like we were done at like three
o'clock afternoon and i looked around
and i was like it doesn't even look like
we took anything out
i mean like how many potato peelers did
we have i was like we have like nine
potato peelers meanwhile in ethiopia i'm
like
i'm like we had so many things and what
do things represent their measurements
of time
they're measurements of time because you
have to have time
expended and energy to get that thing
right and so
then i get this thing and then there's
always another thing that you need to
get well the attachment for the mixer
that goes on the thing that does the
pasta like you know what doing that
but like well it's an extra 10. you know
we'll add it on there
and so we started going through and just
getting rid of tons of stuff you know
and and the scariest thing is going to
be like going to my closet you know like
and and realizing that wow i've spent a
lot of time in my life getting these
things and i'm like never have time i
had a time i don't have enough time what
am i doing with my time i'm using my
time to get things that i don't need
and so it's like gandhi was asked the
question what confuses the most about
modern man he said modern man spends all
his time to get money then spends all
his money to get his time back
that's i mean that's pretty profound
right like
and um i remember running that calculus
i was like a young well not not a young
seal but i'd been in the teams for a
while and there was people i guess as
sort of maybe remember the adventure
racing things as that started coming out
but then
and then that became sort of extreme
sport and like that whole thing
and then i thought to myself man
uh people like work hard to get money to
pay for to learn how to skydive or scuba
diving i get to do that that's just
freaking cool like i thought i had the
whole system beat man it kind of did a
little bit you know it's like hey man
i'm doing you're working your ass off to
go do this i'm literally getting paid to
do that stuff in the first place
i i
one one thing that i
that i think was probably
it might be
it's a very important part of my life um
when i was in the teams
my first platoon and i like
figured out to take a step back and look
around
i call it detachment now because i don't
know that's the word that i figured out
to call it but like
you're in a situation there's going
on and no no one's making a decision and
i like learned hey take a step back look
around and you'll be able to see
infinitely more than if you keep staring
down the the sights of your weapon or
whatever
and i learned that clearing
oil rigs and training and then i started
applying it and everything i did but but
then at some point i started applying it
to like you know having a conversation
with my platoon chief my platoon chief
starts getting mad about something i'm
thinking instead of me being in the
moment like in my own head getting mad
back and escalating the situation and
all of a sudden i'm yelling a yelling
match with my chest and i never did that
i'd be like oh hey got it chief and i
would take a step back and and i feel
like that was helpful and is helpful to
me
i guess all the time because i'm always
like taking a step back and saying hey
what am i really doing like what's what
am i what's driving this
me to do this particular thing or what's
making me do this other thing or why am
i not doing something else
and it seems like uh when you go into
these extreme situations
it's another time where it happens like
when you're freaking dog ass tired
or you're freezing cold
and you know it's like i was telling
that story about my my uh sdv buddy that
was just like i don't want to be doing
this anymore
and you take that step back do you feel
anything like that like in these sweat
lodges where
bro you can only suffer so much and then
you got to just like take a step back
and look at your whole life
except yeah you have to let go
see it's like you have it's it's the art
of like letting go it's the art of
detaching like
and that's when
you go from that kind of physical to
spiritual
where where you're no longer holding on
to anything and you're just being
and that's when
we spend so much time asking and wanting
things
but no time
listening just
being still and listening
well
you know
in those places the you know i'm like
you know your mind's going a million
miles an hour and you're like i gotta
get like all these things like ah this
things are popping up everywhere i don't
know betty i wonder if she's uh who's
bed and like i don't like all these
things are coming right
and and then all sudden when you when
you learn to quiet your mind and be
still and begin to listen the things
that you need for your life
out of the nothingness comes to you
i don't know how to explain it
scientifically or like in a lab or like
whatever but i'm telling you right now
the the
if you look at like jesus for instance
right like jesus really like i mean
jesus wasn't a religion okay jesus
basically said love your neighbor as
yourself
well to love
yourself you have to know who self is or
you only love the idea of self so you
have to know what yourself is right and
then
the kingdom of god
it's in you
okay it's actually within you and then
like those leaders of the day he's like
by the way those dudes are liars
and they're gonna kill me
but you know whatever so he was a
cataclysm he was a nuclear bomb dropped
on culture of the day okay so we think
of cataclysm we think of meteorites or
floods or earth fractures or whatever
solar flares
but a powerful idea that speaks to the
core of who we all are as people is a
cataclysm and he was a cataclysm of the
day but his message was simple right you
have to love what you have to you have
to love yourself well you have to know
who itself is and you have to love
yourself then you have to love your
neighbor the same way
right and then
the kingdom of god is it's in you it's
it's in you so you have to go within and
so what does he do he goes up there and
he doesn't have food or water for 40
days right and then you know they kill
him
and then by the way he comes walking
through walls like by the way you never
die
okay
thanks for the message right
i mean that's the message like if you
look at through all about history
it's always the same know thyself it's
inscribed in the oracle of delhi and
every year we have a different saying at
heroes and horses that's on the belt
buckles that the guys get when they
graduate this coveted belt buckle
and uh everyone they have a different
saying in this year is kind of is the
saying is know thyself and um
uh you know one year we had think
greater than you feel you know we have
all these other ones
but know thyself and i think that's just
gonna kind of stay there forever now i'm
done making up slogans uh
i i think like
know thyself is a is a powerful thing
right and so that is inscribed in gold
at the oracle of delhi 1400 bce it
hasn't nothing has changed except for
know thyself i'll caveat that or else
other people that actually know what you
are will use you to create their own
kingdom and enslave you
that's that's what it is this is this is
this is reminding me of a uh i don't
know we were doing a podcast a while ago
and we got asked a question
so it was like legit i think it was
legitimate dating advice someone was
asking or they got dumped or something
like this that's heartbreaking and so i
was saying and i've given this answer a
few times on the podcast hey when you're
when you get dumped and you get broke up
and you're all heartbroken
i i try and explain that like hey the
person that you were in love with
that cheated on you or that you know ran
away or whatever they did
the person that you were in love with
actually didn't exist
they didn't exist that girl that seemed
so sweet but then she cheated on you or
whatever
you were in love with this idea of this
person and and now it's gone you have to
accept the fact that the person that
you're in love with actually didn't
exist in it it kind of is a good thing
you go oh wait a second
i'm all heartbroken now who am i going
to marry now who am i going to spend the
rest of my life with oh no actually the
person that i thought i was going to
marry and the person i thought was going
to spend the rest of my life with didn't
exist
that this girl was not a good person and
now i got to learn that now i can move
forward but what i'm relating this to
what you're talking about
is when people
look at themselves and they got this
idea of themselves that they're kind of
maybe not in love with but they at least
like yeah you know i'm this or i'm that
i'm a fighter i'm a soldier i'm a wall
street dude or whatever
you are you have this idea of yourself
like hey you know i kind of love who i
am
and then there's something going on
where you actually don't love that
person and cause you know that that
person that you're portraying doesn't
actually exist it's a projection it's a
projection and so that's a rude
awakening and i think that can be a rude
awakening when someone gets out of the
military
and is all of a sudden saying oh the
person that i was which was a soldier a
sailor an airman or marine one that
person all of a sudden they literally
don't exist anymore
and you can try and hang on to it
but it's got it's it's not going to be
there you don't
like you said you don't have
your friends you don't have a word you
don't have a platoon anymore
you don't have a platoon anymore it's
think about how heartbreaking it is when
you don't have a platoon anymore it's a
freaking horror show it's everything i
love a single platoon and all of a
sudden you don't have a seal platoon
anymore you don't have it doesn't exist
anymore for you
and so you can't you you have to figure
out okay what what am i really
and you gotta dig in there and figure
that out and you know i think for me
again
i was always like a rebellious kid
growing up blah blah blah and i always
was like questioning myself and
i don't know i think when when even when
i was in the seal teams like
there was
i'd look at some leadership and be like
this guy's
whatever this this guy's not me right
this guy's legitimately not me like i
know who my guys are i don't know what
we're like but that guy's he's not
really one of us and there's a bunch of
people that aren't really one of us so i
always kind of felt that and it was okay
when okay now i'm gonna move on to my
next job or whatever i got out of the
navy retired from the navy
but
man
trying to figure out trying to make sure
that you know who you are
and make sure that who you are isn't a
construct i just used your word of the
day construct i normally don't use that
word that's an interesting word i don't
normally use that word
that construct that you built
it might not be for real
and if it's not for real that's gonna
it's gonna sting and all but it's gonna
sting it's going to hurt but cool now
you know that now you can figure it out
now you can get in there
start doing work baseline
you got to hit the you got to hit the
bottom of the bowl
you know where where the projection
doesn't protect you anymore listen you
can you can dress up all day and put on
the mma stuff or whatever and until you
know you get freaking spun kicked in the
side of your head and then the
projection doesn't work anymore right
like and that's life we're all you know
everybody's living some form of
projection at some point in their life
and
you know the thing is as those
projections fade you become depressed
and you become disenfranchised and and
the thing is like you don't have to be
if you have one job really in your life
is to wake up and just be yourself
and then you can't fail
it's impossible like sure it doesn't
mean i do dumb i do dumb i say
things i have a second guess myself oh
i called my wife i should have
never said that she's like honey and
but then she's like it doesn't matter
because that's just how you are just be
okay with that and so you just if
everybody just woke up and just and just
where there's authentic self the entire
world would be a completely different
place like think about
like think about filters think about a
filter on a cell phone right you got
some like lady where like you know the
botox is failing shit's going down
probably was hot ex-husband's in dallas
like you know but you know she's kind of
like this she's got a little droopy and
then and then she puts the filter on
you're like boom right in love with the
projection of themselves you know it's
like the worst thing is you see
everybody
sitting on the bus and i'm sitting on
the bus you know the today and
everyone's like you know you can see
them over there like liking they're like
and they're like this they're like
l-o-l-l-o-l like heart heart lol like
happy smiley face right like they're the
saddest looking people you know dudes
like bellies are gross or mask is on
crooked you know their hair is up
they got two cell phones lol lol lol
right it's all a projection
it's a total projection and so
like we have to stop being projections
and get back to the basics of who we are
but unfortunately we put projections in
these places where we try to
be like somebody else rather than being
ourselves and that's destroying the
fabric of humanity
and you know if you look at you know you
look at chinese culture um
they're all simulated
everyone's wearing the same clothes
everyone's doing the same things
everyone's serving the same people
they're all born from chinese mothers
they're all you know they all have this
they all have this plan in place this 10
000 year destiny okay what are we trying
to do we're trying to like you know
we're trying to make the rent you know
we're trying to like you know we're
trying to pass the bill you know we're
trying to you know you look at these
people well i don't want that either
that is a nightmare there is no
individuality like what do you exist you
exist to serve the state well you exist
here in north america to serve the
projection
the projection i'm going to go why i'm
going to buy the car so that when people
see me
they'll think i'm successful even though
i work at in and out which i'm not no
dings on in and out
you actually props to the in and outs
oh yeah by the way didn't they just do
some great stuff or something they
wouldn't do them
covey backs or something i don't know
shout out to the in and out okay good
burgers but like you know or whatever
like you you but like you'll see people
will buy things and do things and extend
themselves to a point to to fulfill a
projection and it's so empty because
there's never enough
there's always a new thing there's
always another thing and so your whole
life is giving you projection and that's
why people are the quintessentially lost
they're they're literally
have
their self standing next to them in
their life and they're completely in the
material realm everything is material
the five senses there's nothing else
beyond that so in that case i have to
chase these projections down get that
one
get the next one get the next one so on
and so forth that's why like filters and
all those things like they're cancer
because they they they are nothing more
than a project you don't look like that
you don't you're not that way it's like
a crate it's if you take a step back and
think about this
hey i gotta
when i send a picture to my friends
i'm gonna run it through a computer
program that makes me look better like
that's a crazy thing it's so
that's a crazy thing yeah because it
because it and it drives
it it's put us into all forms of chaos
as a society right like where
i mean you think about
you know this whole thing on climate
change everything that's happening in
the world is like i think the debate is
like are we causing climate change or
are we just destroying the environment
right well we are 100 destroying the
environment um
and for what
so you can have like another table
another
mahogany
table
okay like or more diamonds you know
because i love you and i want you to
have this diamond that was mined by
children
in africa and smuggled over here so that
we can be together for a year
and then you can take half of everything
i have but you know
it's this whole bizarre thing where it's
like we don't even care about
anything except for enforcing our own
projections so it's like hey maybe we
shouldn't like chop down every tree
because maybe when i breathe out the
tree breathes in with tree breeze out i
breathe in maybe we shouldn't be dumping
the chemicals into the rivers what is
that almost every river in north america
now contains glycophade in it right so
it's bleeding in from
npk from mass farming and agriculture
the soils dying i mean i'm with ranchers
i'm in rural i'm in agriculture people
that's my life
and
you you listen to these old guys kneel
down and pick up the soil dead right and
where is all this stuff going where is
all these things going
what's happening around us
uh is that people only care about their
own projections and the very things that
give them life they're destroying to
further something that does only exist
fictitiously as an idea
and it's a scary time to be living in
right now it's like you know here we are
like ukraine like russia like look out
like wow like they're coming they're
gonna get us ah like the russians and
and it's like
okay
but you're really concerned about their
borders but like
what about like our borders
like aren't those important too no
only the ones in ukraine right and and
it's it's you get sold these illusions
and and in turn we destroy every single
thing around us including ourselves
and
if we don't change
we are coming into an epoch we are
coming into a time
a real time
that we will become unrecognizable to
ourselves and when i see guys coming and
they're on 11 medications they're on
eight medications or been in therapy for
ten years now they're
unrecognizable to themselves they are
unrecognizable they look in the mirror
they don't know what they are they only
exist as a projection of an identity
and you know
yeah it's like i'm sorry for the doom
and gloom y'all no
believe me
you
listen to this podcast a little bit more
we got dude
i mean there is like there is like a
1940s like machete
the the weird thing is
is as you look at this stuff
in a large scale
all these things are in place
and you you know when you just were
saying that about vets
and you're on a bunch of medications and
you're
being
basically subdued you know you're being
subdued and it's not just vets it's like
humans
humans are being subdued look we don't
really actually want you to do anything
we don't actually want you to come up
with your own ideas we don't actually
want you to write your own freaking
books we don't want you to create
something what we want you to do is
continue to feed our machine that we've
got working over here that's what we
want we want to feed our machine and we
don't want you to feed your own machine
and that that's
that's like what is actually happening
because people spend as i don't know
what the what'd you say 37 years in
front of a screen or whatever it was
yeah you're not gaining when you're
doing that that's not that's not for you
that's for them that's so they can sell
your they they can sell you to whoever
their advertisers are so you can buy
more of their stuff that's what's
happening it's your energy they need
your energy
see
everything is energy
they need you and i say they
okay like
corporatocracies governments whatever it
is marketing companies data capture
people whatever
you see they need your attention and
your attention is your energy and that
is the impetus for them to grow but if
you're using your own energy
to do your own thing
that's problematic that's scary that's
really scary scary for them right it's
terrible and they can't have everybody
running around so what do they want you
running around with a projection you
need all these things to help your
projection
and it is cr
this is uh like almost cliche right now
it's cliche for me to say what i'm about
to say there are
free psychologists and scientists and
computer programmers or whatever they're
called
sitting
figuring out
literal ways to make
you look at the screen more
to addict you to that that's what
they're actually doing they're actually
doing that they're actually doing that
and here by the way you're paying them
to do it in many ways you're actually
giving them money to do this so that
they can get you to not think for
yourself
and i'm not saying like oh think for
yourself come up with some crazy no
think for yourself like actually think
about what's going on around you instead
you're just receiving what someone else
is telling you which what they're
telling you to do is waste more time
looking at this and and and to buy
whatever product it is that they're
making this is what what's actually
happening
think about like what have you heard of
the milgram experiments oh yeah it's
crazy right yeah what two thirds of the
people killed the person because
the guy in the white coat told them to
right
so it's already figured out we already
understand how to like corral human
beings and to get them to give their
energy and focus into developing what
whatever it is is vying for your
attention it needs you it doesn't exist
without you
i mean our founding fathers were pretty
smart we the people okay
um you know
they understood that there's a power
associated with the people you know the
people united the people you know
believing in the goodness and the
opportunity that was afforded by this
nation and
and and instead we we have fractured
ourselves among the most trivial things
and then given our energy and then we
complain about the very thing that we
feed to build we complain about it when
we are responsible for paying for the
bricks the prison keepers the uniforms
everything and so
turn your attention to something else if
you took that same time you know between
14 and 23 years watching tv in your life
let's just say take one year
out of that maybe you get 22 years of
netflix in all right take one of those
years and and just solely dedicate it to
yourself
and if you do
well you will regain time because time
is accelerating extremely fast and it's
accelerating because
because time is only realized by the
experiences that are contained in it
right so like
like you know i've heard it said like
one million years with one event
or or 10 minutes with 50 000 events
every moment of our life is filled with
it with with an experience and so we
realize time and time accelerates and we
accelerate our own time in life it's
like at the end of the day you're like
man
like you feel like you lived a lifetime
because you realized every moment of
that day and none of it was spent with
you
none of it and so you feel disconnected
right well don't worry take a vacation
down to disney
we're gonna get you patched up
you know have a couple margaritas you
know eat four meals a day it's vacation
consume
right and so this built-in acceleration
that's happening that we feel in the
world right now
is caused because all of our energy is
directed towards that
and so i think that we
can walk away
and you know i've i've walked away you
know i kind of started out when i first
started this i didn't know a social
media i had nothing i'm like okay i'm
starting a foundation like i gotta get
an instagram you know so i used to look
back at like the instagram i had and was
like i didn't i didn't even know what a
hashtag was you know um i was like it i
was like you know it was like me like
chopping wood you know i'm like do work
or something i had the worst things but
then it kind of grew and i got to like
almost 20 000 people and i was like
sharing ideas and then and then i you
know throughout you know my experience
of going through the program every
season because i'm out there doing it
right i'm not out there like standing
there like you know
i'm living it with the guys i'm feeling
it i'm feeling the ice i'm feeling the
cold i'm i'm you know i'm hitting the
ground riding the colts i'm like at ten
thousand eleven thousand feet i'm
building the can i'm feeling every
moment i'm in the sweat lodge i'm doing
i'm not like this like kind of passive
participant i'm there and then i just
realized
i have to walk away like i have to just
do it so i just
i just deleted it and i just walked away
and man all these like anxieties and
things like it went away you know of
course like my foundation has it and all
those kind of things and then like i
don't know like a year later i was like
i'm going to start it off again
i got a message to share the world
and what do i start doing next thing i
know i'm sucking back in the hole i'm in
there and i'm doing this and then i just
and i just stopped i was delayed i'm
like i'm done for the rest of my life
i'm never doing that again
and and
it's like it's the battered wife
syndrome you know it's like
that's what i had and and i look and
listen people can choose whatever they
want to do or whatever but i'm just
saying for my life
i needed to realize that my energy
needed to be directed at something else
and that i wasn't being you know i
wasn't fulfilling and maximizing my
potential as a person because i was
spending my time to start and i was like
you know consciously like this is not a
projection this is who i am this is but
then of course i'm like i don't like
that little love handle okay
let me get it honey get another side
shot here with the axe
that's in the remote wilderness here
photoshop yeah right like probably
you know just you know it's three bucks
you get the abs it's no big deal this is
the freaking man wilderness filter
yeah
exactly and so you know so i i'm trying
to change like i i we haven't bought
meat from the store in four years you
know i sold my beloved pickup truck to
my good buddy
uh team guy
and i bought a 66 foot by 17 foot wide
geothermal greenhouse and an excavator
and
on my land and you know we have the
ranch and you know training my horses
and like
my kids like they don't have any tech
they don't have a
screen on the ipad on any of those
things
teaching the real basic things like
and
i started realizing how much time i was
actually spending doing the things that
i'm actually railing against you know
and so um
little tiny changes one step at a time
you know so do you not have a vehicle no
i have a view i have a vehicle but no i
had this truck i had the 75 ford high
boy i put a 429 cobra jet in it and
all of it was sick red lifted i was all
you know it was cool guy like one mile
to the gallon i started like a bird died
you know it was like that kind of truck
and i loved it and i always wanted that
growing up as a kid you know i mean the
the ford high boy was cool when i was a
kid
and um but i sold that and i bought
things and and i've really um i've
changed the relationships in my life
and even the things that i expose myself
to and the content and those kind of
things
um radical quiet time in the morning you
know like like not just like working out
and getting in my son or whatever but
like like learning to just sit there and
be still and thoughtless
and then like
you know get to the place where i can do
that for 40 minutes without without a
thought and just breathe nothing
and then all sudden
i have all these realizations about
things i don't know where they come from
i have well i do know where they come
from right you get plugged in
that energy is real and you get plugged
into and that's what guys find listen
there's days in the backcountry where
it's like everyone's kind of chatty
and then they'll be like days where
you're on a horse
and it's like
nobody says a word
and it's just like
man you can like
it's amazing everyone's real talkative
at the first like 12 minutes of a forced
road march
exactly yeah this is going to be
like 30 minutes in dead silence for the
next four hours as you just hop it out
you're trapped in there in your own
little brain do you think that you were
uh do you think that you made the seal
teams or steel teams made you
probably a little bit of both well yes a
little bit of both um i can i can tell
you like from my experience of like
going through buds i i was never gonna
quit i never thought about quitting i
was just like
i was so stoked and happy like this is
what we're doing this is what i'm doing
uh
i it took me a while
to figure out like i wanted to be a good
seal you know that's what i wanted to be
once i got in the teams i wanted to be a
good seal
and it took me a while to figure out
what that actually was and i i don't
think i really figured it out until
probably about five years after i
retired
and i think i would still be them
modified i'm still working on it right
now
but
you know there was different things that
i did along the way where it seemed like
the team guy thing to do and then as i
got older and
figured out oh yeah that wasn't really
exactly a good team guy thing to do now
there's some core tenants that never
changed and i think the ultimate one is
like
if you're a good team guy you put your
team in front of yourself and that would
seem clear to me from day one
and and i think that
that is the ultimate sort of the
ultimate quality of a good team guys
like oh that guy he
will do he he will he's going to put you
ahead of him and if you have a platoon
full of guys and they're all putting
each other ahead of themselves like
that's a freaking kick-ass platoon
so
i kind of knew that
i kind of felt that way like even with
the friends i had growing up
it was sort of that same mentality about
not being selfish and not putting
yourself like not looking out for
yourself
and and so when i got in the teams that
core belief
was probably
it was probably in existence when i got
when i was when i got in the teams of
like hey you don't put yourself ahead of
your friends i think uh that's what i
was
kind of
that's what me and my friends were like
when i was a kid and i think that was
that core tenet was there
so did it get honed hell yeah it got
honed
but i'd say it was kind of there man
yeah it's like something i feel like
when i showed up at buzz it was like
i felt really inferior to everybody like
in the sense that
everyone has like ripped and like they
were like all had like you know played
football and everybody was like sports
athletes and everyone was there and i
just felt so inferior i had like this
shitty tattoo
like everyone made fun of well not my
classmates but all the instructors what
was the shitty tattoo uh i have uh i
still have it um
i have like a transformer tattoo
but it's just like a shitty outline that
was done by a friend of mine like on
this arm and uh
yeah and whatever but like i got this
thing and they used to say faint get up
here and show everyone your stupid
tattoos and then i'd have to get up in
the truck and then they'd be like
everyone laugh
of course
you know everyone would laugh and then
they would come down and i remember we
had this one we had this one chief my
instructor i'll never forget he's like
he was the one that was constantly
calling me out he's like get up here and
show everyone your stupid tattoo and i
was like whatever so i'd like go up
there and show them the tattoo everyone
would do the laugh and then we'd take
off on the run you know kind of the
thing and uh and then one day he's up
there and i was like
he's like you know if i had that tattoo
like that i i think i would just kill
myself and i was like well if i had legs
like yours i would kill myself oh damn
and everybody was like and then
everybody laughed for real
so
i i proceeded to eat
a mouthful of sand and i did the run
every time i lost the sand because i
would slowly do a little
like i would stop it i have to refill
refill yeah i would refill and i'd put
the sand and i'd run
but all the instructors came up to me
and they're like
we got props for you
we know that like really sucked and
they're like they all like gave he gave
props you know yeah and uh but i i just
kind of like
going through that like i did have that
belief in myself like i i had a belief
in myself and i would look at that the
instructor is not in a sense of like
they're out to get me but that like if
they could be on the other side of this
experience then i could be too
that's all i ever thought about was like
if he can do it i can do it you know
it's like that was that movie the edge
or whatever uh with uh anthony hopkins
and uh
who's the dude that just shot the guy
oh alec baldwin he just shot a gun
female actually he did yeah he's a
female yeah that's right
and um
yeah but memory did that movie the edge
yeah
he's like what one man can do another
man can do
like
and i kind of like i mean i wouldn't say
i was like thinking about that movie but
like in my own way i i thought like man
if somebody else can be standing there
with that shirt on i could be standing
there with that shirt on you know i
think pressure i think those experiences
just reveal
who we really are and i think that
everybody could make it if they had the
ability to look in at that you know that
fire in the gut or whatever
but too often not it's too enticing to
ring out
i was uh
i was not great at anything right i
wasn't the fastest runner i wasn't the
fastest swimmer i guess like you i
wasn't like a great athlete i was like a
maybe slightly below average athlete in
high school and then even when i got to
teams it was like i was never gonna win
anything yeah so i always felt like i
had to work harder and to be a good team
guy
and the quitting thing is crazy actually
when you look at the things that
happened with people like incredible
athletes
like i was literally
a below average athlete and i was young
you know so like even if if you went to
college
your mortgage developed i mean the
difference between a 18 year old and a
22 year old is a big freaking difference
but you know i i had college athletes d1
college athletes i had an olympic
alternate for gymnastics which is crazy
quit
uh
wrestler d1 wrestler quit wrestler
really the wrestlers are tough
i think i think so i think so
i i i'm actually
one of my swim buddies rang out in like
um
the after hell week in dive phase we're
doing something in the pool
and i'm i think we're doing buddy
breathing in the pool yeah and so i'm
passing in my regulator and i'm taking
two breasts and he's taking nine
and this dude was from like iowa or
something he'd never been in the ocean
before and he was super pale
so he was just sunburned he looked
bright red like the entire time yeah
and and so i'm doing you know taking
whatever two breaths giving him he's
taking nine and finally he just stands
up he wearing four feet of water in the
pool he just stands up he goes to the
surface and i'm like down there and i
think
okay
so i stand up and he's just calling out
like hey i quit i'm out of here this is
i'm not doing this after hell week wow
so that water thing can get a little bit
crazy on some people
uh yeah the water thing is legit you
know i've had some so i mean i was
drowned in afghanistan uh and yeah i had
like some i've had how'd that happen i
had some um
crossing a river uh and
the uh
a rope that i was attached to got
wrapped around a rock and i don't really
know how much i can say about because of
the nature of where we were and all
those things well you're in a river i
was in a river yeah and so basically um
i had gone down there once checked it
out um it was much more intense than
anticipated uh you know and i had this
like idea like about this water op and
all this kind of thing so began studying
it and
there was a really there was a mission
that we needed to get done that had not
been successful previously and
i was in this this this space with with
some guys and it's kind of like really
amped up on this you know first water
off all the things
so go down there the second time with
like a
two
100 meters of one inch tubular nylon all
tied together in an alice pack
and
uh the plan was that i would go upstream
and offset and then swim down the other
side then pull the equipment set off a
hoist system so that you know we could
zipline all this stuff and get everybody
across this sounds good
so it was like uh
uh you know class four rapids
way way way north and uh so
it starts off i'm down there i got like
my my boots on i got my stuff is my
second time done now i've been watching
this thing drone footage all the things
i've been observing this for a long time
i understood the flow of the river and
there was a dog leg which was like the
point of no return like if you went
there there was a huge cave and i would
watch on the footage like logs and like
trees did go in there and like days
later would be like bloop would come out
so i knew if i went in there that i
wouldn't live and uh
so i go down there and
i start going like upstream so now this
is you're executing the mission well i'm
doing the are you doing a recon i'm
basically doing recon to see a proof of
concept and so we're down there we got
guys set up security the whole deal i'm
down there i'm like
really nervous i'm like whoa this is
like i'm like in shorts and like you
know this is like really a wild place
and there's huge cliffs so there's only
kind of one way in this wadi to the
ocean to the uh to the river
so i kind of start going up while i end
up getting like sucked into a cave that
i couldn't see it would just look like a
dark spot on the on the
on the aerial
and they like let all the rope go the
rope gets all tangled up around me i'm
like a cat grabbing on the sides like i
can't grab on anything so i'm end up
making to the beach
now i can't i can't get back there's no
way to get back unless i do that again
i'm not going in that cave nobody has
any idea it's like one o'clock in the
morning so finally i go up and i get the
rope
and
i get it taught and i'm on the beach and
i'm like i sit down i have a riggers
belt on with a carabiner my boots fins
and uh no shirt and a pair of shorts and
a speedo underneath
um
because i have to contain that thing
just kidding so
that's a lot see it's a projection and
uh
so anyway i'm like so i'm sitting there
and i can tell you i honestly felt like
a lot of fear i felt afraid because like
the waves were so big it was like
so i'm like okay okay okay like just
like just michael phelps it like
you can do it and like so i get into the
water and i start like swimming as hard
as i can and i was unprepared for the
violence of that water it literally
swept me away
and as i'm like flying down i'm like i
kind of get
like almost to where the dog leg is to
get to the other side and so everybody's
like in this wadi there's guys up here
on this mountain these two mountains and
this is all like cliffs and it's kind of
not cliffy on the other side and you
know that was the plan so as it's like
turning like this i kind of get to hear
and there's a boulder in the center
and the rope goes right around the
boulder which just they're holding an
anchor and i just become like a flapping
parachute and it just sucks me
underneath and my feet go underneath a
boulder
and i had a ut life vest on so i pulled
a little thing which i've never done in
my whole training
and i was like and it just ripped right
off it was like a
toy and my shoes are gone everything's
gone finn's gone
shorts are gone i'm in my speedo
all this is happening very quick and i
realize like i'm drowning
and i try to unhook the carabiner i
physically can't i'm not strong enough
and i'm no like crane puff like i i
couldn't physically the current was so
strong and i'm trying to move the rope
one and a half inches to get it out of
the back and it was a stupid little like
black issue like locking carabiner you
know where i gotta twist the thing a
half turn and like
and i'm like and i started like really i
started drowning and i started seeing
like you know these kind of like i guess
like you would say hallucination or
whatever i started like seeing all kinds
of crazy images and i started feeling
like i'm going out unconscious like this
is like the end i remember saying like
please god don't let me like drown in
afghanistan and and then meanwhile these
guys are like everyone's piling down off
the hill like thinking i'm like dead
they saw me like zip by and so they're
heave hoeing and they're like heave hoe
and heave honing there's a lot of rope
so they end up like heave hoeing the
rope off the rock and like i right when
i'm like about to totally just drown and
i remember saying in buzz dry drowning
is better than wet drowning dry drowning
is better i mean don't breathe in
because you can be resuscitated but if
you suck in
your toast like all that water is going
to go in your lungs
you know being a medic like it too and
i just kept saying dry drowning is
better than what johnny and i just
refused to breathe in and then all of a
sudden i like pop up into the foam and i
remember like gagging in and sucking all
this foam and i'm like
and i just start washing down the river
again i'm just hitting rocks i'm like
doing cartwheels
i don't know which way is up and i'm and
i'm like
screaming help like
to nobody
and and i'm like oh like and i remember
i'm like breathing in foam and i and i
get to the other side
which they could not access me because
of the the terrain
and i get to their side and i'm like i'm
on land and i start like crawling you
know super fast to get up on short and
then they just start dragging me on my
face right they're like
oh like and and i'm like getting dragged
back into the river and so i get against
this boulder there's a lot of slack in
the line i do kind of like a squat like
and i pop the off and apparently
everybody like fell down and they pull
it back and they're like he's alive
they thought i was dead they thought i
had drowned
so now i'm like in my speedo with no
shoes on or anything in real bad guy
land like and there's like people with
like lights collecting driftwood there's
like and so i'm like i crawl underneath
this like outcropping and i cover myself
in mud
because i saw it on predator
and and i mean that's really what i did
i remember you know like that scene you
know yeah
and and so i cover myself in mud and i
just lay there until like almost like
probably
an hour before first light
and i'm like thinking
i'm gonna be the first seal to ever be
captured like and i was like off like
that and i'm like and i got like
sticks and like rocks like piled up and
i'm just and i'm freezing
the like one of the coldest moments i've
ever been in what was the water temp
what time of year was it it was uh
august okay but it was cold yep super
cold and we were
pretty damn close to as far north as you
could go
and um
so i'm
uh i'm like laying there and then i see
like some nods like lights and the guys
have made it around come down they were
scanning the shore and i like popped out
i'm like here's like mud dude with like
you know cool guy with like a speedo on
no shoes well i had no shoes
so like they have my bag though we gotta
get out of here now like so i'm like yo
you know we're hugging like i thought
you're dead we're doing that whole thing
so i get my clothes i have no shoes on
and to tell you truth i don't remember
walking back
i i think i just like blacked out or
something like because i was so cold and
i had my shoes on and i was so
you know i got my gun got all my stuff
got everything we go back get the base
one of the guys there one of the oga
guys son's a team guy he runs one of the
branches now
um
so sun's up we get back and he was there
and he's like
he's like in tears he's like you want to
have a drink so we go up and we go in
the skiff and
he's like i thought you were dead and i
was like why did we do this like this
was terrible like we should have never
done this like blah blah blah so he
gives me a drink we have a drink can i
go back in my room i'm like
that was like
whoa so back to like open it up whatever
move on well my team leader comes to me
like a week later and he's like
hey brother i think you could do that
again and i'm like
i'm like sure definitely like go in my
room i'm like i'm so scared i don't want
to do that like that was the worst
experience of my whole life like i but
of course i'm like yeah i mean
definitely brother like for sure like so
i started like watching all these
youtube videos and i started like river
crossings all this kind of stuff i'm
like okay like and so i order all this
equipment from the um
pjs and all this stuff comes up i got
throwbacks rescue stuff i'm like
inflatables protects the whole deal
long story short i go back down there to
prove the concept and there was people
down there so we bagged us canked it we
didn't want to burn the air now
everyone's hearing about this like water
mission going down
and the night we were supposed to go
and execute we never did
do it
and two hours before we left i was
switched out with josh harris who
drowned and died
and i was right next to him yeah so
there's a lot of little details in there
i'll leave out but it was uh
it was a bad deal yeah and uh you know
that experience had an impact on me
for sure
uh and so when i did the ironman in 2012
one of the reasons why i did the iron
man was because as a free diver i got
into serious free diving like serious
venezuela mexico all over the world
that's why you were in the teams you
were doing that when i was contracting
and but i started free diving in the
teams uh matter of fact i came up with
this whole thing called spear fishing pt
uh because we had surf pt and i was like
that's not fair it's discriminating like
we should have spearfishing pt
which was the greatest thing because we
never got back to work on time there was
always some kind of issue
and so we got the day off basically
i know that only lasted for like three
weeks
um but yeah so i uh i had to fell even
diving around the world like i mean i
was going to very deep desk you know 110
feet like uh
killing you know tuna and panama and i
spent you know three weeks in venezuela
diving i always had this wreck playing
in my head
of what had happened when i would get in
situations i got my arm caught in
venezuela underneath a rock at 80 feet
you know and the next thing i know it's
like in my head like i'm in afghanistan
i'm drowning like it was crazy i'm like
i gotta kick this thing
so
i ended up like signing up for the iron
man because i heard like the the swim is
the most terrifying thing in the world
which it was
yeah i had like a pant that's a bold
statement coming from that freaking
afghanistan holy you want a bunch
of like middle-aged men and women that
are like you know hate their lives and
trying to find themselves
like you don't want to be in the water
with them because they're vicious
and but anyway like i'm out there and
i'll never forget it like i'm a fast
swimmer i i was like finished i think
112 on the swim and the iron man which
is is really good 2.4 miles
and i'm out there and i started too far
in advance for my skill and then people
started swimming over top of me like i
was just a random buoy i mean they
literally just kicked me in the face and
just there was 2400 people just like
swimming
and i couldn't catch my breath and i got
kicked in the face my goggles got kicked
off and i got and i'm like hey got like
guys look at like the paddle board's
like you need help you know like if race
is over like i can't breathe i can't
breathe and i'm like oh my god i'm back
and i remember this guy was like i'll
never forget it he looks at me he's in a
panic like me
and i'm like not panicking panicking but
i'm just like i can't catch my breath
because every time i try to breathe i'd
get some like you know 45 year old
lady's foot
toe up my nose
and
and so he grabs on to me and he's
holding on to me and i'm at this buoy
and i remember he's pushing me down he's
like
and the paddle boards are trying to get
in and i'm like in this mix and i
remember i just looked at him and i was
just like and that moment
i like faced it
and this dude was like pulling me down
and i just like grabbed him by his like
rubber cap and i punched him between the
shoulder blades as hard as i could and
he was just like just
like it was like electric shock like hit
him and i was like ah just like ah i
just started like swimming
and i my wife has this great shot of me
coming out i look like
i look like i have like ptsd when i'm
coming out of the water like might have
like bags under my eyes i got news for
you you did
it
yeah and i came out of the water and i
was like i was like totally terrified
and uh but
i never had another
bout with that ever again
and uh it was a moment where i was like
i knew i had like i had like finally
like face that thing down which was like
playing in the back of my head it was
really weird uh when i would get into
water situations where i've been
drowning which happened a lot like
in dive spear fishing you know and
uh so and i never had another another
had another issue again so
it was uh
it was a moment in my life that i'll i
will never forget as long as i live we
go offline i'll tell you some more
details but yeah
and then what what do you got going on
right now like with the
the beef the ranch the cows like you're
full on just going for it
yeah i mean it just uh i mean my goal is
so we just purchased this ranch we've
got a capital campaign going on and
we've raised some money
building a human development center
there so which will be uh it's a 10
person cold plunge a 10 person sauna
a gym in the center and then a
meditation room that's sound proof and
then it vibrates at 528 the megahertz of
the earth so it's very good grounding um
and uh when something's vibrating 525
megahertz do you hear it do you feel it
or it
it's the earth it's the earth so like if
you ever if you know i always tell
people like if you're having like
anxiety or something like that like or
you're just like you know sometimes you
get that kind of like raciness or you
feel like you gotta like down regulate a
little bit
like the best thing you can go out is go
outside take your shoes off stand in the
ground be in total silence and stand
there and it usually goes away within
like three to four minutes and i just
breathe
it's very grounding it right it grounds
you and so you know frequencies are
super important so we actually do sound
with the guys and last year the guy said
it was our first year doing it uh
almost every guy said it was the most
profound experience of their life we
have uh somebody that comes in and
brings those sound bowls and they bring
up the resonance outside on the ranch
like deep where the sweat lodge is and
it just vibrates it and they do these
bowls and it's like
some people it's so intense they vomit
from it uh so wait you sit
you lay there and these are big bowls i
don't know what you're talking about
yeah they're bowls and they stir them
and they
each bowl produces a frequency and they
can bring you up to the resonance which
ground it grounds you and so
um you know obviously like everything is
frequency and everything is is like how
are you looking at somebody on their
iphone
like how am i talking to you how am i
vibrating right now and you are somehow
interpreting what i'm saying in your
brain i'm literally vibrating to you and
somehow you're like yeah let's go do
something right go over here like and so
um
you know that's that's that sound
therapy is something that uh it works
it's very very powerful uh if you've if
you've never tried it there's probably
places here go go to a sound bath they
have all these bowls all these things
they'll bring you in there
and because your whole life is inundated
with blue light and frequencies and
wi-fi signals and all those kind of
things so what you're doing is you're
re-establishing a baseline
so so yeah so the ranch we're building a
human development center we've got an
arena going up a 100 by 200 indoor arena
so we can expand kind of into the winter
time and uh and then the guys live in
non-electric
wood cabins with outdoor showers and an
outhouse
total minimalist so um the guys the
students the students that are going
through yep are going through so they
live in like little lodgepole cabins
that we're building that are just little
bunks a little wood stove and an outdoor
shower and an outhouse a double owl
house i'm gonna get some of that yeah
get some of that yeah a matter of fact
this year when we put the double house
up we forgot to put the little blanket
in the center and like three days later
the guy's like hey do you have like a
blanket or something and i was like oh
i'm sorry i totally forgot about that
but they were using it yeah which is
disturbing that's one of those things
that's one of the like starkest memories
i have from navy boot camp was that
there's no stalls in the and
you were just literally sitting down and
there was someone sitting next to you
you know a foot away taking a next
to you it's just the removal of
whatever it's kind of the removal of
all privacy is gone it's gone yeah it's
a hundred percent on you yeah poop next
time
[Laughter]
that's how much we owe you moving that
hole
and by the way there's another dude on
the other side of you that's also shitty
so that's good times so you're so you're
building this so this is gonna up our
capacity to take more students and do
more yeah because right now i mean the
guys are living in wall tents uh and
everything's out all the outdoor showers
all that kind of stuff the ranch we
bought has basically a tiny little cabin
on it that you know abraham lincoln's
contractor built and two pivots you know
and uh and a small shop that had no well
or anything so we popped in a well we've
done all this stuff and so now we're
raising money too
to build that out and to expand the
program uh to year round and you know my
goal is not to have some big giant
program like i think that is the problem
is that everybody thinks there's like
one institution that can do it all
and
my idea is to kind of get to a sweet
spot with guys and then you know we're
capturing data and then to go and to get
other organizations to up level
themselves and to begin to really start
thinking about like human development
and bringing forth change rather than
like me saying like i can do it all and
i can build this huge thing and i i
wanna i wanna network with people and
have them scale up and uh that people
that are really serious about human
development and i think that will i
think we'll look back and this will be a
hub of uh
um
you know it'll be a place where a spark
formed and um
when people start looking at things
different because the guys that graduate
this program uh
you know it's uh
they're they're they're cha they're
different they're changed you know what
i mean and and so um i think that
everybody deserves that opportunity but
i can't do it all and i think that other
people like i said there's 50 000
non-profits in north america you know we
spent 92 billion dollars since 2012 and
the end of 2020 and it's gotten worse
um you know and i'm sorry and a lot of
people like you know they hate me
because i say you know you know you got
organizations they got shetland ponies
that you can take and
they put sneakers on them and you walk
around town
like my message is
you know you like that is that
doesn't that doesn't do anything like
like it takes time and it takes
commitment and maybe that's not for
everybody and and you'll have to walk
your own path but i think that as all
these existing institutions maybe i can
find 10.
maybe i can find 10 that are focused on
human development maybe maybe it's
saying like hey think about the change
of a guy you take a guy's 75 pounds
overweight he's on meds he's like but he
wants to change and he's got the fire
and you put him in a 10-week fight camp
right
and then think about who that guy would
be at the end of 10 weeks right
nutrition diet focus meditation ice
baths like working out purpose like
feeling good strong like getting
balanced all those things like
i mean it's it's simple
but it's it's
it's it takes effort and it takes work
and so my my goal is to is to start a
new conversation and bringing people
together
about what it you know about restoring
um you know these guys back to the
dignity of who they are
it's crazy
like the shit's not gonna be easy
if you're gonna reset your life and dig
in and find out who you are
that's not gonna that's not gonna be an
easy evolution no doughnuts like yeah
it's like
yeah and it's it's crazy you know that
that opening that i read for me was like
literally there are some people that are
literally trying to give you a magic
pill that's going to do all this work
for you like which is a crazy thing it's
crazy
it's in it's insane like when you think
about it but the thing is we already
know the secret sauce right that's why
you know the business people are like
let's create something called obstacle
course races right like you literally
climb over a log flop into the mud then
some roided out dude hits you in the
head with a foam bat and then you get
like a medal and then the next day in
the office everyone's like whoa
what's different about him he faced an
obstacle gem
and he over game
right i mean that is the obstacle course
races like i mean we so
so set that challenge in front of
yourself i think we can like unite
together do different for me like i
never thought you know we bought a ranch
for three million bucks
i met this guy
he was delivering hay i started talking
to him he goes oh my dad might be
selling his ranch you should meet him
are you looking for a ranch i'm like
sure yeah definitely we worked seven
years with no ranch
leased everything set it up every year
mobile gypsy camp it was a living hell
imagine 70 horses not owning 1 16th of
an acre was a nightmare
and most people never saw that and so
here i am like
going to this guy's place and i sit down
a cup of coffee you know big business
guy i sit down i'm like he's like so he
interested in the ranch i'm like yeah
he's like well do you have any money and
i'm like no no
and he's like thanks for coming
like basically it was like really nice
but then never talk to me again
so then like a year later he calls me up
he's like i'm definitely gonna sell the
ranch are you interested and i was like
absolutely so i ride down there my
motorcycle and i'm like i sit down with
him he pours me a cup of coffee goes
do you have any money and i'm like
no but i'm gonna get it
because i was like it was like the jerk
store with like you know
with george costanza you know i was like
thought of this this comeback like the
whole year and he's like well
i said i'll give you my word give me an
opportunity and i'll get it
and
i i didn't have any of that kind of
resources so we ended up getting a loan
what year was that that was last year so
you got a loan against uh a charity is
that yeah yeah we got a loan yeah we got
a loan on the ranch and so um and i
raised a million five from various
donors and put that you know down
payment or whatever took a loan out and
you know we just launched a four-year
capital campaign to build a ranch out so
some 7.5 million bucks over four years
and uh
and then you know the funny thing is
about nonprofits is that i don't own it
i'm basically even though i'm the
founder i'm just an employee i'll never
have those assets like if the whole
thing dissolved tomorrow goes to either
the state or to another nonprofit
and so you know i exist in this
solely for the development and
betterment of
my fellow man
and i think that you know whether it's a
veteran or it's a stay-at-home mom or
somebody recovering from a getting ran
over by a dump truck or whatever it is
um i think that people are gonna once
again begin looking um
to to partake in that hero's journey and
that journey of self-discovery to get
out of the places
that they're currently in and
so that's that's my goal and we're
capturing data we're working with the
university to get results and stuff like
that so that i can go to other
non-profits and sit down with that
person say listen i know you give five
thousand dollars to critically injured
soldiers i also know that you have 290
million dollars in the bank because your
financials are public and online as a
non-profit
maybe you could run a program that
actually does something for people
beyond
you know
getting on their kids ipads maybe we can
do something to better mankind you know
maybe we can do something to level up
you know society our society our
community in a way and and stop giving
handouts
and start you know giving hand ups
you know i think that handouts are a
total
failure i think yeah of course people
have things and stuff like that you know
critical things but like for the most
part like
you have to own it you have to earn it
and you have to own it and i think we
get an opportunity business and we get
out of the handout business oh you
served come on and float in a tube and
we have a massage therapist online like
thank you for your air force time oh
here's a filet mignon and a carrot and a
raspberry like you know then a jacket
and some fishing gear even though you
live in detroit and you live in a
one-bedroom apartment and you know below
the poverty line like most veterans do
um and and and maybe i'm going to give
you an opportunity to change your own
life but you're going to have to do the
work and we get back in the opportunity
business
that's that's what i want to see happen
and then hopefully you know
uh you know when the meteorite hits the
world and dinosaurs come back or
everything like that
it'll be like a plaque somewhere it'll
say he tried to do good
but it was futile
they destroyed themselves aren't you
aren't you trying to uh do something
with with beef too like
yeah so what's going on with that yeah
so uh so the beef model is kind of like
so
i
i talked about the social hybrid is this
non-profits are in this perpetual
starvation cycle right where you're
beholden to the donors where you know
you have to raise money and then you
know you're constantly in this state of
having to raise money because you can't
generate money because you're a
non-profit i didn't know that by the
name when i started i'm like why am i so
broke
and then like five years later i'm like
wait a second
non-profit
damn it
so um but i was like we have this ranch
uh you know we're going to start a
cattle company farm to table you know
and i think that like the care of the
animal from the moment it's born living
and dying on the ranch treating that
animal with respect
you know if you've ever been to mass
agriculture and you saw what it's really
about it's one of the most disturbing
things that you've ever seen in your
life and if you've ever been to a
slaughterhouse or a packing plant where
they're doing a thousand head a day you
know they're picking them up with skid
steers and terrified adrenaline hormones
and they're gonna pump like smash it is
very
it's not good um and i think that i
think that carries over to the food and
so like you know raising that animal
honoring that animal letting him graze
letting him live letting him be out
there letting him live their lives
sustainably harvesting them
teaching people how to do that you know
integrating that and then selling that
beef to
um donors that can then in turn support
the program so the ranch stands on its
own two legs so it's a social hybrid it
won't exist to make money but it was
just to sustain you know the program
then also expose people to that animal
husbandry into that ranching side of the
house and then also you know down in
line with the beef i
i i think like to me
food like where your food comes from is
so important and it's so critical to the
wellness of the individual you can't
expect to be happy if you're eating you
know uh
cheez-its and garbage and all those kind
it all is tied together your body is the
subconscious mind and even down to the
food that you eat
and you know what i started getting
exposed to this world and i started
seeing things i was like man this is
like rough
like when you really see what's
happening
put to the animals and those kind of
things and listen i'm not like you know
out there like you know whatever like an
activist or anything like that but i'm
like there's a better way like the
natives did it right you know they they
harvested they took what they wanted
they they used every component think
about the waste that we have they only
take the best cuts everything's dog food
or this or that or like and so for me
it's like butchering the whole animal
using the bones to create bone broth
taking the hides and and making boxing
gloves and american-made boxing goes
with the hives and like
taking all the fat taking all those
things taking the bones making biochar
out of them right so like using that as
a as an organic fertilizer that we could
use on the ranch and we could give away
and share with other people like using
the whole animal and teaching guys those
things because when they become
connected to their food
they start to understand the system that
they're a part of you know
i tell people the whole world is it's
like your life is held together by a
wire okay
a wire so like if the wire breaks
meaning like the power goes out millions
will die within weeks
from a wire
like oh i'll hunt you're not gonna hunt
you're not gonna make it out of your
high rise you're gonna be like you'll be
in a 25 million dollar tomb okay the
water comes out what are you gonna do
it's over a cable
a cable breaks the internet goes out and
millions die and i think that
so many guys like common they realize
and they change their whole lives
because they start to realize the role
that we pay in the system and how you
know how everything is now handed to you
and you take for granted all those
aspects
and so my goal is to stand up that that
system and that human development
program and then begin to get other
people to do the same thing and i want
to expand a community you know and and
that's my goal so that's what's going on
with the beef and just
i mean i i talk a lot well not a lot i
talk about china
china yeah china
and
you know we saw a lot of this during
covet like what are we dependent on but
we're dependent on china for food
and a lot of people don't recognize that
china limit china
china is coming for us
i tell people i'm like if you look at
mao during the chinese industrial
revolution the great leap forward mao
knew that he needed nuclear technology
there's been five emperors in china
emperors
that's what i'll call them dictators
whatever leaders great ones whatever
dragon lords so like
microaggression and so but if you look
at what they did he understood that they
needed nuclear technology so what did he
do he traded food to the russians in
exchange for nuclear technology starved
his own people 30 million people died
during peace time and he got the nuclear
weapon they have a 5 000 year plan all
right they understand that by by
enslaving their own people for cheap
labor because americans exist for
consumption
i want it now and i want it cheap
and it it's like my house i go in there
how many how much do i need right
it's that's cheap it's only three bucks
another potato peeler
you never know
so so so how many potato peelers did you
actually have in my house okay i did
have five that's a lot i did have i kept
two
shout out to cuisinart but
i uh i was like if you look at them
they're smart because what they did is
they understood the american psychology
they understand that americans are
overconfident because from childhood
they're told you're the best you're good
you get praised for things you never
deserved they they're entitled and lazy
chinese are the opposite right so
they're like marching forward to their 5
000 year destiny
and so what do we do we outsource
everything to them for super cheap goods
and in turn handcuff ourselves to them
right including our medications the
world's most critical medications are
made in china
and so you know china is on the move and
their military is now expeditionary
they're providing aid to foreign
countries they've got their jets and let
me they got hypersonic missiles and let
me tell you something they're not over
here like trying to pass the pt test
okay oh i didn't you know got to go to
fep
because i didn't make it by the way my
rights matter you don't tow the line in
the chinese army you wind up as biochar
okay they don't no need for you and and
xi jinping said that
you know if we try to stand against the
chin this is two months ago in a live
speech he said on their show of force
and he said you will meet a great wall
of steel made by 1.8 billion chinese
that are unified
what are we over here like don't go over
here like i don't like you like
so
they banned all girly men on tv
there is no
boy bands allowed social media turns off
at 10 o'clock at night
and and what are they preparing for to
be a world leader
and who are they in lock stuff with the
russians right and and because they see
the united states dwindling because
consumption consumerism entitlement
overconfidence uh and and this desire to
tell people what's right and wrong you
know like we have these things and then
what happened in afghanistan right we're
no longer a force for good
we are we better rethink because this
enemy is not like an afghani running
around in pajamas
these dudes are probably genetically
modified who knows what they're going to
do they might unzip their fake chinese
bodies and come out and just be like
who knows right they are genetically
modifying super soldiers forbes just or
was at a time or whatever just had a
thing on them so we are facing a time
right now where this entitlement and all
these things that we have are coming
home to roost on us
and you know buyer beware
because if the cable breaks if the earth
even burps okay if it just rumbles in
the wrong place and the power goes out
for say two months
millions upon mil there won't be enough
excavators to dig the holes for the
bodies that will burn
people
oh no
but it's the truth think about it if
you're living in a 25 million dollar
high rise on the 98th floor
and the power goes out
where do you get your next sandwich from
by time you make it down every store
will be gone all the food will be gone
there will be no water your well pumps
won't work just think about it
life is held together by a cable
and we never think that that cable is
gonna ever break and you know who's
holding part of that cable
network is china
and i don't think that china would have
picked a fight with us but i think we've
put a fight with them and because here
we are just bloating bloating bloating
bloating bloating
and
and and they're refining refining
refining refining refining
so i mean if if putin invades ukraine
i bet you i bet you see china and china
go after taiwan simultaneously
i wouldn't be surprised
and then they could launch hypersonic
missiles and vaporize our fleet in two
seconds and then it's either go nuclear
or stand down
i i think i don't know what's what's
today just for reference today is the
24th of january
nice i think that
putin's going in i think ukraine's i
think it's on and i think he's what he's
doing he's looking at biden who's
compromised
and he is
it
it breaks it breaks my heart and russia
has a bona pic because think about it we
eisenhower screwed them over because we
were supposed to pay them all that money
and we never did and then we chased them
over to over to afghanistan what you
know caused problems over there whooped
on them over there did the cold war
ripped the walls down crushed our
economy did all these things right and
now we're telling them oh you can't go
across those borders and they're just
like
meanwhile the russians over there like
every guy is like khabib yeah you know
like kill kill kill kill kill
our guys are over here like stand down
people are being mean
they're gonna call us back
not all americans are like that there's
definitely too many that i mean there's
definitely plenty of americans i work
with a lot of young military folks and
man they are uh yeah
there's kids ready to rock and roll
but
i don't know if the country is if the
country's willing to sacrifice like in
those situations
our guts are ripped out i mean think
about 20-year war
you think you think about like the
united states there was a usa article
last year it's it's worth checking out
even though they're kind of like
whatever but like they have a
article with a moving map on it called
the cost of war
if you google if you look it up or
duckduckgo or whatever brave it and
you will see a moving map and it shows
last year the united states you know
waged war in 88 countries okay so we we
had we had an 88 count so we're getting
look at the british empire they got so
spread so thin in so many places
right and they got so worn down they
were facing conflicts in turkey and the
conflicts in india and conflict next
thing you know america you know you got
george washington's like we're gonna
kill you
right and
and so america has become super extended
i think we need to
restore
what it means to be an american
like i think we've lost i think that
term is synonymous with the wrong things
and and being a patriot is synonymous
with the wrong things and you think
patriot you think like dude riding it
jacked up side by side like whoo like
freedom like no
there is no freedom there's only free
and that's what america freedom means
that someone's affording you that to me
free is an inalienable right is is to
live like
as i see fit and fulfill my purpose and
this nation affords me that and in turn
i serve you know my country that gives
me the opportunity provides all this
infrastructure and all those kind of
things we take all that for granted and
we need to restore the message
of what it means to be an american i
don't care what political parties and
what color and your race in general i
don't care about any of those things
what it is is a common thread that made
this nation incredibly great and we've
taken it for granted and it's starting
to get frayed
and what happens is that
it's like lennon said
you give them a rope and let them pull
it around their neck and they'll hang
themselves
matter of fact they sold us the rope
and we put it around our necks and so i
hope i hope we can change i hope the
noise can quiet down because if people
got serious just
you change the world by changing
yourself
that's the thing there's not these big
grandiose ideas where i get out there
and i'm like you have this huge idea the
idea is that on the really macro scale i
change myself and when i change myself i
change the things around me and when the
people around me change themselves the
things around me change and that's how
mass change happens
um it happens inversely as well and so
you know uh change for the negative
and i think like to restore what it
means to be american to be able to walk
down the street and to be able to grab
somebody by hand to be united to uh um
to restore it kind of that that that
viewpoint of
of what's made us so great is
is the is is the common thread that runs
through the hearts of every single one
of us and and we have to put all those
things aside all these projections aside
and get back to the basics of what it
means to be a human and i think that we
can come back from this do i think we
will
i don't know um
i don't know but if we don't
um
it will happen
to us
and uh
and it will be more swift and more
violent than we could ever imagine
whether it comes from the planet or
whether it comes from another nation um
the time to change is now is right now
and and and to readjust
so
yeah and like you just said all that
starts with you yeah
whoever you are you if you're listening
to this right now
it's you it's you change and don't be
afraid to change you know we're so
attached to these outcomes like
don't be afraid to change and uh
um yeah i just like
i i i i see it in the world and i see
people like i like today on the bus i
saw all these people and i'm like
man we are so disconnected from each
other just trying to walk out the door
of the bus to the rental car company
people are shoving each other
just to get out first so they could
do what be one step in front of the
other guy
right like that's not who we are as a
nation that's what makes us different
and we gotta get we gotta get back to
those cores core values
all right this is a long one that's all
good man um
i wanna make sure so you've been
mentioning your your non-profit yeah uh
horses and heroes heroes and horses did
i get it backwards
it's heroes and horses yeah okay
heroes and horses
you can go to heroes and horses.org
is in there you also have instagram and
facebook and a youtube channel
heroes and horses all of those can be
found at the same spot
um echo you got anything
i do actually okay so a long time ago a
few hours ago you mentioned something
about an experience with a black bear
and then you just sort of moved on dang
oh good point i wanted to come back i
kind of wanted to know what what
happened with the black bear listen
wearing that look look
around your leg right now
look you know you know what's really
funny about that is i've had so many
run-ins with bears at this point in the
game i look back at that one and it and
it's kind of makes me chuckle
i mean i've had you know we had a bear
come out horse go off a cliff and
getting impaled like i mean i run into
him archery hunting all the time
and and now i'm like my black bear story
when i was like a teenager coming back
from my dark years
and this black bear like having this guy
like if i see a black bear literally in
the background i'm just like i just pick
a stick up i'm like god and he's like ah
they like take off a grizzly bear is
different
a grizzly bear is like you feel like
you're hunted but you know no what had
happened was i was out hiking um i was
kind of just like you know here i am
returning from you know this kind of
childhood uh
um you know uh i guess you could say
prodigal son kind of experience and
um i'm up there hiking and a great while
i'm sleeping out no tent a small black
bear kind of comes in and he's like
literally sniffing around he's all by me
and everything and all i had was like a
swiss army knife that i've gotten from
my grandfather he'd have the kind with a
little white toothpick he could pull out
and uh
and i have never had it and and and i
was actually very terrified at the time
uh i was like oh my god like here's this
thing i'm laying in my sleeping bag and
he's just kind of sniffing around
sniffing around he's walking around and
that's what really like i started
thinking about my life he got my food i
didn't have it wrapped up properly eats
my food
and
so anyway that experience right there
like when i came back i finished my hike
with no food it was like
a three-day hike so two nights and three
days total
and that was on my first night and that
whole time i reflected on what did i
want my life to be and so that was a
real pivotal moment in my life that that
little black bear came in and it made me
think about the fragility of my own life
um
you know in it and i'll tell you like
there's nothing more uh that feeling in
the wilderness of
the wilderness has no mercy you know it
has
only rule and only law it has no mercy
there is no equality in nature
you know and you feel that when you're
around animals and you see them and
you're with them there's a
there's an honesty that happens and you
know and i discovered that honesty
really for
um because i was a lost person you know
and i i did feel like i was invincible
and so that little black bear kind of
brought it in made me have my swiss army
knife and made me feel my own fragility
so that's what kind of led me to taking
the next step to change
well i'm gonna ask you i'm just gonna so
what happened with the grizz on the
horse falling off the cliff oh man so
because i mean i mean they're gonna ask
you now or we're gonna stop recording
i'm gonna ask you as soon as we get done
so you might as well tell everybody
otherwise everyone's gonna have to sell
it one time yeah so i was like you know
um it's like my second season packing
and um you know i got a pack string with
me and i'm in the back and a grizzly
bear kind of comes out on the trail it
comes but kind of like barreling down
most of the time the bears will stop
kind of like look sometimes they'll
stand up and then they'll usually when
they see the horses they don't like the
horses when you're alone by yourself
that is a completely different story
and
one of the guys one of the cowboys was
in front of me and he
thought he was going to kind of spook
the bear off more which was still kind
of going down the trail because he
dropped down to the next switchback
and when he did the the horse spooked
when the bear moved and he went off the
side it was very steep and the horse
kind of locked up his hindquarters and
then took a jump locked up his hind
quarters
and then there was like one huge like
douglas fir with a giant
timber or a bow sticking out that was
like pointed and when the horse leaped
you know at that kind of steep grade
it gained a lot of altitude and it
landed directly onto that thing and it
went through its stomach and out its
side
and
it would made the most horrible noise
i've ever heard a horse make in my life
and it was like
like and it was about like making this
bellowing sound the cowboy flips off
peels the head stall off the horse
everyone's like screaming like oh my god
so i'm like i like
jump off my uh my horse i just leave the
mules loose and i start like kind of
trying to get down to him and the horse
is like kicking and blood is like
pumping out it's hitting me my face i
mean it's a large animal
and uh
i'm trying to get him up off this thing
and the cowboy is kind of the head's
dazed and he's like there i was like i
need help getting this horse up we're
trying to stop the bleeding like you
know i'm like and then the horse died he
died like probably like within 10
seconds bled out i mean it was a massive
injury
and uh
there was nothing more healing than that
uh yeah so i you know
that was uh that was an intense
experience i've had him uh we had some
guys we had a guy quit uh
three years ago
bear came out barreled uh towards the
whole pack string
uh the guy that was working for me at
the time shot him
and tumbled him bear turned came at him
again hit him a second time what was he
shooting 357
that's why i carry 44 mag and i was like
oh dude the 10 mil more shots i'm like
44 mag
and
they're so the bear uh tumbles and of
course you got to call the forest
service it's this like investigation and
they came up and it was 13 feet uh the
shot was made 13 feet the bear print
from the horse so he was about he was
about to tackle the animal
um
but most of the times you know they
don't really want to bother you but you
know
you never know and the guy that quit was
like yeah and i'm good well the whole
pack string exploded okay so here comes
a grizzly bear a dead run and next thing
you know these guys are fi you know
they're on day nine on horses their
horses start bucking and you blow up and
the mules are going every i mean it's
like a yard itself this is a complete
freaking mayhem mayhem
mayhem because like i mean somebody
that's more skilled could have like got
a hold of them if you watch that film
the 500 mile project uh you know um it's
it's a great film but we had a guy uh
a mountain bike run into him and and the
horse reared back and broke his orbitals
and broke his face and um and then have
to get medevaced or whatever but things
can get sideways you know with horses
like pretty quick and uh that grizzly
bear experience was was one of those uh
but it doesn't happen often and uh you
know so by the way apply to the program
uh it's totally safe uh
almost totally well we'll protect you no
but uh it's it's a huge opportunity we
just opened applications by the way i'll
plug that real quick uh last week so
they're piling up quick
and uh you know we'll we'll close them i
think march 31st and then april 1st we
select the class so we kind of select
them along the way and that selection is
eight people
or is it there's there's three eight-man
classes and then we'll run our winner
class so we'll have 32 guys go through
the program this year
um so yeah so so applications are over
nine so go to heroesandhorses.org and
apply if you're interested in coming out
for the experience of your lifetime
right now man awesome 357 magnum no good
for for bears no it's not i mean i have
a 44 mag i'll tell you right now i've
like i've i've done so many side cut by
side comparisons with guns like 10 mils
357s i'm telling you you want that
initial knockdown power to be a wake up
call and let me tell you when a bear
runs they put their head down low to the
ground
they're not like up they're super low to
the ground and so you know a lot of
people don't realize that like they're
actually difficult to hit because
they're like when they're running at you
like that you know 30 miles an hour
they're coming in there's a lot
happening very quickly
and bears aren't scared of people
anymore the scariest thing is when i
shoot
you know when i knock an elk down
and i'm by myself and then i got you
know hit on the gps for the guys to
bring the horses or whatever and i'm out
there by myself like standing over a gut
pile
that is like the worst feeling chum in
the water man it's the worst feeling
like you want to i always build a fire
and i like make it like super big or
whatever and i try to put pine boughs
over and piss on them or do all these
like kind of things or whatever but you
want to talk about like getting in your
you know i'm doing the whole like what
was that
i'm the only one out there i'm like yeah
there's not like how long does it take
the horses to get to you uh it depends
where i'm at you know what's the longest
waited okay so have you ever slept out
on some guts no no no guys come no
matter what that would be your horse can
see at night
i always thought
listen we ride at night and it's broke i
mean things happen i mean there is no it
is what it is you're right at night you
want to find out uh you know always tell
people i said you don't know you know a
lot of people don't know this little bit
of history but i always tell them that
the the uh maybe i shouldn't say this
but the an old cowboy told me one time
that the catholic religion was actually
started in montana and it was a it was
an old outfitter looking for tree
branches at night right so
riding his horse and i always tell that
joke to the guys joking around shout out
to the pope or whatever but i
i uh
it works like if you ride you can't see
anything and you're like
it is the craziest feeling to ride all
through the night on a horse it's wild
but the horses know what's up oh they
see perfect at night no but you can't
see anything
you know and you're walking on these
like ridges and you just hear like rocks
you're like okay you're just like you're
writing a horse name like dingbat or
whatever you're like i don't know i
trust you
but they don't want to die either so
yeah heroes and horses.org i really
appreciate the opportunity uh and taking
the time you know to kind of hear the
story and stuff so thank you very much
well hey man thanks for coming on uh
you know sharing these lessons thanks
for your service and in everything that
you did and and really man i think
thanks for the most part
what you're doing right now man i think
it's awesome and um
appreciate it bro all right thanks
thanks echo
micah just stepped stepped out awesome
having him on i just was reviewing my
notes that i was taking while he was
talking
and
most of them i got to but there's one
that i didn't get to address and i'm
sure maybe come back on at some point we
can talk about it or we'll just talk
about it but
you remember he told the story or he was
he's making hypothetical situation
warren buffett is in the desert he has
no water
and
micah sees him
and micah has water yeah
and warren buffett's gonna die
and he says you know
i'll give you this water but you have to
give me all of your money
and and and micah says so he's gonna do
it right and that's
true
often
but
here's the crazy thing
there are people
whose ego
will not allow them to make that trade
they would actually rather die
i know that sounds crazy sounds a little
bit inconceivable let me tell you how
it's not inconceivable
in
what leif wrote about
with the with a situation with a uh
a
special operations unit
that
was going to conduct an operation
and leif talked to some
national guard guys that were saying do
not do that operation leif goes and
gives that information to the special
operations unit that was going to go do
it
and those guys were like no we're going
and those
the the national guide guard guys they
don't know how to handle i forget what
the exact wording but we don't need to
listen to them
instead we're going to go do this
mission
and so we have to keep in mind
that ego is so strong
that if you have a guy now look warren
buffett might be a guy who's you know
led his eagle he's an older guy maybe
he's got enough life experiences to be
like oh i want to live that's more
important to me but i guarantee you
there are some individuals that would
rather die than admit that they're wrong
they'd rather die than take help from
someone else they'd rather die than ask
for help
so
that was just one little
thing that i thought about as
and unfortunately you know i took the
note and then i didn't get to get to
bring it up with
with micah but
that is something to think about you
don't realize how powerful
a negative force an ego can be yeah i i
was thinking the same thing
too at that time there's a movie
like kind of new i think where it had
kevin spacey in it and then before they
released it they replaced them because
there was a kevin spacey scandal already
do you know what movie i'm talking about
it's uh something about the
i want to say the gatsby i don't know i
don't know i don't know what movie but
it was basically a famous rich guy um
is in the movie or that's the movie's
about both okay both um it's i don't
know yeah so it's about a real it's like
kind of like a true story or something
okay i think if i'm not mistaken i'm
only gathering like pieces of it but
it's basically about uh this super duper
rich guy um they i want to say they
kidnap his son or something like that or
the daughter or something and they're
like hey basically like you know held
them for ransom or like give us this
money or whatever and the guy and it was
no money for this guy like it was not
that much and he was in the oh yeah i
think it's like on the news or something
he's like oh so what are you going to do
he's like i don't care i don't care like
there's no way he would give money it
was that it was like that
that much you know where yeah i can lose
a son like whatever it's like the in
it's not like and i'm totally trying to
remember the thing but it wasn't it
wasn't like oh i can't afford it or it
was it was more about the prince yeah
yeah like like no no no i'm not giving
that much money no one can do that to me
kind of a thing like i'm not even
meanwhile like you know kind of a real
important thing you know the son or the
grandson or something like that but yeah
i i thought that same thing too i said i
get i get the example because it's true
it is true it's kind of true it's
basically like like saying without your
health you have nothing you know like
you can't you can't bring your money to
the grave like it's true it's true but
there are these weirdo little exceptions
where it's like that doesn't matter to
some some people yeah that ego gets that
ego starts to get charged up man it's um
it can be
it can definitely be a scary
thing so it's like and you might even
said this before where ego is
essentially like a like a drug that you
can you know some people like they'll oh
they'll just take drugs till they die
yeah like
ego will kill you that's an example yeah
yeah exactly it's like that thing you
know people will smoke cigarettes like
so much and they'll be like hey the
thing that i said was your ego will love
you to death
your ego will love you to death there
you go just like drugs will love you
dude like drugs love you yeah and i took
this from j i think if i remember this
correctly jay adams who is a old-school
skateboarder
dirt
like dog town z boys
and i heard him saying drugs will love
you to death yeah because you know he
had a bun he had problems with addiction
and went to jail and all this stuff and
i actually met him and kind of hung out
with him a little bit
i was my friend
my friend uh ran an underground
scape downhill skateboarding
uh
uh event
not just one but like a regular basis
yeah and and it was like hey we're gonna
meet at this random mountain that just
got freshly paved
like the state just freshly paved some
mountain yeah and we're gonna meet out
there and do downhill races have you
ever been on a downhill skateboard uh
i've been on a downhill skateboard yes
okay
i've i said oh i'll try what this is
like or whatever
i got on a downhill skateboard i went
20 feet and i was already going so fast
i i did i jumped off
because i could see where this was going
it wasn't a good place i don't have the
skill set to be doing this yeah guys
race in leathers
yeah like like uh motorcycle racing
leathers they race in those things
so i kind of so at any at one of these
underground events
jay adams rest in peace was there and
you know i got to shake his hand and i
didn't get a picture
that's a bad move actually well how long
ago was it
um
10 years 10 years ago maybe 10 years
maybe even a little bit longer
you should have got a picture and then
pictures are available at that time
because if it's like 1991 or oh no no
this was this was recent this was like
you know i was a grown man trying to get
on a downhill skateboard dude those guys
are freaking crazy
yes sir yes they are bombing hills yeah
bombing hills you're on escape this
isn't on the snow or the water yeah like
you fall in the snow look you can get
hurt on the snow for sure yeah you can
get hurt on the water you notice there's
a key word there canned
you can get hurt on the water you can
get hurt on the snow
if you fall in a freaking downhill
skateboard you're getting hurt
interestingly they don't
they wear leathers they know how to fall
better or whatever yeah i think i think
a lot of times especially in
skateboarding in general that you just
get hurt and i think those guys are kind
of just used to it for sure you know
unless you break like your ankle your
wrist or whatever or whatever break
whatever
either hurt or you're injured so
skateboard is just used to getting hurt
let's face it bro you get you get
especially on the downhill right where
you gotta bail or whatever and you're
sliding oh you're sliding
what are you hitting something's gonna
stop you you know
so jay adams said drugs will love you to
death and as soon as i heard him say
that i was like uh yeah you know what
also we'll love you to death your own
ego your own ego will love you to death
so you got to watch out for it yep yeah
like the the the short-term payoff of
what it delivers to you is just so makes
you feel so good or safe or secure or
whatever get that little hitter that
like yeah i mean well your
your health your safety your well-being
you got to be careful that well hey uh
this has already been a really long
podcast appreciate everyone for
listening if you want to support the
podcast go to jockofield.com get some
get some supplements of whatever kind
you may need
jockofield.com we also have look we
talked a little bit about china today
china
we talked a little bit about china
we are
we are in an economic war with china for
the time being could it escalate yes it
could if we lose the economic war trust
me the escalation is going to be real
bad
so we're in a economic war with china
right now
and at origin usa we are on the front
lines of that war
we are building stuff in america
the things that micah was talking about
today you know a sense of purpose when
you when you're not making anything you
don't have look
let me rephrase that
when you are making something
producing something building something
you have a sense of purpose
and when you're building something
that's helping rebuild your community
you have an even greater sense of
purpose
so if you want to help us
rebuild
our communities help us rebuild our
country help provide a sense of purpose
to hundreds
and one day thousands
of hard-working americans
then check out originusa.com
get awesome stuff that's made in america
yeah i think that that concept kind of
probably goes deeper than maybe we might
think at a glance where you know how
like you know as technology evolves and
all like all this other stuff or
whatever you know basically it's just an
it's an evolution of problems being
solved so the smaller problems get
solved just so you can take on bigger
problems right and they then we have
innovation and you know all this stuff
invention
like back in the day right you have
these simple tools a stick a rock you
know and you're making like you're
spending five days making this one thing
that literally you can buy at 7-eleven
nowadays right like that kind of stuff
but back then
it's just how it worked it's like yeah
bro if you want to fire bro it's going
to take a lot to make that fire then
after you make that fire it provides the
warmth and the heat and you can cook for
you and your family and all this stuff
so it's like this little system that
kind of works together
but then
when you start inventing things that
fire part making the fire apart becomes
really inconvenient like we got to focus
on this bigger problem here that making
that fire takes like freaking i don't
know 35 45 minutes that maybe would help
us in this bigger problem if we could
just do that in an instant so let's
solve that problem indefinite on an
indefinite level you know so boom we saw
that problem now you got lighters
matches whatever right
i'm sure it didn't happen in that order
but i'm just saying for example but it
just keeps going and going and going and
going so we got a bunch of problems
solved for us now yes all kinds of
problems yes but now the problems become
you know what's that hierarchy it's like
some yeah hierarchy right hierarchy of
needs so now technology
kind of like exploded so fast so now it
ended us up on that that higher part of
the hierarchy or the needs right
but technology has it right now it's not
good enough to solve those problems so
now you got people depressed or whatever
that's what i'm saying
so now yeah if you we can infuse little
little scent sprinkles of senses of
purpose into all of our lives really i
think that's going to be the beginning
of the uh the solution
yeah but it was just kind of like how
michael was saying where
you kind of got to go down to the
the baseline a little bit to explore
like where can i infuse some of the
purpose in that baseline then your life
it just as a whole would be more
more beneficial more fulfilling or
whatever yeah i think fulfilling is the
word yeah like you'll you'll feel more
purpose like just in your day-to-day you
know
just how it works but or i think it
works like that check
um so originusa.com cool awesome to
support get it get whatever you need
there also we got jocklestore.com which
echo nate made up the name for very
original yeah because we have a store no
i think i i accepted the name for oh see
i think did i name it literally made it
up you know what actually now that you
mentioned no you actually said to me
like hey
i'm going to start us a store i was like
oh what's it going to be called i didn't
think i asked that was probably like
three days later you're like hey i set
up the store okay cool yeah
you like we'll look at the website and i
go okay cool what's the website you're
like a jockless door you know what's
funny like i'm remembering it and you're
correct exactly right i don't know you
could tell me anything right now and i'd
believe you if you're like no you
imposed it on me or no you said
you know your idea is dumb josh or you
said you know jocko you wanted to name
the store something lame and then i came
up i would believe whatever you said yes
sir because i remember it i am
remembering it now
and it's weird because
it's not like i was like hey what's the
best kind of name for this or that or
you know how to make this it was
just like it was just kind of like a
foregone conclusion like i didn't even
really think of it i was like oh let's
just do the thing this is just just how
you know
podcast so you gotta have a store so
chocolate store nonetheless on jocko's
store
you can get your uh apparel
shirts hats hoodies good stuff if you
want to represent on this path that
we're on subscribe to the podcast
subscribe to our youtube channel all
that stuff we appreciate it check out
check out jockowunderground.com look
there's a lot of influential things
going on out there in the world people
are getting banned whatever
not whatever really yeah straight up
some of us got shadow band did you get
shadow band
i don't know i i don't know it's kind of
like
there are people that i follow that i
know when they're shadow band because
i'm like you know how you kind of miss
it like you're like oh i haven't heard
from this person when they're not
posting and they've been and you even
try to look them up and their their name
that's the thing the name don't that's
the video that someone sent me was there
searching for my name and it's not up
there yeah look we don't know what's
gonna happen we don't know who's in
control of these platforms they seem to
be being okay sometimes but sometimes
we're getting shadow banned so go to
jockonground.com if you want to help us
out on that
psychological warfare you know the deal
on that flip side canvas dakota meyer
got cool stuff to hang on your wall
i've written a bunch of books if you
want to check them out there's some
information in them that could help you
especially the kids books man get the
kids some books and also have a
leadership consulting company
go to ashlandfront.com if you want some
details on that check out our our online
training academy
our online training academy extreme
ownership.com putting all kinds of
effort
the lessons that the lessons that we
learned are so helpful
we this is what we hear all day long
every day i get emails i get handwritten
letters we get updates
utilizing the skills that we brought
back the leadership skills
the life skills
if you want to get in the game go to
extreme ownership.com and check it out
yeah it's funny that that academy
because you have it under echelon front
you know with you know and i always
looked at it or kind of imagined it as
essentially oh this is what you you know
if you work and or if you manage a team
you're a boss or something like that oh
yeah perfect freaking perfect really
but when you kind of look into it and
you kind of go on there and stuff this
is really what it is where it's like
okay yeah sure i listen to jocko you
know sometimes
involuntarily against my will whatever
but let's say i volunteer i listen to
jocko and you know what he has some good
advice you know and actually if i'm
going to tell the truth here
where if i listen to
and by the way you kind of choose what
you put in your head and what you listen
to right so we choose to listen to you
most of the time sure
so now jocko with all this advice or
whatever he actually has
an online academy like to train you
that's literally what it is it is
like okay so and i kind of took it for
granted where i can ask you questions
like when i see you it's easy i can
literally call you up if you answer
you've asked me a lot of questions over
the years yes if you think about it now
i'm not talking about questions about
how to do a camera which you have asked
me but i'm talking you come in with a
legitimate scenario yeah business narrow
family scenario i need advice straight
up straight up just the other last time
i saw you i asked i asked you what do
you think about this i'm thinking about
this or this and i need like straight up
legitimately need advice for me right
now did i give you good advice yes i
think so i'm following it i'll tell you
that it's working right now so far
i guess it was more of a long-term
decision-making course well then we're
probably thinking it's the right move
because you probably weren't thinking no
offense you may not have been thinking
long term yeah a lot of us make that
mistake we think short term yeah about
what plays out i was it's like one of
those things where you know how you make
this decision to pursue this it's going
to put this other thing on hold for a
long time or
you can pursue the other one and it'll
put this one on hold
either indefinitely or for a long time
so it's like which one is it the advice
i gave you is very good by the way i i
agree yeah and even when you said it it
cl it hit me so quickly that yep you i
think you're right you know that's a
good call so if you didn't know me yeah
if you weren't if we didn't hang out if
we weren't doing jiu jitsu if we weren't
doing the podcast and you had that
question
you could go to extreme ownership.com
and literally ask me and i would give
you the same advice exactly right and
that's get some more particulars maybe
your scenario is different maybe your
area of operation is different but
essentially you'd get at least now does
this mean i'm going to preach to you
that i know 100 no but i would help you
way through the options which is what i
did with you right yeah exactly right
and that's exactly what i was going to
say
that's exactly what it is you know where
you and then of course you know you you
have a bunch of other experts in little
little special specialty
elements of life or whatever as well but
yeah that's what it is yeah you want to
you want to get
straight up life advice from jacqueline
you want to get straight up online
training from jacob there it is boom you
got it right there extreme ownership.com
hey if you also if you want to help out
service members active and retired you
want to help other families go to mark
lee's mom she's got an awesome charity
organization
called america's mighty warriors you can
go to americasmightywarriors.org
she's doing a ton of help a ton of help
that i've seen with my own eyes my
friends have gotten help from her
so
it's a great organization also obviously
check out heroes and horses.org
micah in case you couldn't tell he's a
freaking awesome guy with an awesome
vision
and he's moving forward with that
if you want any more of my
torturous tales
or you need more of
echo's discombobulating
disclosures can find them on the wood
you can find us on the interwebs on
twitter on instagram on facebook echo is
at equity charles i am at jacqueline
does this mean we want you to go in
there and waste time
freaking getting sucked into the
algorithm no don't do that
you want to check out you want to hit us
with something you want to give a shout
out cool we appreciate it you want to
get a little
information about what we're doing cool
don't get sucked into the algorithm
the
so listen and i my brain mind and i'm
sure a lot of people do the same thing
where it does this thing where anytime i
listen to like micah or
you know anytime pretty much anyone's
story and you hear those cool little
parts of it where it's like oh man i
need to take away the computer from my
kids from now on you know it's like you
get sucked into a story so much like
it's so um
what do you call like so engaging that
you kind of
like i kind of want to be a bow hunter
now you know it's like that kind of
giving john dudley a call that's what
i'm saying when he's talking i'm like
dang maybe i miss my calling from you
know for bow hunting yeah even though
i'd be out there in the woods with the
with the grizz i literally shot one bow
in my life one time by the way and it
was pretty recently but nonetheless i
still had that feeling assumed saying
because you see you get so immersed in
like the story or whatever then he was
talking about like the social media and
i felt it i was like yeah you're right
social media is so toxic but the reality
is
it can be toxic
and it can be very beneficial like you
would you know i know i'm you know you
can be in communication with very
valuable people for very good reasons
i've gotten through
we've probably gotten
30 guests on this podcast
legit awesome guest freaking so stoked
from social media oh yeah so
that's definitely and it's and it is a
legitimate way to communicate with other
people
it doesn't mean you have to get in the
algorithm
so it's there we're there and also
heroes and horses
at heroes and horses you can check out
the instagram the facebook the youtube
go check out the youtube a bunch of the
things that that micah talked about
today he kept g hey we made this film we
made that film go check those things out
they're they're really cool to watch i
watched them
and uh
yep so there we are micah
really appreciate you coming down really
appreciate your service in the military
and out of the military and once again
thank you for what you
are continuing to do to help out vets
and
it's going to have a huge impact so
thanks brother and to our active duty
military
and our veterans out there
thank you for your service and remember
you got a lot to offer even when that
layer comes off
even when that layer comes off
of the uniform and the military when
that uniform comes off you still have a
ton to offer so go out find a mission
find yourself that's where it starts
and also thanks to our police and law
enforcement firefighters paramedics emts
dispatchers correctional officers border
patrol secret service
and all first responders
thanks for what you do and remember just
like the military
what you do is not necessarily who you
are you have more than your uniform
so remember that
and to everybody else
let's follow the words we heard today
quoted
from micah from alexander the great
who said
bury me with my hands out of the ground
so the world can see that i left it with
nothing
let's leave it all in the field
by going out there
every
day and getting after it
until next time
zecko and jocko